WE'RE GONNA CALL THE.
.
COMMITTEE OF HIGHER EDUCATION TO
ORDER. AND.
SINCE WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM
WILL BEGIN.
A AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
SO GOOD AFTERNOON.
.
PLEASE NOTE THAT FILE ITEM
ELEVEN.
AB TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY SIX.
HAS BEEN PULLED FROM THE AGENDA
BY THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR.
ALSO KNOW THAT OUR GUIDANCE FOR
BILLS HEARD AND COMMITTEE TODAY.
OUR GUIDELINE FOR BUILD CERTAIN
COMMITTEE TODAY IS TO ALLOW
TESTIMONY FOR TWO WITNESSES FOR
SUPPORT.
TWO WITNESSES FOR THE OPPOSITION
TO SPEAK EACH FOR TWO MINUTES.
HOWEVER IF YOU'RE ABLE TO KEEP
YOUR TIME DOWN TO FOUR MINUTES
YOU CAN DIVIDE YOUR TIME AMONG
YOUR OTHER WITNESSES.
I WILL ALSO CALL FOR TWEENER.
TESTIMONIES
THOSE NEITHER IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF THE MEASURES.
LASTLY I WANT TO PUBLICLY THANK.
CHUCK NICKEL FOR HIS HARD WORK
AND DEDICATION TO THE COMMITTEE.
CHUCK AS RETIRED AND YOU
WOULDN'T
SERVE THE LAST FEW MONTHS AS A
PRISON BOTH PRINCIPAL CONSULTANT
TO THIS COMMITTEE.
TODAY'S CHUCK'S LAST HEARING
WITH THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
LEGISLATION SESSION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH JACK FOR ALL YOUR
WORK.
AND WITH THAT WILL BRING UP.
GRAY.
FILE ITEM FOR.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO OH TWO.
WELCOME MR GRAY.
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS.
LET ME START BY KNOWLEDGE IN THE
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH ME ON THIS BILL AS
WE CONTINUE TO DEVELOP.
AND REFINE ARE EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION OPPORTUNITIES IN THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY.
THANK YOU FOR.
THE ONGOING DISCUSSION ALLOWING
THIS ONGOING DISCUSSION TO TAKE
PLACE TO EXPLORE CREATIVE
OPPORTUNITIES TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES WALL ALWAYS PRIORITIZING
THE HEALTH AND WELFARE OF THE
PEOPLE I REPRESENT.
AB TWENTY TWO A CHU APPROPRIATES
IN UNSPECIFIED AMOUNT OF MONEY
TO THE REGENTS OF THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA.
FOR THE CREATION CONSTRUCTION
AND ESTABLISHMENT OF THE UCSF
MEDICAL SCHOOL BRANCH CAMPUS IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH UC MERCED AND
UCSF FRESNO.
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN THE STATE
BUDGET DIRECTED YOU SEE THE
COMPLETE ANALYSIS OF THE PROCESS
TO CREATE A MEDICAL SCHOOL AT
MERCED CAMPUS.
DO YOU SEE RECENTLY RELEASED
THEIR COMPLETED ANALYSIS WHICH
PROVIDES AN OVERVIEW OF THE
HEALTH NEEDS OF THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY. A TIMELINE OF COMPLETED
MILESTONES TOWARDS THE CREATION
OF THE MEDICAL SCHOOL.
AND ECONOMIC ANALYSIS OF THE
UNIQUE CHALLENGES AND
OPPORTUNITIES FACING THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY MEDICAL SCHOOL
BRANCH CAMPUS.
THE ADEQUACY IS OF THE SAMPLE
CAN DOLLARS HEALTH CARE ARE
INFRASTRUCTURE ARE WELL
DOCUMENTED.
AS THE UC'S REPORT HIGHLIGHTS
THE VALLEY'S ONE OF THE FASTEST
GROWING POOREST AND LEAST
HEALTHY REGIONS OF THE STATE.
AND HAS A LONGSTANDING SHORTAGE
OF PHYSICIANS AND OTHER
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS.
WE HAVE THE LOWEST RATIO OF
LICENSE DANDIES DE OWES AND PEAS
ARE ENDS MARRIAGE AND FAMILY
THERAPIST LICENSE COUNSELORS AND
LICENSE SOCIAL WORKERS IN THE
STATE.
DO YOU SEE REPORT IS ONLY THE
LATEST IN A TWO DECADE EFFORT TO
LEVERAGE STATE ASSISTANCE FOR
THE BUILD OUT OF MEDICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE VALLEY.
A FULLY INDEPENDENT MEDICAL
SCHOOL YOU SEE HER SAID WAS
BEING DISCUSSED BEFORE THE
UNDERGRADUATE CAMPUS EVEN BEGIN
CONSTRUCTION.
A TWO THOUSAND EIGHT REPORT BY
THE WASHINGTON ADVISORY GROUP
KNOWN AS THE WAG REPORT
ENVISIONED A UC MERCED MEDICAL
SCHOOL UP AND RUNNING BY TWENTY
TWELVE.
AS THE STATE GRAPPLE WITH THE
EFFECTS OF THE RECESSION SHORTLY
AFTER THE WAG REPORT WAS
PUBLISHED FEW OF ITS
RECOMMENDATIONS WERE EVER
IMPLEMENTED.
HAVING GONE THROUGH A DIFFICULT
LCB LICENSING PROCESS AT UC
RIVERSIDE MEDICAL SCHOOL DO YOU
SEE IN STATE HAVE LEARNED A
GREAT DEAL ABOUT WHAT IT TAKES
TO CITE A NEW MEDICAL SCHOOL.
WITH A MULTI BILLION DOLLAR
SURPLUS
STATE IS IN A STRONG FINANCIAL
POSITION TO DEDICATE THE
NECESSARY RESOURCES TO ADDRESS
ONE OF THE STATE'S MOST
PRESSING.
AND MOST IGNORED PROBLEMS.
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF MEDICAL
SCHOOL BRANCH CAMPUS THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH YOU SEE A STAFF. UC MERCED
AND UCSF FRESNO WELL NOW THE
TRAINING OF MEDICAL STUDENTS WHO
WERE BORN AND RAISED IN THE
REGION. AND WHO HAVE ROOTS THAT
WILL ENCOURAGE THEM TO PRACTICE
MEDICINE CLOSE TO HOME.
THIS STEP WILL PROVIDE IMMEDIATE
RETURN OF FUNNELING DOCTORS INTO
THE REGION WHILE PROVIDING TIME
FOR THE YOU SEE TO DEVELOP A
TRULY COMPELLING. AND INNOVATIVE
PROPOSAL FOR A FULLY INDEPENDENT
MEDICAL SCHOOL YOU SEE MERCED.
IN ORDER TO ADVANCE THIS CONCEPT
THE LEGISLATURE MUST PROVIDE
FINANCIAL CERTAINTY. A VARIABLE
WHICH INITIALLY STALLED. THE
ACCREDITATION OF THE UC
RIVERSIDE MEDICAL SCHOOL ONE OF
THE CHAIRS ALL TOO FAMILIAR WITH
THAT.
AB TWENTY TWO A TO SEEKS TO
PROVIDE THIS FINANCIAL CERTAINTY
EITHER THROUGH A LARGE ONE TIME
APPROPRIATION TO CREATE ANNUAL
ENDOWMENT. OR THROUGH GUARANTEED
ONGOING FUNDING THROUGH THE
BUDGET.
THIS CONTINUES TO BE A WORK IN
PROGRESS AND COMMITMENT MEMBERS
WILL NOTICE THE BILL CURRENTLY
LEAVES THE APPROPRIATION BLANK
AS A RESULT.
DIFFICULT AS IT MIGHT BE.
WE MUST CONTINUE TO MOVE THIS
DISCUSSION FOR IT IS THE VALLEY
IS BEEN THE VICTIM OF DELAYS FOR
TOO LONG.
THE BILL IS SUPPORTED BY MERCED
COUNTY THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS
AMONGST OTHERS.
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION HOWEVER
THE UC HAS RAISED A NUMBER OF
CONCERNS WHICH WE MUST WORK TO
ADDRESS.
IN PARTICULAR THE UC IS RAISED
THE CONCERN THAT PREMATURE
ACTION TO ESTABLISH A BRANCH
CAMPUS COULD RESULT IN THE
TRIGGERING A BELL CME REVIEW. AT
A TIME WHEN OUR RESOURCES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE NOT PREPARED TO
MEET THE REVIEW STANDARDS.
WITH A FAILED REVIEW DOES NOT DO
A PROJECT IN PERPETUITY EACH
FAILURE DOES MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT THE NEXT TIME AROUND.
IS NOT MY INTENTION.
THAT THE BILL.
PREMATURELY FORCE ELSIE MAYER
VIEW ON COMMITTED TO ADDRESS
THAT CONCERN HOWEVER HEALTHCARE
ACCESS IN THE VALLEY HAS NOT
BEEN A PRIORITY AT THE STATE
LEVEL FOR TOO LONG. AND I'M
EQUALLY COMMITTED TO SPOTLIGHT
SPOTLIGHTING THIS ISSUE AND
KEEPING A HEAVY FOOT ON THE GAS
I HAVE WITH ME TODAY DOCTOR
PETER BROADRICK WIFE NO AND.
FOR MANY YEARS AND HAS BEEN
INVOLVED REALLY SINCE THE
INCEPTION OF THE EFFORT TO
ESTABLISH A MEDICAL SCHOOL IN
THE VALLEY A TO PROVIDE SOME.
HISTORICAL CONTEXT AND.
IS AN EXCEPTION KNOWLEDGE OF
FIRST ON THE SUBJECT DR.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMAN GRAY AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON
HIGHER EDUCATION I'M DOCTOR
PETER BRODERICK.
AND I'M PLEASED TO. KNOW
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY TWO OH TO.
I'M THE FORMER CEO OF VALLEY
CONSORTIUM FOR MEDICAL
EDUCATION.
WHERE I WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN
STARTING CALIFORNIA'S FIRST
TEACHING HEALTH CENTER?
AND IN THAT CAPACITY WELL I
STILL SERVICES IN ORGANIZATIONAL
AND.
INSTITUTIONAL ORGANIZATIONAL
OFFICER FOR THE ACCREDITATION
THEIR.
I'M ALSO THE DIRECTOR OF
UNDERGRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION
FOR SUTTER MEDICAL GROUP WHERE I
OVERSEE OUR MED STUDENT
TRAINING.
FOR THE NORTH CENTRAL VALLEY
I'VE BEEN INVOLVED IN MEDICAL
EDUCATION SINCE NINETEEN NINETY.
AND HAVE. BEEN.
PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR TO
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY SO FROM THIS
PERSPECTIVE I CAN ATTEST. BOTH
TO THE DIRE NEED.
TO EXPAND MEDICAL EDUCATION AND
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AS WELL AS
THE BENEFIT.
AND THAT I THINK A CREATING A
CENTRAL VALLEY HUB FOR MEDICAL
EDUCATION WOULD HAVE. IN THE
PROPOSED FUNDING THROUGH AB
TWENTY TWO OO TO.
I KNOW YOU'RE WELL AWARE OF THE
HEALTH.
CHALLENGES OF THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IN TERMS OF HEALTH CARE
DISPARITIES HEALTH OUTCOMES AND.
PROVIDER.
A SCARCITY IN FACT IN OUR.
SUCCESSFUL FEDERAL GRANT WE
CHARACTERIZE A CENTRAL VALLEY IS
THE NEW APPELLATION.
IT BE IN TERMS OF HEALTH CARE.
ISSUES YEAH. IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT.
I WAS INVOLVED IN THE
WASHINGTON ADVISORY GROUP PANEL
TO DISCUSS THE BENEFIT.
OF A MEDICAL SCHOOL.
THE IMPACT THAT WOULD HAVE IT
YOU SEE MERCED ITS HORRORS.
PRODUCING.
.
MORE STUDENTS IN OUR REGION
THAT CAME FROM OUR REGION AND
MODESTO WE ACTUALLY. IN RESPONSE
CREATED.
EXPANDED POSITIONS FROM TWENTY
SEVEN RESIDENTS TO FIFTY ONE
RESIDENTS CURRENTLY IN
ANTICIPATION SO WERE TRYING TO
GET READY FOR THE EXPANSION. WAS
A FORMER PROGRAM DIRECTOR I'M
WELL AWARE OF THE. BENEFIT OF
HER TRACK OF THE RECRUITING.
STUDENTS WHO COME FROM OUR AREA
WE KNOW THAT. WHEN THEY COME
FROM OUR AREA WE OFTEN RETAIN
THEM IN OUROUR EXPERIENCES
SIMILAR TO FRESNO ABOUT HALF OF
OUR. GRADUATES STAY IN THE
REGION WHICH HAS BEEN REALLY
TREMENDOUS FOR US.
AND THE TRUTH IS HAVING A HUB
OF MEDICAL EDUCATION IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY I THINK WILL
ENHANCE OUR CALIBER AND OUR
ABILITY TO REALLY ATTRACT LOCAL
TALENT.
NOW YOU KNOW TRAINING THEM
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY HELPS THEM
STAY WITHIN THE COMMUNITY.
CALIFORNIA IS A NET EXPORTER OF
MEDICAL STUDENTS I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU KNOW THE HOT.
WE SEND THEM OUT AND BRING THEM
BACK AFTER ALL THEIR TRAINING.
IT IT'S A SHAME BECAUSE THERE
DISCONNECTED TO THE LOCATION
WHERE THEY TRAIN THEM. OUT WE
KNOW THAT IF WE TRAIN.
STUDENTS ARE PARTICULARLY IN
RESIDENCY THEY TEND TO STAY IN
THAT LOCATION MORE AND CERTAINLY
CREATING A PIPELINE THAT
IDENTIFIES TALENTED REGIONAL
UNDERGRADUATES.
FOSTER'S THEM TO BECOME
COMPETITIVE MEDICAL STUDENT
CANDIDATES.
SUPPORTS THEM THROUGH.
AFFORDABLE.
AND MEDICAL EDUCATION AND ALSO
THROUGH GEOGRAPHIC.
TRAINING IN RESIDENCY I THINK
WILL CREATE A SOLUTION FOR SOME
OF THE CHALLENGES WE HAVE BY
TRAINING AND RETAINING OUR
STUDENTS.
CERTAINLY WHERE OF FACING SOME
REAL CHALLENGES WITH.
THE AGING MARROW PHYSICIAN
POPULATION I'VE MYSELF TURNED
FIFTY SEVEN SO I'M AMONG THE
GROUP OVER FIFTY FIVE WHO.
ARE SET TO RETIRE IN THE NEXT
TEN YEARS AND WE ARE NOT
REPLACING THE NUMBER OF
PHYSICIANS THAT ARE RETIRING.
THE PROPOSED MECHANISM OF AB
TWENTY TWO A TO ADD BY CREATING
A BRANCH CAMPUS OF UCSF AT UC
MERCED. OF FOR BAY BASIC SCIENCE
EDUCATION AS WELL AS THE
REGIONAL TRAINING THEY CAN GET
CLINICALLY IN THIS IN THE VALLEY
PARTICULARLY AT UCSF FRESNO.
I THINK THAT WILL BE A MODEL AND
HAS BEEN A MODEL THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA HAS USED
SUCCESSFULLY. IN FACT.
GERMAN MEDINA I WAS.
UC RIVERSIDE UNDERGRADUATE I
WAS ATTRACTED TO UC RIVERSIDE
BECAUSE OF ITS BRANCH CAMPUS
STATUS WITH UCLA. ALTHOUGH I
CHOSE TO GO TO MEDICAL SCHOOL
UCSF I WAS IMPRESSED. BY THE
CALIBER OF STUDENTS THAT THE
SCHOOL ATTRACTED I THINK BECAUSE
OF ITS BRANCH CAMPUS IDENTITY.
AND I DO BELIEVE THAT THAT
IDENTITY WILL HELP YOU SEE
MERCED IN RECRUITMENT AS WELL.
SOME. THAT THE TRUTH IS THAT.
IN.
TERMS OF QUALITY OF MEDICAL
EDUCATION.
THE CLINICAL CAMPUS AT UCSF
FRESNO IS.
ON PAR WITH ALL THE MAJOR
MEDICAL SCHOOLS.
I MYSELF AS A MEDICAL STUDENT
AT UCSF SPENT SEVERAL MONTHS IN
FRESNO DOING MY CLINICAL
TRAINING AS PART OF MY COMMUNITY
BASED CURRICULUM. AND IT WAS THE
FIRST TIME I SAW SOME OF THE
HEALTH CARE CHALLENGES OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. AND ACTUALLY
THAT IMPACTFUL EXPERIENCE MADE
ME WANT TO PURSUE FAMILY
MEDICINE TRAINING. IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND THEN I WENT
ON TO PRACTICE IN A SMALL TOWN
CALLED TO SIN.
ABOUT SIX THOUSAND PEOPLE
BETWEEN MERCED IN MODESTO.
CERTAINLY IN IN TERMS OF.
.
V. AB TWENTY TWO OR TWO IT IS A
AND IT IS PART OF A MULTI
PRONGED APPROACH CERTAINLY WE
NEED TO GROW. UP A POSTGRADUATE
RESIDENCY TRAINING PROGRAMS BUT
HAVING A PIPELINE OF GOOD
STUDENTS
IT WILL HELP US DO THAT.
I THINK BY CREATING.
UCSF FRESNO CAMPUS.
THAT KEEPS THE CALIBER VERY
HIGH THE ACADEMIC CREDENTIALS
ARE IMPECCABLE IN AND CERTAINLY
I THINK AS WE PRODUCE A LARGER
PIPELINE WE CAN GROW OUR MEDICAL
EDUCATION BOTH.
UNDERGRADUATE AND POSTGRADUATE
AND HOPEFULLY RETAIN MORE
PHYSICIANS AND HAVE A BENEFICIAL
IMPACT ON. THE REGION WHICH IS
REALLY IN DIRE NEED OF ATTENTION
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY. WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ANY
WITNESSES.
IN BETWEEN THERE ANY TWEENER.
BRING UP THE TWO WINNERS.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ANGELA GILLIARD I
REPRESENT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. I'M WE'RE HERE TODAY
TO EXPRESS OUR CONCERNS IS
ASSEMBLYMAN GRAY. ALLUDED TO.
AND.
I'M I'M HERE I AM ACCOMPANIED
TODAY BY MIKE PETERSON.
ARE FROM YOU SEE IS EFFORT PHOTO
WHO IS A.
AB WILL INTRODUCE HIMSELF AND
DISCUSS OUR CONCERNS IN MORE
DETAIL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
APPEAR BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY.
AS ANGELA SAID I'M MICHAEL
PETERSON LIVE THE PRIVILEGE
CURRENTLY OF SERVING AS THE
CURRENT ASSOCIATE DEAN FOR THE
UC SFS NO MEDICAL EDUCATION
PROGRAM.
THIS LEGISLATURE.
ESTABLISHED OUR CAMPUS FORTY
THREE YEARS AGO TO ADDRESS THE
PHYSICIAN SHORTAGE IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT WE'VE
GRADUATED WELL OVER TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED PHYSICIANS AND CURRENTLY
HAVE OVER THREE HUNDRED
RESIDENTS AND FELLOWS IN OUR
PROGRAM.
AND WE RETAIN AS NOTED EARLIER
BY PETER FIFTY PERCENT OF THEM
IN THE VALLEY THE CENTRAL VALLEY
TOGETHER WITH THE INLAND EMPIRE
REMAIN THE MOST POSITION
UNDERSERVED AREAS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
WE HIGHLY VALUE ASSEMBLYMAN
GRAYS AND OTHER LEGISLATORS
INTEREST IN EXPANDING MEDICAL
EDUCATION ESPECIALLY FOR MEDICAL
STUDENTS FROM AND INTERESTED IN
RETURNING TO THE VALLEY TO
PRACTICE.
TOGETHER WITH YOU SEE US OUT
FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT. WE EMBARKED ON A TWO
YEAR PLANNING PROCESS TO DEVELOP
A PATHWAY TOWARDS A FULL UCSF
BRANCH CAMPUS AND ULTIMATELY AN
INDEPENDENT MEDICAL SCHOOL IN
THE VALLEY.
THE FIRST STEP IS TO ESTABLISH
AN ACCREDITED BRANCH CAMPUS TO
THE LIAISON COMMITTEE FOR
MEDICAL EDUCATION THE LCM ME.
THE BODY THAT REVIEWS AND
APPROVES ALL ALLOPATHIC THAT IS
MD GRANTING MEDICAL SCHOOLS IN
THE COUNTRY.
OUR APPLICATION TO THE LCM IS
BASED ON THE ROBUST MEDICAL
EDUCATION INFRASTRUCTURE
CURRENTLY AVAILABLE AT UCSF
FRESNO.
THE LCM IS CURRENTLY REVIEWING
OUR APPLICATION.
WHILE WE ENTHUSIASTICALLY SIX
SUPPORT EXPANDING OUR ABILITY TO
TRAIN PHYSICIANS FOR THE VALLEY.
WE DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS WITH AB
TWENTY TWO OH TWO AS NOTED BY
ASSEMBLYMAN GRAY.
FIRST INCLUDING YOU SEE MERCED
IN THE LANGUAGE FOR THIS PRANK
CAT BRANCH CAMPUS WILL LIKELY
MAKE IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR US TO
RECEIVE APPROVAL FROM THE LCM
ME.
BECAUSE YOU SEE MERCED HAS NOT
YET DEVELOPED SUFFICIENT MEDICAL
EDUCATION INFRASTRUCTURE TO MEET
THE HIGH LC EMMYS STANDARDS.
WHILE WE ARE CURRENTLY WORKING
WITH YOU SEE MERCED FACULTY IT
WILL TAKE SOME TIME FOR THEM TO
DEVELOP THE EXPERTISE AND
EXPERIENCE THAT THE L. CME
REQUIRES.
HOWEVER TOWARDS THAT STEP WE
CURRENTLY HAVE FOR YOU SEE
MERCED FACULTY COMING DOWN TO
FRESNO EVERY WEEK.
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE EDUCATION
OF YOU SEE US UP MEDICAL
STUDENTS.
SO EXPANDING TO FORTY EIGHT
STUDENTS ARE ULTIMATELY.
IN THE NEXT PHASE IS GOING TO
BE A BIG STEP.
THIS FIRST STEP.
WITH THE ST WOMAN GRAY IN PHASE
ONE WAS REALLY THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY PRIME PROGRAM AND THE
ENHANCEMENT FUNDING THAT HE.
BROUGHT TO US THIS WAS A BIG
STEP FOR IT ALLOWED US TO BUILD
SOME OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
WE DID NOT HAVE IT YOU SEE A
SELF FRESNO. UP PRIOR TO THIS.
I ALSO REALIZE THAT THIS IS A
POLICY COMMITTEE AND NOT ONE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BUT I DO WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THE FUNDING MODEL IN
THE BUSINESS MODEL THAT WE
DEVELOPED IN THE TO YOUR
PLANNING PROCESS.
IN THIS MODEL WAS REALLY BASED
ON BUILDING ON THE
INFRASTRUCTURE CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE AT UCSF FRESNO AND NOT
THE MORE EXTENSIVE REQUIREMENTS
THAT WOULD BE THERE. FOR
BUILDING OUT A YOU SEE MERCED
BRANCH CAMPUS.
SO AGAIN I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO MEET WITH YOU
TODAY AND EXPRESS OUR PROFOUND
INTEREST IN BUILDING CAPACITY
FOR HEALTH CARE IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. AND LOOK FORWARD TO BE
ABLE TO WORK WITH ASSEMBLYMAN
GRAY AND OTHERS IN THIS PROCESS
THANK YOU YOU. OTHER WIENERS.
I AM ABSOLUTELY IN SUPPORT
APOLOGIZING CURRENT MUSCLE
MOVING HERE FASTER KAREN LAYING
ON DOUBLE THE MERCED COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS THIS BILL
IS URGENTLY NEEDED AND THE
VALLEY FOR ALL OF THE REASONS I
THINK YOU'VE ALREADY EARD ABOUT.
SO WE ASK YOU FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY AND THANK YOU TO MISTER
GRAY FOR SIGNING AN EARLY.
YOU.
ANY WITNESSES I'M SORRY SUPPORT
WING.
MAX PARA CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
FAMILY PHYSICIANS ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE. ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MISTER PATTERSON.
COULD YOU EXPLAIN JUST A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT WITH RESPECT TO
THE CONCERN OVER OVER FRESNO.
DOES THIS.
EXCLUDES MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT.
FOR FRESNO TO MOVE FORWARD OR OR
NOT AND YOU ARE A TWEENER SO
UNITED OPPOSITION CORRECT
ALRIGHT THANK YOU.
NOT. IT'S EXACTLY THE OPPOSITE
OF OF THE EFFORT HERE.
SURPASSING WHAT WE'RE ACTUALLY.
UP UNTIL THIS YEAR HAVE ALWAYS
BEEN ENGAGE IN THE UC MERCED
EFFORT FOR ABOUT AN INDEPENDENT
MEDICAL CAMPUS.
.
YEAH THAT GOES BACK IN THE EARLY
TWO THOUSANDS AS YOU'RE WELL
AWARE. ON WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE
IS TRYING TO MARRY AT THE
INTEREST OF UCSF WITH THE
INTEREST OF LONG TERM OF A
MEDICAL SCHOOL YOU SEE MERCED.
.
FRANKLY THE ENTIRE VALLEY
SUFFERS FROM THESE POSITION A
PATIENT RATIOS A LOT OF THE SAME
ISSUES.
AND YOU SEE THE SAP IS WELL
POSITIONED GIVEN THE.
THE LAST FOUR DECADES OF WORK
THEY'VE DONE IN THE VALLEY OF
THE AS WE A INVEST MORE IN THE
UCSF PROGRAM.
THEY PARTNER WITH YOU SERVICE
THAT WE CREATE THAT OPPORTUNITY
SAME OPPORTUNITY THAT WAS TRADE
BETWEEN UCLA AND UC RIVERSIDE.
PRIOR TO THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
AN INDEPENDENT SCHOOL UC
RIVERSIDE AND IF ALL LET DOCTOR
PETERSON. FOLLOW UP.
YES FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE THE THE
ISSUE REALLY IS THE
ACCREDITATION PROCESS AND THERE
ARE VERY SUBSTANTIAL
REQUIREMENTS FROM THE LCM ME IN
ORDER TO ESTABLISH A BRANCH
CAMPUS. WHEN WE.
LET THE LCM YOU KNOW THAT WE
WERE GOING TO BE DOING THAT.
THEY REQUIRE A CONSULTATION
WHICH IS AN APPLICATION AND
REVIEW IN THEIR CURRENTLY IN
THAT REVIEW PROCESS. AND THAT
APPLICATION PROCESS CONTAINS A
LOT OF DETAIL ABOUT WHAT NEEDS
TO BE IN PLACE
FOR A BRANCH CAMPUS WHICH WE ARE
VERY CONFIDENT ARE IN PLACE IT
YOU SEE YOURSELF FRESNO. BUT
INCLUDING YOU SEE MERCED IN THAT
THEN RAISES THE ISSUE ABOUT WHAT
WHAT DEFICITS MAY EXIST
CURRENTLY AT UC MERCED. THAT WE
COULD USE THIS NEXT PHASE TO
BEGIN TO BUILD OUT CAPACITY IN
ADDRESS.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
OUT WE'RE GONNA PAUSE FOR FOR A
SECOND BEFORE ASK YOU TO CLOSE
TO IT TO. ESTABLISH COR. SIR.
MEDINA PRESIDENT.
BAKER. ARAMBULA. BLOOM.
CHAVEZ IRWIN.
KILEY. LEVINE.
LOW.
PATTERSON.
QUIRK SILVA.
SANTIAGO WEBER.
QUORUM IS PRESENT MISTER A WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU.
THEY WAS CHAIR THANK YOU
MEMBERS.
DON'T CLOSING. EVERS FOR EVERY.
ONE STUDENT WHO GRADUATES
UNIVERSITY HERE CALIFORNIA GOES
TO MED SCHOOL ON FOR STUDENTS GO
SOMEWHERE ELSE.
AND.
UP IN DOWN THE STATE WE HAVE AN
AGING POSITION POPULATION AS
WELL AS OTHER AGING HEALTHCARE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
I AND THE CONVERSATION HERE IN
SACRAMENTO HAS ALMOST
EXCLUSIVELY. A BEEN ON COVERAGE
AND NOW MORE RECENTLY COST
CONTAINMENT.
NEITHER OF THOSE THINGS ARE
IMPACTING.
THE LEAST AMONGST US A IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IN OTHER AREAS
THAT ARE HURT.
WHEN YOU HAND ME AN INSURANCE
CARD AND I CAN ACCESS A POSITION
I END UP IN THE EMERGENCY ROOM
WHICH IS THE SAME PLACE I WENT
BEFORE HAD INSURANCE CARD.
WHEN YOU A DEAL OF COST
CONTAINMENT.
IT FURTHER.
FRANKLY ERODES THE ABILITY OF
FOLKS AND UNDERSERVED AREAS WITH
A LACK OF INFRASTRUCTURE
POSITIONS AND HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS TO GET IN AND GET
CARE.
AND SO WE TRULY ARE BEING LEFT
BEHIND AND I WOULD I RECOGNIZE.
THE EXPENSE OF THIS UNDERTAKING
I RECOGNIZE. THE DELAY IN THIS
UNDERTAKING BUT IF WE CAN'T
ADDRESS THIS AT A TIME WHEN THE
STATE HAS.
RECORD SURPLUS.
IN ONE OF THE LONGEST ECONOMIC
GROWTH PERIODS IN LAST HUNDRED
YEARS.
THEN WE'RE LIKELY NEVER GONNA
ADDRESS THIS AND.
AT THE TIME IS NOW TO MOVE
FORWARD A THERE'S BEEN SEPARATE
EFFORTS I KNOW MY COLLEAGUE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA THAT
WAS WORKING OUT ISSUE WHICH
FRESNO STATE UC MERCED EFFORT
GOES BACK INTO THE EARLY TWO
THOUSANDS. OF A IT WAS SUPPOSED
TO BE BUILT BY TWENTY TWELVE IN
THE BAG REPORT TWENTY EIGHT AND
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT RATHER. AND.
.
WE'VE PUT ALL THAT BEHIND US
WE'VE GOT IT UNITED THE EFFORTS
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH UCSF NOW.
TRYING TO STRENGTHEN.
HEALTH CARE SERVICE
INFRASTRUCTURE DELIVERY IN THE
VALLEY AND I WOULD APPRECIATE.
YOUR AYE VOTE HERE TODAY THANK
YOU.
WE HAD A MOTION BY.
THIS BAKER.
MAY COME WAITING FOR A SECOND.
SECOND BY MISTER KILEY.
UP.
I'M SORRY.
MR LEVINE.
THANK YOU.
WHEN I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING IT FORWARD MUCH OF THE
DISCUSSION IS VERY REMINISCENT
OF THE DISCUSSION THAT YOU SEE
RIVERSIDE. AND WE STILL SHARE.
THE NEED FOR DOCTORS
IN RIVERSIDE AS MUCH AS I HEAR.
THAT THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
SO I AM A VERY SYMPATHETIC AND
APPRECIATE THE.
THE WORK THAT WE'VE DONE
TOGETHER. A TO MOVE.
THIS SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY TOWARDS
MORE DOCTORS.
SO I AM.
ITS SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
MADAM SECRETARY OF YOU WOULD
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. MEDINA
AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER. BAKER AYE
ARAMBULA BLOOM. CHVEZ
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA. QUIRK
SILVA AYE SANTIAGO WEBER.
SIX ZERO YOUR BILL WILL BE ON
CALL.
A RESEARCHER THANK YOU.
NEXT ITEM THIRTEEN MISTER
GLORIA.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY SIX
.
WELCOME AND YOU MAY BEGIN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I BRING TO YOU THIS AFTERNOON A
BILL THAT IS NEAR AND DEAR TO MY
HEART AS THE LEGISLATURE'S ONLY
ENROLLED TRIBAL MEMBER.
AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY SIX SEEKS
TO FINALLY PUT AN END TO THE
DECADES OLD CONVERSATION ABOUT
THE DISPOSITION OF NATIVE
AMERICAN ARTIFACTS REMAINS THAT
ARE HELD BY VARIOUS UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA CAMPUSES.
AS YOUR INCREDIBLE ANALYSIS BY
YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF WHICH I SAY
THANK YOU UP POINTS OUT AB
TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY SIX WOULD
REQUIRE YOU SEE REGION'S TO
ESTABLISH AND SUPPORT A SYSTEM
WIDE COMMITTEE. AND CAMPUS
SPECIFIC COMMITTEES TO ADDRESS
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES FOR THE
APPROPRIATE TREATMENT OF NATIVE
AMERICAN HUMAN REMAINS AND
CULTURAL ITEMS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY IN THE POSSESSION OF
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA'S CAMPUSES
AS WELL AS THEIR MUSEUMS.
AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY SIX COMES
OUT OF DECADES OF LEGISLATION
OVERSIGHT HEARINGS AND THREATS
OF LITIGATION FROM NUMEROUS
SOVEREIGN TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS.
FOLLOWING THE ENACTMENT OF THE
NET THE FEDERAL NATIVE AMERICAN
GRAVES PROTECTION AND
REPATRIATION ACT OF NINETEEN
NINETY THIS LEGISLATURE
OVERWHELMINGLY PASSED AB NINE
SEVENTY EIGHT BY THEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DARRELL STEINBERG. TO
ENSURE PROPER IMPLEMENTATION OF
THIS NEW FEDERAL LAW.
REGRETTABLY SEVERAL UC CAMPUSES
HAVE NOT ONLY FAILED TO PRODUCE
IMPLEMENT THE LAW AS INTENDED
BUT SEVERAL OF OUR TRIBAL
PARTNERS REPORT TO THE UC
SYSTEM.
HAS FAILED TO ADEQUATELY INVOLVE
TRAVEL STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THESE IMPORTANT
PROCESS HE'S.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT THE STATE
SENATE'S GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE HELD AN OVERSIGHT
HEARING TO EXAMINE THIS VERY
ISSUE.
WHILE MOST OF US WERE NOT
SERVING LEGISLATURE AT THAT TIME
ACCORDING TO THE TRANSCRIPT IT
IS CLEAR THAT MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WOULD THEN FRUSTRATED
BY THE UC'S LACK OF PROGRESS IN
REPATRIATING. THESE MOST
IMPORTANT REMAINS AND ARTIFACTS.
IS MY UNDERSTANDING THAT MANY OF
THESE ARTIFACTS AND REMAINS OUR
CONTINUE TO BE HOUSED IN STORAGE
UNITS AND OTHER FACILITIES THAT
THEY DO NOT RESPECT. THE SACRED
NATURE OF THESE ITEMS.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW NATIVE
AMERICANS BELIEVE THEIR
ANCESTORS CANNOT REST UNTIL THE
REMAINS ARE PROPERLY CARED FOR
MAKING THIS BILL DEEPLY PERSONAL
TO ALL OF US THAT IT INVOLVES.
I'M ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT
TODAY FOR A BIG TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY SIX TO HOPEFULLY ONCE AND
FOR ALL CONCLUDE THIS
CONVERSATION THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN HAVING WITH
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
FOR DECADES NOW.
I THAT'S TO MEET WITH MEMBERS OF
THE USE OF REPRESENTATIVES OF
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA TO HEAR
SOME OF THEIR CONCERNS AND WHAT
THEY BELIEVE THE CHALLENGES. AT
FOUR EIGHT FOR IMPLEMENTING THIS
LEGISLATION AND REQUEST A TOUR
OF A FACILITY WHERE THESE ARE
BEING AWARE THESE REMAINS ARE
BEING HELD. I LIKE TO THANK YOU
SEE FOR GETTING BACK TO ME
TODAY.
WHY DO NOT PLAN TO SIT WHY DO
YOU PLAN TO SIT DOWN WITH YOU
SEE TO DISCUSS THEIR CONCERNS I
WOULD LIKE TO TAKE ISSUE WITH
WHAT YOU MAY HEAR IN TERMS OF
TESTIMONY? THE NOTION THAT THE
PROVISIONS THAT THIS BILL WOULD
SOMEHOW DELAY OR SLOWDOWN
REPATRIATION EFFORTS.
MUCH RESPECTFULLY POINT OUT TO
THIS COMMITTEE THAT WE FIND
OURSELVES IN THE SITUATION
SEVENTEEN YEARS AFTER THE
STEINBERG BILL BECAME LAW IN
NEARLY THIRTY YEARS SINCE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TOOK ACTION.
IT STRIKES ME AS AN DISINGENUOUS
FOR ANYONE TO SUGGEST THAT THE
PROCESS POPS PROCESS KEY MADE
ANY SLOWER THAN IT'S ALREADY
BEEN.
SO I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME WITHOUT I
HAVE WITH ME HERE TODAY CHAIRMAN
MARK WHAT MAKAROV WITH THAT WHO
IS THE CHAIRMAN. OF THE PECHANGA
BAND OF THE SENIOR INDIANS TO
SUPPORT A TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
MR.
WELCOME GERMAN.
THANK YOU ARE CHAIRMAN MEDINA
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
PULLOVER HUNK I.
GOOD AFTERNOON LOVE A CUP RIVER
OUT WILL NOT LEAVE UP TO ABOUT
ASH KNOWN MAKARA THE JOHN AMPLE
BRUSHING ATTY.
.
TALKING AT THE CHAU ON A TOUGH.
HI MY NAME IS MARK MAKAROV THE
TRIBAL CHAIRMAN FOR THE JUG BAND
OF THE SENATE INDIANS. HELLO AT
RIGHT NOW THAT I'M IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN GRADUATE IF UC AND
UC SANTA BARBARA. WOULD BE A
POLITICAL SCIENCE.
WE'RE HERE TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR
HELP IN RETURNING OUR ANCESTORS
IN THEIR FUNERARY. TO THEIR
FUNERARY HOME TO WHERE THEY
BELONG SO THAT WE CAN GIVE THEM
A PROPER BURIAL.
WITH THE RESPECT THE DIGNITY
THAT THEY AND ALL THE OTHER
REMAINS HAVE OF.
ALL THE OTHER PEOPLE THAT ARE
OUT THERE DESERVE.
AND CALIFORNIA HOME TO THE MOST
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED.
NUMBER OF TRIBES IN THE COUNTRY
HUNDRED AND TEN.
THE NATIVE AMERICAN GRAVES
PROTECTION AND REPATRIATION ACT.
OF NINETEEN NINETY THINK IT HAS
A KNACK PARA.
HAS PROVEN INADEQUATE AND
INEFFECTIVE WHEN IT COMES TO
RESEARCH UNIVERSITIES MY
ANCESTORS ARE STILL SEEN AS
SPECIMENS THAT'S THE JARGON
THAT'S USED.
TO MANY RESEARCHERS INSTEAD OF
HUMAN BEINGS WITH THE RIGHT TO A
FINAL RESTING PLACE.
HOW UNIVERSITIES HAVE FOUND WAYS
UNDER THE CURRENT NAG FOR LAW TO
STALL THE REPATRIATION PROCESS
AND IN MANY CASES OUTRIGHT DENY
CLAIMS AND REQUESTS FOR
REPATRIATION? IF FACT.
AS OF JUNE.
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN UC
BERKELEY HAD REPATRIATED ONLY
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN OF ITS
TEN THOUSAND REMAINS.
ALL OVER ALMOST THIRTY YEARS AND
EVEN MORE APPALLING IS THAT
THESE REPATRIATIONS ARE BASED ON
AN INVENTORY AUDIT THAT WAS
CONDUCTED IN NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT AND THAT HAS NOT BEEN
UPDATED SINCE.
REQUIRING ARE NOT IT EVERY TWO
YEARS IS REASONABLE. AND IT
WOULD FORESTALL THE
INSTITUTIONAL CALLED THE SAXON
DEAD ENDS THAT OUR PEOPLE HAVE
ENCOUNTERED IN TRYING TO
REPATRIATE.
THE DENIAL OF THE RETURNS OF OUR
ANCESTORS AND THOSE OF OTHER
CALIFORNIA TRIBES WHOSE HUMAN
BONES WERE DUG UP IN THE NAME OF
SCIENCE IS A DISGRACEFUL
VIOLATION OF BASIC HUMAN
DECENCY.
ONE OF OUR WITNESSES TODAY WAS
UNABLE TO MAKE IT DUE TO
COMMITMENTS THAT SHE HAD A THE
BURIAL CEREMONY THIS EVENING.
HER NAME MYRA MUST YELLS IN MARA
ONE OF OUR TRIBAL MEMBERS EARNED
A BA IN ANTHROPOLOGY FROM UC
BERKELEY.
AND HER MASTER'S DEGREE IN
ANTHROPOLOGY ARE FROM SAN DIEGO
STATE UNIVERSITY.
SHE'S NOW A STATE REGISTERED
ARCHAEOLOGIST AND SHE SERVES ON
OUR STAFF IS A TRIBAL
ARCHAEOLOGIST IN CURATOR WITH
THEIR CULTURAL RESOURCES
DEPARTMENT.
MARA WAS ALSO AN UNDERGRADUATE
IN TURN IN THE NAC PRINTED
VISION AT THE PHOEBE HEARST
MUSEUM AT UC BERKELEY. ASSISTING
WITH NOT PRO REPATRIATION FOR
CALIFORNIA TRIBES DURING THAT
TIME.
SHE WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR CHECKING
INVENTORY FOR KNACK FOR
COLLECTIONS AND DURING A
CONSULTATION IN TWO THOUSAND AND
THREE WITH THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA TRIBE.
A CART OF ASSOCIATIVE FUNERARY
OBJECTS IS BROUGHT OUT THAT THE
TRIBE WAS REQUESTING TO
REPATRIATE.
DURING THE CONSULTATION TRIBAL
ELDERS INDICATED THAT THEY
THOUGHT THERE WERE ADDITIONAL
ITEMS THAT WERE INCLUDED IN
THEIR CURRENT REPATRIATION
CLAIM.
BUT MUSEUM OFFICIALS DENIED THAT
ANY OF ADDITIONAL ITEMS WERE IN
THE MUSEUM'S POSSESSION.
BECAUSE MYRA HAD TO CHECK THE
INVENTORIES OF ON THAT FOR ITEMS
SHE KNEW PERSONALLY.
THERE WERE INDEED ADDITIONAL
FUNERARY OBJECTS THAT THE MUSEUM
WAS FAILING TO IDENTIFY.
IT IS TESE TYPES OF INCIDENTS
THAT ARE WHOLLY DISRESPECTFUL
BREED MISTRUST
AND NECESSITATE THIS BILL.
YOU SEE WILL WILL SAY THAT THEY
TREAT HUMAN REMAINS WITH RESPECT
AND DIGNITY WHILE USING JARGON
WORDS LIKE SPECIMEN. THAT ARE
DEVOID OF RESPECT AND DIGNITY
DIGNITY AND YET AS MYRA PROTESTS
AND SHE IS AN ARCHAEOLOGICAL
PROFESSIONAL THE REMAINS OF OUR
ANCESTORS LIE IN SUPERBLOCK BAGS
ON MUSEUM SHELVES.
ASK YOURSELVES DE HUMAN REMAINS
AND SIMPLOT BAGS REFLECT
CALIFORNIA'S RESPECT TOWARD
TRAVEL PEOPLE.
THIS BILL WILL COMPEL THESE
INSTITUTIONS TO FINALLY TAKE
CONSULTATION AND OUTREACH TO
TRIBE SERIOUSLY. IN ORDER TO
RETURN HUMAN REMAINS IN THOSE
PEOPLE'S PERSONAL POSSESSIONS
OFTEN MUSEUMS SHELVES AND RETURN
THEM TO THE APPROPRIATE PLACE
FOR TRIBES PROPER CARE AS IS
REQUIRED BY FEDERAL LAW IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
THE LAST TWO DECADES
CALIFORNIA'S MADE GREAT STRIDES
TOWARD TREATING INDIAN TRIBES
WITH RESPECT AND DIGNITY.
OUR STATE RIGHTFULLY PRIDES
ITSELF IN LEADING THE NATION ON
CERTAIN ISSUES LIKE.
CLEAN ENVIRONMENT RENEWABLE
ENERGY CONSUMER HEALTH AND
SAFETY. BUSINESS INNOVATION IN
HUMAN RIGHTS PROTECTIONS BUT
MUCH OF WHAT IS HAPPENING UNDER
KNACK PROP IS NOT CONSISTENT AND
IS ABSOLUTELY INCONGRUENT.
WITH THIS RECORD THAT CALIFORNIA
HAS.
AS SUCH WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY SIX ON BEHALF OF THE
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIA IN THE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN REMOVED
FROM THEIR FINAL RESTING PLACES
AND IN MANY CASES DUG UP OVER A
CENTURY AGO. AND SUBJECTED TO
DESECRATION.
ALTHOUGH WERE CRITICAL OF UC'S
HANDLING OF ACCRATODAY FOR ME
AT THAT WITHIN MY OWN TRIBE I AT
LEAST. AT LEAST TWENTY PITANGA
TRAVEL CITIZENS THAT ARE ALUMNI
OF THE UC AT THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
INCLUDING OF COURSE MYSELF INTO
CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS TWO OF OUR
IN HOUSE TRAVEL ATTORNEYS OF
COURSE MYRA OUR TRAVEL
ARCHAEOLOGIST.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
CHRIS LINDSTROM ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA TRIBAL BUSINESS
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT.
MELISSA WARNER ON BEHALF OF THE
WILTON RANCHERIA AND SUPPORT.
FOLLOW TREAT ON BEHALF OF BOTH
PECHANGA AND THE COLUSA INDIAN
COMMUNITY IN SUPPORT.
I DO AFFECT WORKERS FOR THE
RINCON BAND OF LOOSING YOU
INDIANS SUPPORT.
MICHAEL WINDS OF BEHALF OF TABLE
MOUNTAIN MANCHURIA IN SUPPORT.
DRUM SEEN THIS ON BEHALF OF THE
UNITED AUBURN INDEED COMMUTING
IN STRONG SUPPORT LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR. INSPECTS THE
SPONSORS THIS IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT TO KNOW ROB THANK YOU.
I HEADS OVER WHAT MARIN SHARIA
AND WE'RE PLAYING IN OUR SUPPORT
OF AB. TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY SIX.
SCOTT GOVERNOR BEHALF THE
MORONGOBAND OF MISSION INDIANS
IN SUPPORT.
FRANK MARINO BEHALF THE SALMON
WILL PAY THE MISSION IS IN
SUPPORT.
ANY TWEENER.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS JASON MURPHY ON BEHALF
THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA WE DO
NOT HAVE POSITION ON THIS BILL
THIS TIME IN FACT IS IS NOTED
YOUR ANALYSIS. WE HAD EXPRESSED
CONCERNS.
IN THE ORIGINAL FIRST POLICY
COMMITTEE LAST WEEK I WON'T GO
OVER THOSE AGAIN TODAY OF THEIR
PROPERLY RECOGNIZED I JUST ALSO
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
IMPORTANCE OF WHICH THE
UNIVERSITY TAKES THIS.
CONVERSATION.
OVERALL IT WOULD TO LOOK
FORWARD TO SITTING DOWN WITH
THE.
AUTHOR EARLY NEXT WEEK TO TALK
THROUGH THIS WITH A CAMPUS
REPRESENTATIVES.
IF YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
A QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS FROM
THE ACT COMMITTEE MS BAKER. JUST
I THINK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND.
REALLY HOPE THAT THAT YOU SEE
WILL.
THOROUGHLY AND EXPEDITIOUSLY
BRING THIS TO RESOLUTION.
I WASN'T AWARE THAT THIS WAS AN
ISSUE AND FOR HOW LONG IT HAS
BEEN AN ISSUE. AND HOW PERSONAL.
.
AND ISSUE IT IS AND ANYTHING WE
CAN DO THAT TO EXPEDITE THAT AND
I'M OUT OF COURSE STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE THE UNIVERSITY THAT.
TO WRAP IT UP THANK YOU.
WAS QUIRK SILVA.
UP I ALSO AGREE WHAT THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAKER'S. REMARKS
BUT I'M A LITTLE BIT MORE
GROUCHY IN THE SENSE THAT. A.
I'M JUST SHOCKED.
THAT THE YOU SEE A.
HAS CHOSEN TO GO DOWN THIS PATH
WHERE. THIS TYPE OF LEGISLATION
NEEDS TO BE FORCED WITHOUT THEM
COMING TO THE TABLE KNOWING HOW
IMPORTANT THIS IS. KNOW I'M BEEN
A TEACHER FOR ELEMENTARY TEACHER
FOR.
CLOSE TO THIRTY YEARS AND. OFTEN
TAUGHT FOURTH GRADE WHICH IS
CALIFORNIA HISTORY AND SO WE
ALWAYS DID.
WHAT IS ASKED OF US AS TEACHERS
TAKE OUR?
STUDENTS TO A.
VARIOUS MUSEUMS.
VARIOUS EXPERIENCES MANY TIMES
WE'D GO DOWN TO THE SAN JUAN
CAPISTRANO.
.
MISSION BUT WE ALSO HAVE CHOICES
IN TEACHING SO I MADE IT A POINT
TO MAKE SURE THAT I COULD TEACH
STORIES THAT I THOUGHT REALLY
REFLECTED THE CULTURE OF OUR
NATIVE MET MERRICK AND.
INDIANS AND MAKE SURE THAT THEY
UNDERSTOOD.
HOW CALIFORNIA PLAYED A ROLE?
AND SO FORTH AND SO TO TO AGAIN
SEE THAT HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AS YOU MENTIONED WITH
OVER A HUNDRED AND TEN TRIBES
AND. THE RICH CULTURE THAT CAME
FOR BEFORE WE WERE HERE AND TO
SEE LIKE YOU SAY OUT REMAINS
THAT FOR ANY NOXIOUS CULTURE BUT
FAMILY ARE SO PRECIOUS.
THAT WE WOODS PUT HIM ON A
SHELF AND BUT NOT A RETURN THEM.
IN A TIMELY MANNER OR AT ALL I
THINK YOU SEE REALLY NEEDS TO
REVISIT THE POLICY MOVE FORWARD
QUICKLY AND THIS IS ABSOLUTELY.
.
I'M SORRY TO SAY YET ANOTHER
ISSUE THAT I AM BEGINNING TO
HAVE WITH UC'S AYE THEY ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR EDUCATION THEY
DO NOT HOLD UP WHETHER THEY BE
ARTIFACTS AS THEIRS. AND IT'S
THROUGH EDUCATION WE LEARNED
TOGETHER SO I FULLY SUPPORT
THIS.
MISTER PATTERSON.
BOB THANK YOU MISTER GORE
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD I WOULD.
.
LOVE TO BE A CO AUTHOR ALONG
WITH YOU AND THAT MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR YOUR.
PASSIONATE TESTIMONY IN YOUR
PERSUASIVENESS HERE WHO
PRECEDED.
LONG OVERDUE BUT WE HOPE THIS
BRING SOME RESOLUTION VERY
QUICKLY THANK YOU.
MISTER GORE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I JUST WILL CLOSE QUICKLY
I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIRMAN OF
FOR HIS COMMENTS AS. MY
COLLEAGUE MENTIONED VERY
POWERFUL AND RICH THINK A THAT
OBVIOUSLY PERSONAL WAY RECEIVE
THIS AND.
THIS BILL.
IT IS DEEPLY PERSONAL AND I
THINK IN MANY WAYS WERE HUMBLE
THAT TO SIT HERE TO ASK FOR THIS
ON BUT YOU CAN HELP US CRACKED
THIS WRONG THAT HAS BEEN GOING
ON FOR FAR TOO LONG. AS WAS
MENTIONED.
AT THE CURRENT PACE IT'S GONNA
TAKE CENTURIES UP FOR UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA TO RETURN.
THESE REMAINS TO US.
AND SO WITH YOUR HELP TODAY WE
HOPE TO. TO UNDO THAT.
TO CORRECT THIS WRONG I
APPRECIATE THE OFFER AUTHOR
AUTHOR OF CO AUTHORSHIP ALL OF
YOUR WELCOME TO JOIN IN AS WELL
I LISTEN A STRONG MESSAGE LET'S
MAKE THIS LAW AND WITHIN MAKE
THIS RIGHT SO EXPECT FAST
DRIVER.
THANK YOU.
.
I WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES
FOR THEIR ELOQUENT.
DESCRIPTION OF THE IMPORTANCE
OF THIS BILL THANK THE AUTHOR
THANK YOU TO THE CHAIRMAN.
ALSO WOULD LIKE TO BE ADDED AS
A CO AUTHOR.
AND I I I FEEL AS CHAIR OF
HIGHER EDUCATION THAT IT'S.
DEFINITELY VERY IMPORTANT AND.
AND I.
.
GLAD TO HEAR THAT YOU SEE IS
GOING TO SIT DOWN WITH THE
AUTHOR.
AND.
I'M HAPPY FOR THAT.
SO THE MOTION WAS.
DO PASS.
BUT.
MOVED BY MS BAKER SECOND BY MS
QUIRK SILVA.
MADAM SECRETARY OF YOU. CALL
THE ROLL.
EMOTIONS DO PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER
BAKER AYE ARAMBULA.
BLOOM.
CHAVEZ
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA. QUIRK
SILVA AYE SANTIAGO WEBER.
ZERO THE BILL WILL BE ON CALL.
THANK YOU.
MOVING TO ITEM SEVEN MISTER
VOEPEL.
ASSEMBLY BILL.
TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY NINE.
IT WILL COME.
WELL.
MAYBE GET.
ROGER THAT. NUMBER WILL TEAR
COLLEAGUES I'M HERE TO PRESENT
A. B. TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY NINE
WHICH ESTABLISHES.
A STUDENT FINANCIAL AID PILOT
PROGRAM TO EXAMINE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF AN INCOME SHARE
AGREEMENT.
AS A FUNDING SOURCE FOR STUDENTS
EARNING HER BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN
OUR UC AND CSU SYSTEM. COMMAND
SEEN WHAT THE TWENTY TWENTY AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE YEAR.
IT SHOWS MY OPTIMISM TO BE HERE
TO WATCH IT.
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE CS USED
TO TAKE PART IN THIS BILL AND
WOOD* UC'S TO PARTICIPATE.
PARTICIPATION WOULD BE BASED ON
THE LEVEL OF PRIVATE INVESTMENT.
AND I ESSAY IS NOT ALONE OR
OTHER DEBT INSTRUMENT.
AND I I SAY REPRESENTS A
STUDENTS OBLIGATION TO MAKE
PAYMENTS LINKED TO A SPECIFIC
PERCENTAGE OF THE STUDENTS
FUTURE EARNED INCOME.
UNDER A NYE SA PRIVATE
INVESTORS.
FUND STUDENTS IN RETURN FOR A
SHARE OF THEIR INCOME OVER FIX
PERIODS OF TIME.
WELL A MIX OF FEDERAL AND STATE
GRANTS IS AVAILABLE FOR LOW
INCOME FAMILIES THE AMOUNT IS
FREQUENTLY INSUFFICIENTTO COVER
THE COST OF ATTENDANCE.
THE STUDENTS MUST OFTEN TAKE OUT
LOANS TO BRIDGE THE FUNDING GAP.
CALIFORNIA'S STUDENTS GRADUATE
CAL COLLEGE WITH AN AVERAGE LOAN
DEBT ABOUT TWENTY TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND PAY FOUR POINT FOUR
FIVE PERCENT IN INTEREST OVER
THE TEN YEAR REPAYMENT PLAN.
INCOME SHARE AGREEMENTS PROVIDE
ANOTHER FINANCING OPTION TO HELP
ALLEVIATE THE MONETARY BURDEN ON
STUDENTS ARE NEED A BACHELOR'S
DEGREES.
UNLIKE STUDENT LOANS THERE ARE
NO INTEREST CHARGES WITH AYE
ESSAYS.
THE AYE IS A MONTHLY PAYMENTS
ARE ADJUSTED ACCORDING TO THE
STUDENTS POSTGRADUATE INCOME AND
DID NOT BEGIN UNTIL THE STUDENT
IS EMPLOYEE. EARNING THE MINIMUM
SALARY REQUIREMENT OF TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS NETS PER YEAR.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN PURDUE
UNIVERSITY INTRODUCED ANNIHILUS
SAY FUN
OWING TO THE PROGRAM'S SUCCESS
PURDUE EXPANDED THE FUN A YEAR
LATER AND DISTRIBUTED OVER FIVE
POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS TO
ALMOST FIVE HUNDRED JUNIORS AND
SENIORS. ACROSS SEVENTY NINE
MAJORS.
THE PILOT PROGRAM ESTABLISHED BY
AB TWO FUNNY FOR SEVENTY NINE
HOPES TO SHARE PURDUE'S SIX
SUCCESS AND GIVE STUDENTS
ANOTHER OPTION TO CONSIDER WHEN
FINANCING THEIR HIGHER
EDUCATION.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE AND LET THIS THING ROLE.
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
NO SIR.
ANY TWEETERS.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MOVED BY MS BAKER'S SECOND BY
MISTER PATTERSON.
WHEN I THANK THE AUTHOR YOU
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
YES SIR.
THIS IS A.
FINANCIAL AGREEMENT BETWEEN
PARTIES.
AND IT'S ORGANIZED THROUGH THE
UNIVERSITIES.
SO MANY OF THE SAME DONORS IT
SUPPORT UNIVERSITIES WILL
SUPPORT STUDENTS UNDER
INCREDIBLY FAVORABLE CONDITIONS.
SO WE HAD.
MOTION BY MS BAKER SECOND BY
MISTER PATTERSON AGAIN THANK YOU
TO THE AUTHOR AND I THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS UP AS A PILOT.
AND THANK YOU FOR. USING PRODUTO
VERSE CITY.
GOOD THINGS COME FROM PURDUE A
AND I THINK THIS WOULD BE.
RELATIVELY NEW AND ALTERNATIVE
FINANCIAL AID TOOL.
STUDENTS WOULD BE ABLE TO USE.
SO MOTION IS DUE PARRIS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. I'M
SECRETARY OF YOU'D CALL THE
ROLL.
MEDINA AYE.
MEDINA AYE BAKER BAKER AYE
ARAMBULA. BLOOM.
CHAVEZ IRWIN. IRWIN AYE KILEY.
LEVINE. LEVINE AYE LOW
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO WEBER.
SIX ZERO THE BILL WILL BE ON
CALL.
USER.
SHE HER.
NO.
WE DO CONSENT.
THE ON CALL.
MICHIGAN HAS HAD.
OKAY.
MISTER. YOU GOTTA YEAH OKAY
BICU GOOD.
WOULD MEMBERS OF. TEAM WILL GO
TO ITEM FIFTEEN MISTER LEVY.
WELCOME.
I THINK WE'RE WAITING FOR MY
WITNESSES WHO ARE NOT ALLOWED
DOWN THERE WASN'T ROOM FOR THEM
SO THEY'RE OUTSIDE A LITTLE
HEARING.
SO.
KIND OF A SURPRISE A PROWLER
EXPECT ME TO GO LAST.
EIGHT HOW AREA.
BRIAN ALRIGHT TO HAVE A SEAT.
IS.
.
DIMINISH.
THIS COULD EMBELLISH.
REALLY OKAY.
I THINK VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AB THIRTY ONE FIFTY
THREE ADDS THE EQUIVALENT OF TWO
SUMMER SESSIONS AT UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. AND CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY AT CAL GRANT A AND B.
COLLEGE GRADUATE DEFICIT.
A LARGE IMPEDIMENT TO GRADUATION
RATES IS THE LACK OF FINANCIAL
AID AVAILABLE FOR STUDENTS
DURING SUMMER SESSIONS
CURRENTLY.
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS CANNOT BE
AWARDED A CAL GRANT A OR B. FOR
MORE THAN FOUR ACADEMIC YEARS.
OF FULL TIME ATTENDANCE THIS
MEANS THAT EIGHT ELIGIBLE
STUDENTS RECEIVE IN A FOUR YEAR
PERIOD MAY NOT BE INCREASEDOF A
STUDENT IS ACCELERATING THEIR
GRADUATION. BY ATTENDING SUMMER
SESSIONS.
ACCORDING TO YOU SEE FRESHMAN
ENTRANCE WHO DO NOT ENROLL IN
SUMMER HAVE A SEVENTY EIGHT
PERCENT SIX YOUR GRADUATION RATE
COMPARED EIGHTY NINE PERCENT OF
THOSE WHO ENROLL. ONE SUMMER
TERM OR NINETY TWO PERCENT FOR
TWO SUMMER TERMS.
AND NINETY ONE PERCENT FOR THREE
OR MORE SUMMER TERMS. A. B.
THIRTY ONE FIFTY THREE WILL HELP
STINSON PURSES REDUCE THE
FINANCIAL BURDEN IN GRADUATE IN
A FASTER TIMEFRAME WITHOUT
INCURRING ADDITIONAL DEBT. WITH
ME TO TESTIFY IS RYAN BRAUN
ISSUED FROM SECULAR STATE.
I THINK YOU SO MUCH ASSEMBLYMAN.
AND THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR ALLOWING ME TO BE HERE
TODAY.
AS HE SAID MY NAME IS RYAN
BRAUN.
I'M A STUDENT AT SACRAMENTO
STATE A DOUBLE MAJOR IN PUBLIC
RELATIONS AND ECONOMICS.
I'M EXCITED TO BE GRADUATING IN
FOUR WEEKS.
HOWEVER I WOULD NOT BE
GRADUATING IN FOUR WEEKS IF IT
WERE NOT FOR THE AVAILABILITY OF
SUMMER COURSES FOR ME TO BE ABLE
TO COMPLETE MY EDUCATION A
TIMELY MANNER.
UNFORTUNATELY.
THE SUMMER COURSES DUE TO THEIR
EXTREMELY HIGH COST PER UNIT.
A AND IT'S.
.
THE FINANCIAL BURDEN THAT IT PUT
ON ME AS A STUDENT.
I NOT ONLY WAS I OBLIGATED TO
TAKE A SECOND JOB DURING THE
ACADEMIC SCHOOL YEAR. OUGHT TO
BE ABLE TO AFFORD IT THE SUMMER
UNITS WHICH TOTALED. A SLIGHTLY
OVER EIGHTY SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS
OVER THE COURSE OF TWO YEARS.
ABOUT ALSO FORCE TAKE OUT AN
ADDITIONAL FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN STUDENT LOANS WILL BE
REPAYING FOR. THE NEXT SEVERAL
YEARS AFTER GRADUATION.
I'M PROUD TO BE BREALEY
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF THIS
BILL BECAUSE NOT ONLY WAS IT
ORIGINATED BY STUDENTS BUT IT'S
BEEN REALLY HEAVILY PROMOTED BY
STUDENTS.
AND THIS MY STORY.
IS NOT AS MINE IT'S HEARD
REALLY ACROSS EVERY STUDENTS IN
THE YOU SEE ON THE CSU.
I'VE FACED MANY BOTTLENECK
COURSES I AM A PUBLIC RELATIONS
COURSE WORK IN THAT SAUDIS ARE
COURSES THAT HAVE EASILY HUNDRED
TWENTY STUDENTS OUT OF WHICH
MAYBE. UP FORTY PASS ON
REGULARITY. AYE AND THEREFORE
THESE COURSES DO NOT ALLOW
PEOPLE TO PROGRESS THROUGH THEIR
UNIT LOAD.
AND WHEN THERE'S SIMPLY NOT
ENOUGH COURSES DURING THE
REGULAR SCHOOL YEAR STUDENTS ARE
OBLIGATED TO DO ONE OF TWO
THINGS.
EITHER THEY EXTEND THEIR
GRADUATION SOMETIMES
INDEFINITELY.
I KNOW STUDENTS IN THE MATH
PROGRAM AT SAC STATE WHOSE
EXTENDED HER GRADUATION TIME AT
SEVEN YEARS. ARE BECAUSE OF THE
AND AVAILABILITY OF BOTTLENECK
COURSES.
OR THE OTHER OPTION IS TAKE
SUMMER CLASSES.
HOWEVER FOR MANY STUDENTS WHILE
THE SUMMER CLASSES EXIST
THEY'RE NOT NECESSARILY
ACCESSIBLE BECAUSE OF THE
FINANCIAL BURDEN PLACED UPON
STATE.
.
AND OF BECAUSE OF SITUATIONS
LIKE OVER ENROLLMENT IN THE UC
AND THE CSU OBLIGATED UP BY THE
STATE'S.
WE HAVE THE NEED FOR ADDITIONAL
CLASSES
BUT LIKE I SAID A MOMENT AGO
ADDITIONAL CLASSES ARE
EFFECTIVELY MEANINGLESS UNLESS
THEY'RE ACCEPTABLE OR THEIR.
ACCESSIBLE TO STUDENTS.
AND BY THAT ONCE AGAIN I MEAN
BEING EXCEEDINGLY HIGH FINANCIAL
BURDEN PLACED ON STUDENTS WHEN
TRYING TO ACCESS THE SUMMER
CLASSES.
IN ORDER FOR STUDENTS TO
GRADUATE ON TIME IT SHOULD BE TO
THE STATE'S ECONOMY AND FULFILL
THE ONE POINT ONE MILLION DOLLAR
DEBT.
NOT DOLLAR STUDENTS DEBT.
THAT THE STATE HOUSE IN THAN
THEIR NEED FOR GRADUATES BY
TWENTY THIRTY. WE MUST MAKE
SUMMER CLASSES MORE ACCESSIBLE
FOR STUDENTS BY EXTENDING
CALTRANS.
BOB AND SPONSORING THAT THEY CAN
NOT ONLY GRADUATE ON TIME A
GRADUATE WITH LESS OF A DEBT
LOAD. AND I STRONGLY ENCOURAGE
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALSO LIKE
INJURIES COULD HAVE BEEN OSHA
ADVENTURE KAKWA FROM THE CHAIR
OF THE WHO IS THE CHAIR OF THE
COW COALITION FOR A BETTER YOU
SEE AT UC SANTA BARBARA THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE. ALSO
THE REDUCING.
I'M GONNA HAVE TO IT IS A
JUDGMENT. MY NAME IS COMMON BUT
NOT ABLE TO COOKWARE AMADOR TO
PUT THE SCIENCE MAJOR AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SANTA
BARBARA.
NOW MOST OF THE PUNDITS HAVE THE
CODES FOR BDC WHICH SISTER RIGHT
ACTIVIST GROUP AT UCSB.
TO DATE HOWEVER PRESENTING
UNIVERSITAT APPOINTEES
ASSOCIATION.
AND EXPLAIN WHY WE'RE SPONSORING
AB THAT ONE FIVE THREE WHICH IS
A BOTH A LIST EXTEND SOME
CONFERENCE.
NOW YOU MAY WONDER WHY SUITS
HAVE DRIVEN FROM DIFFERENT PARTS
OF CALIFORNIA TO TALK TO YOU BUT
A. B. THIRTY ONE FIVE THREE.
YOU MAY WONDER WHY THIS BILL
WHICH MAKES THE CABIN AVAILABLE
FOR NINE UNITS PER SOME ATTEMPT.
FOR TWO ADDITIONAL SUMMIT TERMS
MATTER SO MUCH THE STUDENTS IN
THIS ROOM.
WELL I'M HERE TO TIE THAT'S
BECAUSE WE HAVE QUESTIONS.
WE QUESTION WIDE MAJORITY
OPPRESSION RECENT BLACK AND
BROWN PUBLIC RECIPIENTS INVOLVED
IN THE UC SYSTEM I'M NOT
GRADUATING WITH THEM FOR YEARS.
WE QUESTION WHY OVER SEVENTY
PERCENT OF THE STUDENTS ENROLLED
IN THE CASTING UNIVERSITY SYSTEM
ARE NOT GRADUATING WITH THEM FOR
YEARS.
WE QUESTION WHY WERE EXPECTED TO
CELEBRATE SIX YEAR GRADUATION
RATES WERE TOLD THEY WERE
ATTENDING FOUR YEAR
INSTITUTIONS.
AND CONSIDERING THE FACT THAT
THE NATIONAL FOR YOUR AVERAGE
BECAUSE GRADUATION IS AROUND
FORTY PERCENT WE QUESTION WITH
THE IDEA OF A FOUR YEAR
INSTITUTION ACTUALLY EXISTS.
WHAT THEY HAVE THAT SUMMIT BE
PERPETUATED A COLLEGE ADMISSIONS
WEBSITE PAGES?
NOW.
ALL QUESTIONS HAVE NOT REMAIN
QUESTIONS.
BUT IT BECOME FEARS AS MY
FRIEND.
SIDE OVER HERE THE PUBLIC
POLICY IS THAT OF CALIFORNIA DO
RESEARCH SAYING THAT IF CURRENT
TRENDS PERSIST BY THE YEAR
TWENTY THIRTY. CALIFORNIA WILL
HAVE A COLLEGE GRADUATE DEFICIT
OF ONE POINT ONE MILLION.
IT IS A GENERAL THAT IS NOT JUST
AN EDUCATION CRISIS BUT THAT IS
AN ECONOMIC CRISIS.
HOWEVER.
BECAUSE YOUNG COLLEGE STUDENTS
WHO DID JUST COME.
WHAT QUESTIONS BECAME TO
SOLUTION?
AND THAT'S SOLUTION IS AB THERE
ONE FIVE THREE.
THE BILL WHICH IS SUPPORTED BY
RESEARCH THAT SHOWS THAT WHEN
STUDENTS TAKE MORE SUMMER
COURSES THE MORE LIKELY TO
GRADUATE ON TIME.
THE BILL THAT WE WERE STUDENTS
WAY ROLLED WILL ALREADY HAVE
TWELVE MONTH HOUSING LEASES.
READ THEM PUNISHING THEM FOR
STATE MATT OF IRAN MEANT THAT I
MADE A CLASS IS OVER AND ROLL TO
THE POINT WHERE THEY CAN GET
THEIR CLASSES TO THE RIG
ACADEMIC YEAR.
THE BILL.
OTHER BIG MONEY.
SPONSORED BY YOU SEE IF THEY.
A POOR BUT THE REST OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT ABOUT THE
BECAUSE IT WAS THE SYSTEM AND
KILEY HAS NO OPPOSITION.
NOW I WHICH ALSO THAT'S A GOOD
PLACE TO STOP IN NO OPPOSITION.
AND. AND AND AND YOUR TIME HAS
EXPIRED WITH THOSE WHO ARE
PREPARED NO THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN IN
SUPPORT.
DEAR TO SOCAL STATE SOON
ASSOCIATION WE SUPPORT THE BILL
IN CONCEPT ALL BE TAKING A
SUPPORT POSITION IN THE COMING
WEEK THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME'S CHADWICK MORE IN
THE FOURTH YEAR POLITICAL
SCIENCE A PHILOSOPHY STUDENT WHO
YOU SEE FETA BARBARA. NAMELY I'M
SPEAKING SUPPORT AB THIRTY ONE
FIFTY THREE BECAUSE MY
EXPERIENCE WORK AT THE FOOD BANK
UP MY CAMPUS.
OUT THE FOOD NICK MY CAPS WE
SERVICE ABOUT THIRTY PERCENT OR
SOMETHING TO REMIND THE
WITNESSES THAT THAT FOLLOW THERE
WERE TWO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
TWO MINUTES.
AND NOW IF YOU JUST GIVE YOUR
NAME WHAT GROUP YOU'RE WITH AND
THAT YEAR IN SUPPORT I THIN
MOTIVES CHADWICK MORE. AYE FROM
UC SANTA BARBARA I'M WITH YOU
CEASE ES A. AND CALLS FOR BUT
YOU SEE WE ARE SUPPORT OF.
AB THROUGH A FIFTY THREE.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS KEVIN SO BELLICOSE
SECOND YOUR POLITICAL SCIENCE
MAJOR AT UC SANTA BARBARA
REPRESENTING YOU SEE S. B. A. S.
LOBBY COR. AYE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS AND LEYVA COMETH
THEIR YEARS HISTOLOGY INBOXACE
IN EASY SANTA BARBARA ADMIN I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF USE YES THEY.
AND THE COALITION FOR BETTY SEE
IN SUPPOT OF AB THREE ONE FIVE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE MY NAME
IS A BASE TO PROVIDE HAS THAT
KIND OF THE FIRST IF I COLLEGE
EMBRACE EYES MAGI UCSB AND I
SUPPORT AB THROUGH A FACTORY.
HELLO I'M A MILLION AGO OWNS AND
I'M A FIRST YEAR AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SANTA
BARBARA AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY ONE FIFTY THREE.
GOOD AFTERNOON ALEX GRAVES OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE PROUD TO BE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TYLER I YOU ARE
BE AFTER THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
HOW MANY MISSED DAVY OBVIOUSLY
FIRST YEAR POLITICAL SCIENCE
MAJOR AT UCSB AND I'M HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE ONE FIVE
THREE?
HI MY NAME IS TANYA HAN I MISS
YOU KNOW YOU SEE BERKELEY I'M
HERE TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
AS A TRANSFER SHOULD I JUST
WANNA REEMPHASIZE OUR OFTENTIMES
WERE NOT ABLE TO GRADUATE ON
TIME NAME IN THE GROUP OKAY. SO
THANK YOU.
HIRAM SORROW TO CHEYENNE FROM UC
BERKELEY I ALSO SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
HI MY NAME IS CHLOE I'M A FOURTH
YEAR UCLA WE LITERALLY FLEW IN
JUST TO SAY OUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL.
NOTED THAT MISSILE ALSO FROM
UCLA.
FULL SUPPORT THINK.
LEO SHAKE AND ALSO HEAR FROM
UCLA AND IN COMPLETE SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS A LOT OF IT IS FIRST
YEAR UCLA AND I'M ALSO
INCOMPLETE SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
LOW TAR ALEXANDER THE UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATION AND THE Q. AND WE
SUPPORT AND SPONSOR THE BILL.
CHARACTER AMERICA HAVE THE
ASSOCIATION OF INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES IN OUR APOLOGIES TO
THE AUTHORS OFFICE ON THE
COMMITTEE STAFF WE REACHED OUT
LAST WEEK LATE LAST WEEK. WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE AMENDED WE COMPLETELY
AGREE THAT SUMMER SCHOOLS
IMPORTANT THAT WE WOULD HOPE WE
WOULD INCLUDE THE LOW INCOME
STUDENTS A CALIFORNIA'S PRIVATE
NOT FOR PROFIT INSTITUTIONS.
THANK YOU.
ANY TWO WIENERS.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION AS
BAKER. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU FOR THE SPELL.
YOUR WITNESSES SAID VERY VERY
WELL WHY IT IS SO IMPORTANT. OF
BUT I ALSO THINK IT IS NECESSARY
TO INCLUDE PRIVATE NOT FOR
PROFIT COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
IN THE AND IN THE STATE THEY'RE
ALREADY TREATED.
I THINK UNFAIRLY BECAUSE IF
YOU'RE A STUDENT WHO GOES TO A
PRIVATE NONPROFIT UNIVERSITY IN
CALIFORNIA YOU DON'T GET THE
SAME CAL GRANT AMOUNT IS IF YOU
ENDED UP GOING TO PUBLIC
UNIVERSITY AND YOU SHOULD. AND
THEY HAVE JUST THE SAME
PRESSURES THAT WERE VERY WELL
ARTICULATED BY YOUR WITNESSES.
VERY WELL. AND THAT WE WE I
THINK NEED TO HAVE. PARITY AND
HOW THOSE STUDENTS HAVE PATHWAYS
OPPORTUNITY PARTICULARLY OF FOR
COMPLETING NOT ONLY IN FOUR
YEARS BUT WITH LESS DEBT
OVERALL.
AND SO I'M I'M PLEASED TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY REALLY
REALLY WISH THAT HAD THEM IN
THERE I HOPE YOU HAVE INTENT TO
DO THAT IF NOT HOPEFULLY WE CAN
TRY TO WORK ON THAT TOGETHER.
EVEN CURIOUS WHY THEY AREN'T
ORIGINALLY IN YOUR LEGISLATION
WOULD WELCOME YOUR THOUGHTS ON
THAT.
SURE A AND IT'S A GREAT QUESTION
NOT THE FIRST TIME A SPIN ASTON
WILL CONSIDER IT I THINK THAT
THE CONCERNS WE HAVE ARE ONE YOU
KNOW THE IMPACTION AT THAT
PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES IS REALLY
BAD.
.
I'D NEED TO SEE THE DATE ON THE
PRIVATE UNIVERSITIES.
FAIRNESS FOR FAIRNESS TO SAKE
IS GREAT AYE WE WANNA SEE THE
OUTCOMES AND MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE GRADUATING PEOPLE ON TIME.
THANK YOU I AND I THINK IT IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE GO BEYOND
FERRIS IS HER FRIENDS THINK THAT
THE STUDENTS NEED TO COMPLETE AS
AND FOR YEARS AS WELL I'M SURE
WE CAN WORK ON GATHERING THAT.
THAT DATA AND TRY TO.
TO.
BE FAIR WITH REAL RESULTS FOR
THEM SAID THANK YOU.
MISS QUIRK SILVA AND THEN MISTER
BAD.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THIS
LEGISLATION.
THIS SUMMER HAVING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A SUMMER
PROGRAM BUT ALSO TO RESERVE FOR
UP TO RECEIVE THE SUPPORT FOR
THAT IS REALLY HUGE I WAS
SOMEBODY MANY MANY YEARS AGO WHO
WAS ABLE TO GRADUATE IN FOUR
YEARS.
THROUGH A YOU SEE A UCLA BUT I
ALSO TOOK ME OUT NOT ONLY SUMMER
SCHOOL BUT EVEN AT THAT TIME
THEY HAD WINTER OFFERINGS SO.
THING IT REALLY IS ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE TO DO A FOUR YEAR
PROGRAM WITHOUT
OF THE SUMMER SCHOOL AND AS
MENTIONED MANY STUDENTS DON'T
TAKE IT BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
THE SUPPORT SO THANK YOU I THINK
THIS WILL.
DEFINITELY SHOW RESULTS.
MR MAGIC YOU GET DISTRACTED THE
VICE CHAIR WITH RESPECT TO OUT.
A PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS.
I REPRESENT SEVERAL OF THEM IN
MY DISTRICT.
PRESENT PACIFIC AS AT A IS ONE.
AND AS.
.
STUDENT MYSELF AND AS THE FATHER
OF THREE STUDENTS.
WE HAVE EXPERIENCED THE VERY
SAME KINDS OF CONCERNS WITH
RESPECT TO GRADUATING. THEM ON
TIME AND SO I WOULD I WOULD HOPE
THAT.
.
YOU WOULD BE ABLE TO INCLUDE A
THAT THE PRIVATE UNIVERSITIES
THAT THE STUDENTS IN THOSE
PRIVATE UNIVERSITY HAVING THE
SAME KINDS OF DIFFICULTIES. AND
I THINK OF AN INQUIRY INTO IT
WOULD FIND A LOT OF US. A LOT OF
INFORMATION TO DEMONSTRATE THE
NEED.
MR LEVINE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
AS A CSU SOON HE TOOK THREE
SUMMERS OF SUMMER SCHOOL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MS QUIRK
SILVA.
NEEDING A SECOND.
SECOND BY MS IRWIN.
I THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THE BILL.
LIKE THE AUTHOR AND LIKE.
OTHERS OF ON THE DIE IS HERE
ALSO TOOK ADVANTAGE OF SUMMER
SCHOOL TO MAKE SURE THAT I COULD
GRADUATE. WITHIN THE FOUR YEARS
SO I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THE BILL FORWARD I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. AS AN
INCENTIVE FOR CAL GRANT
RECIPIENTS
OF UC AND CSU TO FINISH THEIR
DEGREES. ON TIME. AS THE
WITNESSES STATED WHICH IS
SOMETHING THAT WE ALL WANT.
OF RECOGNIZING THIS BILL WILL
HAVE A SIGNIFICANT FISCAL IMPACT
I URGE THE AUTHOR TO CONSIDER
THE COST ISSUE AND TO LOOK AT
SOME OF THE REMEDIES. THAT ARE
RAISED IN THEIR ANALYSIS
SO THE MOTION WAS DUE PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS.
MADAM SECRETARY OF YOU WOULD
CABALLERO.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER.
BAKER AYE ARAMBULA BLOOM.
CHAVEZ IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW. PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO WEBER.
WEBER I.
PAGE ZERO YOUR BILL IS OUT I
WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
IAM GOING TO LOOK TO MISS.
.
CABALLERO FOR HER INDULGENCE.
IF THE IF YOU AYE I MIGHT.
MISTER CUNNINGHAM HAS A
STUDENTS HERE FROM CAL POLY
POMONA WHO HAVE TO DRIVE BACK TO
CAL POLY. THIS AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU MISS GOV AHEAD OF.
SO WE WILL GO TO ITEM SIX
MISTER CUNNINGHAM.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY FIVE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
MY STUDENT WITNESSES ARE.
ON THEIR WAY THAT'LL GET STARTED
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME.
.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY THREE EIGHTY FIVE
AND I LIKE TO START BY ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND
THANK THEM FOR THE. HARD WORK ON
THIS.
OVER THE COURSE OF A SINGLE
SCHOOL YEAR THE AVERAGE COLLEGE
STUDENT.
ACCORDING TO THE COLLEGE BOARD
SPENDS MORE THAN TWELVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS ON TEXTBOOKS IN THE
TERRACE.
TWELVE HUNDRED DOLLARS A YEAR
FOR THE AVERAGE COLLEGE TO.
IT IS ESTIMATED THAT UP TO SIXTY
FIVE PERCENT OF STUDENTS.
SKIP BUYING THE REQUIRED
TEXTBOOKS.
AT SOME POINT THEIR COLLEGE
CAREER.
BECAUSE OF LACK OF
AFFORDABILITY.
WHICH BEGS THE QUESTION HOW THEY
ARE PASSING THOSE CLASSES.
BUT WE OF SIXTY FIVE PERCENT
IT'S ESTIMATED SKIP BUYING
TEXTBOOKS FOR CLASSES.
THIS BILL URGES PUBLISHERS OF
TEXTBOOKS TO PROVIDE A MORE
DETAILED DESCRIPTION OF.
THE NEWEST EDITION OF A BOOK
AND HOW IT CHANGES FROM THE OLD
ADDITION.
AND OUR HOPE IN DOING THIS IS TO
PROVIDE MORE TRANSPARENCY. SO
THAT STUDENTS CAN BE ASSESSING
AND.
MEASURING WHETHER THEY NEED TO
BUY THE NEW EDITION THE TEXTBOOK
WHETHER THEY CAN GET BY WITH THE
OLD ONE.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO GIVE
STUDENTS MORE CONCRETE
INFORMATION AT ALL HELP.
MARGINALLY BUT SIGNIFICANTLY
WITH COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY.
NOW WITH THAT I JUST WELCOME ANY
QUESTIONS I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE
MY TO STUDENT WITNESSES THAT ARE
HERE TO GIVE A FIRST HAND
PERSPECTIVE FROM CAL POLY SAN
LUIS OBISPO.
I BONTA MEDINA AND LINDSAY
WALLACE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN MEDINA AN
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR HAVING US HERE
TODAY.
MY NAME IS LINDSAY WALLACE AND
I'M A THIRD YEAR POLITICAL
SCIENCE MAJOR AT CAL POLY
ORIGINALLY FROM FRESNO
CALIFORNIA.
I HERE BEFORE YOU TODAY TO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON OUR PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. OUR BILL LIKE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CUNNINGHAM
MENTIONED WOULD WORK TO INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY ABOUT CHANGES MADE
TEXTBOOK ADDITIONS.
SO THAT STUDENTS CAN BETTER MAKE
AN ECONOMICALLY SOUND DECISION
WHEN PURCHASING BOOKS.
AS A FINANCIALLY INDEPENDENT
COLLEGE STUDENT. I WORK PART
TIME AND ATTEND SCHOOL FULL
TIME.
CURRENTLY I CANNOT AFFORD GAS
AND GROCERIES WITHIN THE SAME
WEEK.
WHILE THE FORTY OR FIFTY DOLLARS
SAVED ON BUYING OLDER TEXTBOOKS
MIGHT NOT SEEM LIKE MUCH.
IT ADDS UP.
IF YOU'RE TAKING FOR FIVE
CLASSES A QUARTER THAT AMOUNTS
TO HUNDRED AND SIXTY TO TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS A QUARTER THAT
YOU COULD BE SAVING. THAT MONEY
COULD BE GROCERY ARE GAS FOR AN
ENTIRE MONTH.
OR A BIG CHUNK OF YOUR RENT
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THAT AN
INCREASING AMOUNT OF HOMELESS
STUDENTS.
EVERY YEARS OCCURRING ONE IN TEN
STUDENTS FACE THE RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS IN THE CSU SYSTEM
ALONE.
THAT MONEY IS THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN WORKING AN EXTRA
EIGHTEEN HOURS.
TO PAY FOR THE BOOKS OR SPENDING
THOSE EIGHTEEN HOURS ACTUALLY
READING THE TEXT BOOKS AND
STUDYING.
COLLEGE STUDENTS ARE COST
BENEFIT ANALYZERS BECAUSE THE
INCREASINGLY HEFTY PRICE TAG OF
COLLEGE FORCES US TO BE.
AND THIS IS WHY WE BELIEVE THAT
STUDENTS WILL SEEK OUT THE
INFORMATION. TEXTBOOK
TRANSPARENCY THAT ARE BILL WOULD
PROVIDE.
THIS BILL WOULD ENCOURAGE
PUBLISHERS TO POST THE CHANGES
MADE FROM ADDITION TO ADDITION
A DECISION ON WHICH TEXTBOOK
ADDITION TO PURCHASE.
THEY CAN DETERMINE FOR
THEMSELVES IF THE NEWER VERSION
IS VITAL.
THE STUDENTS WILL BE ABLE TO
COMPARE THE DIFFERENCES IF THERE
ARE ANY AND THEN COMPARE THE
COSTS.
OUR BILL IS SIMPLY GIVING MORE
POWER TO THE MOST IMPORTANT
CONSUMER WHEN IT COMES TO BUYING
TEXTBOOKS.
THE STUDENTS.
BY INCREASING TRANSPARENCY WE
CAN LOWER THE BURDEN OF
PURCHASING TEXTBOOKS ON
STUDENTS.
WITH THE COST OF COLLEGE AT AN
ALL TIM HIGH THIS IS A LANDMARK
PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT COULD
ULTIMATELY HELP COLLEGE STUDENTS
ALL ACROSS CALIFORNIA SUCCEED.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME.
THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN MEDINA AN HONORABLE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS IVANA MEDINA
AND I'M A FOURTH YEAR POLITICAL
SCIENCE MAJOR I PALPABLY SAN
LUIS OBISPO. I'M HERE TODAY TO
ADVOCATE FOR HIGHER EDUCATION
STUDENTS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AS A STUDENT I SPEND COUNTLESS
HOURS AT THE BEGINNING OF EACH
QUARTER SEARCHING ONLINE MY
TEXTBOOKS FOR THE QUARTER.
AND THERE'S NOTHING MORE
FRUSTRATING THAN GOING YOU SEEN
MY TEXT. FOR THE LATEST ADDITION
AND THEN SEEN THAT PREVIOUS A
DUCK PREVIOUS EDITION OF A
TEXTBOOK FOR LESS THAN HALF OF
IT. OBVIOUSLY WANT TO MAKE IT
ECONOMICALLY SOUND DECISION AND
BUY THE CHEAPER EDITION OF A
TEXTBOOK.
BUT THEN I'M LEFT WONDERING IS
THIS IS GOING TO HURT ME IN THE
CLASSROOM SETTING.
.
A MANY COULD SIX SIX FOUR SIX BE
WILL GIVE STUDENTS A CHANCE TO
MAKE REASONABLE DECISIONS WHEN
PURCHASING TEXTBOOKS.
STUDENTS CAN THEN ASK THEMSELVES
THE FOLLOWING QUESTIONS.
IS OUR SUBSTANTIAL CLIENT CHANGE
IN THE NEW ADDITION. WHAT
PROBLEMS HAVE CHANGED?
IS THE PRICE DIFFERENCE WORTH
IT.
CURRENT LAW DOES NOT INCLUDE THE
MENTION OF STUDENTS HAVING THIS
RIGHT TO TRANSPARENCY AND WE
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE THIS RIGHT
UPS.
BILL AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY FIVE
IS SIMPLY ASKING FOR AN
EXTENSION OF TRANSPARENCY TO THE
STUDENTS AS WELL AS EASY ACCESS
TO INFORMATION.
TEXT BOOKS I HAVE LITTLE TO NO
EXPLANATION OF HOW THE ADDITION
HAS BEEN CHANGED MAKE IT VERY
DIFFICULT FOR STUDENTS TO
DISTINGUISH IF THEY NEED THAT
NEW LATEST ADDITION.
THERE ARE MANY EXAMPLES ONLINE
OF PUBLISHERS NOT THOROUGHLY
DISCLOSING THIS INFORMATION.
HOWEVER THERE ARE SOME
PUBLISHERS THAT ARE ACTUALLY NOT
DISCLOSING INFORMATION AND
SHOWING GREAT ADDITIONS FROM
CHAPTER TO CHAPTER AND THAT'S
WHAT WE WANT TO SEE FOR ALL
TEXTBOOKS ONLINE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT
OF BILL TWENTY THREE EIGHTY FIVE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
YOU PLEASE COME FORWARD.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN MEDINA AND
HONORABLE MEMBERS FOR HAVING US
HERE TODAY MY NAME'S CHASE DEAN
AND I AM A FOURTH YEAR POLITICAL
SCIENCE MAJOR FROM CAL POLY SAN
LUIS OBISPO.
OUR BILL AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY
FIVE THE STEP IN THE RIGHT
FIGHT FOR AFFORDABILITY AND
HIGHER EDUCATION.
AS CURRENT LAW STAND STUDENTS
ARE NOT MENTIONED AS INDIVIDUALS
WERE GRANTED INFORMATION
PERTAINING TO. THE DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN TEXTBOOKS DESPITE
FACULTY IN THAT CONVERSATION.
AB TWENTY THREE FIVE SIX TO PUT
ONE OF THE PRIMARY CONSUMERS OF
TEXTBOOKS STUDENTS FIRST.
ARBIL CAN MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
IT COULD BE THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN WHETHER A STUDENT EATS
OR PAYS RENT.
STUDENTS ALREADY USE RESOURCES
TO COMPARE TEXTBOOK PRICES SO
GRANTED THIS INFORMATION TO
STUDENTS WILL CERTAINLY BE OUR
ALLIES.
BY URGING PUBLISHERS TO DISPLAY
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN EDITIONS ON
THEIR WEBSITE STUDENTS WERE ABLE
TO BE ABLE TO DECIDE WHETHER THE
INFORMATION.
WHETHER THAT NEED WHETHER THEY
NEED THE TWO HUNDRED DOLLAR
TEXTBOOKS OR THE FIFTY DOLLAR
PREVIOUS EDITION WILL SUFFICE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
HELLO MY NAME IS JESSE VIOLENCE
YAK COW PLACE IN THIS THIS PHONE
I SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME'S JOEY HOLLERING
INCIDENT A COUPLE AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS JAMIE BACK ON
MSN ACCOUNT FALLING AND I
SUPPORT AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY
FIVE.
HI MY NAME IS VICTORIA ATTORNEY
KEVIN AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME'S MICHAELKORS
ACCOMPLICE IN THIS PROPOSAL
OBISPO STRONG SUPPORT TWENTY THE
EIGHTY FIVE.
HI MY NAME'S CAITLIN BECAUSE I
AM A IS AT CAL POLLY SAN LUIS
OBISPO AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS MICHAEL HUMOR A
CYNIC HELPFULLY SAN LUIS OBISPO
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HOW I MY NAME'S CHRISTINE DEAN
I'M A STACK CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY OF SACRAMENTO AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL?
BECAUSE YOU'RE A JUDGE AND I'M
IT VOLUNTEERS BOTHERS WOULD A
STUDENT THIS WORKED WITH THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
THE GENTLEMAN WHO NEEDS NO
INTRODUCTION.
ANY ANY TWEETERS.
AND YOU.
TWO WINNERS.
NO ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
YES.
IT IF WE WOULD GO AHEAD MAKE
ROOM WILL MAKE ROOM FOR YOU
HERE.
POTS.
STILL SHE WAS SAKE WITH THE
ASSOCIATION AMERICAN PUBLISHERS
OF WERE OPPOSED TO THE BILL.
WE RECOGNIZE THE INTENT AND WE
SUPPORT THE TRANSPARENCY IN THE
OVERALL PROVISIONS IN THE
APPROACH OF THE BILL.
WILL WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE IS
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL.
TO CROSS REFERENCE IT TO THE
FEDERAL LAW WHICH ALREADY HAS
SOME SIMILAR PROVISIONS IN THE
SAME OBJECTIVES AND AS WE NOTED
IN OUR LETTER. WE CITED THE
SECTION OF THE FEDERAL LAW WHICH
IS ALMOST IDENTICAL TO WHAT THE
WHAT THE.
PROVISIONS IN STAKEHOLDER DOING
ON BY CROSS REFERENCING IT TO
THE FEDERAL LAW WILL HELP ENSURE
THAT THERE'S CONSISTENCY IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND THE
ENFORCEMENT ADOPTION. OF THE
ROOTS OF.
THE PROVISIONS OF BOTH THE
STATE LAW IN THE FEDERAL LAW.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NINE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE MISS BAKER.
THANK YOU HAVE. WHICH CAN HAVE
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND IT
WAS NO SURPRISE AT ALL TO SEE
OUR FORMER CALL A FORMER
COLLEAGUE MISTER SASHA AND
CONTINUING TO HELP STUDENTS SAID
THANK YOU FOR COMING ALL THE WAY
UP HERE AND BEING A PART. OF THE
HEARING AND IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE.
YOUR BILL IS MORE ACCESSIBLE FOR
STUDENTS AND THE FEDERAL
STANDARDS WOULD BE IF WE JUST
CONFORM TO FEDERAL LAW.
WOULD BE ABLE TO HAVE THE FULL.
AMOUNT OF DISCLOSURE THAT'S MOST
CRITICAL TO GET TO FOR THE
STUDENTS.
IS IS THAT CORRECT OR IS THERE
IN MY NOT RIGHT ABOUT THAT
THAT'S RIGHT DID AND TWO
COMMENTS IN RESPONSE THAT VERY
QUESTION THE FIRST IS THERE'S NO
CALIFORNIA. LAW RIGHT NOW THAT
COVERS THIS ISSUE IN THE FEDERAL
LAW DOESN'T REQUIRE THE LEVEL OF
DETAIL OF EXPLANATION ABOUT THE
CHANGES.
AND REALLY WHAT WE'RE LOOKING TO
DO IS TRY TO.
DRIVE THE MARKET A POSITIVE WAY
BY GIVING THE STUDENTS
INFORMATION ABOUT. THE ARE THEY
HAVE THEY REARRANGED COMMAS OR
REARRANGE HOPE PARAGRAPHS FOR
THEIR NEW CHAPTERS THAT HAVE
BEEN ADDED. TO THE COURSE
MATERIAL THAT MIGHT BE
SUBSTANTIVE AND THIS GOES A
LITTLE BIT FURTHER THAN.
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT THE
WITNESS I THINK THIS BILL GOES A
BIT FURTHER IN WHAT THE FEDERAL
LAWS. IS REQUIRING RIGHT NOW
THANK YOU FOR CLARIFYING THAT.
MISTER PATTERSON.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I'M ALSO WANTED TO THANK
THE STUDENTS FOR FOR COMING.
I REALLY APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE TAKING
THIS ON AND I'M HOPING THAT THIS
REALLY BEGINS TO BE A.
AB AS THOROUGH IN DEEP AN EFFORT
TO TRY TO GET THIS A PARADIGM
TEXTBOOK CHANGED.
WE LIVE IN THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY.
THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
TECHNOLOGY FOR DIGITALIZATION
FOR LESS OF A REASONABLE
LICENSING FEE TO GET SECTIONS OF
TEXT BOOKS NECESSARY TO. TO TO
GET THROUGH THE.
THE PROGRAMS I I I MUST SAY
THAT.
.
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
UNDER THE PRESIDENCY DR CASTRO
HAS TAKEN THIS VERY VERY
SERIOUSLY. AND HAVE SOME PILOT
PROJECTS THAT ARE THAT ARE DOING
SOME OF THAT.
BUT I WANT TO ENCOURAGE THE
STUDENTS.
TO CONTINUE TO COME BEFORE US.
TO GET THIS PARADIGM
SHIFTED ARE. AM ALL I.
GRADUATED FROM PRESENT STATE.
ALL THROUGH MY KIDS WENT THERE
MY HOPE MY GRANDKIDS ARE GOING
TO GO THERE. YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT THIS MOST SIGNIFICANT.
HURDLE HERE IS THAT HUGE
EXPENSIVE TEXTBOOKS AND
OFTENTIMES THE.
MY NEW. AMOUNT OF CHANGE THAT IS
FROM ONE TEXTBOOK TO ANOTHER AND
YET THE REQUIREMENT TO HAVE TO
PURCHASE.
I THINK THIS IS A SYSTEM THAT.
REALLY IS GOING TO HAVE TO HAVE
SOME MODERNIZATION AND SOME
SERIOUS REFORM AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT YOU IN
THE STUDENTS ARE BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND. MAKING THIS A VERY
IMPORTANT DATA. NO ISSUE HOW
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR AND A LOT OF
STUDENTS AND BE GRATEFUL THAT
THIS IN FACT GIVES STUDENTS
CHOICES AND OPTIONS THAT.
MANAGE DOWNWARD THERE SPIRALING
COSTS OF TEXTBOOKS THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING FORWARD.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS SEEN NINE
CHIU CUNNINGHAM WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
I WOULD JUST SAY. TO PIGGYBACK
ON THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS COMMENTS
THIS IS
I THINK A MODEST AND REASONABLE
STEP INTO RIGHT DIRECTION OF
INCREASED TRANSPARENCY IN TRYING
TO MODERNIZE. THE SYSTEM THAT IN
SOME IN SOME WAYS. IS A LITTLE
ANTIQUATED PERHAPS AND.
I'D LOVE TO TAKE ALL THE CREDIT
FOR THIS IDEA BUT IT WAS A
STUDENT COLLABORATION WITH THE
MY PREDECESSOR CACHO. VERY.
THANKFUL FOR BE INDULGENCE
TODAY THAT WHAT THE STUDENTS
COME UP AND TESTIFY.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY
BOAT. AQ.
BUT THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THE BILL FORWARD. AND.
PUT PARTY THANK YOU TO ALL THE
STUDENTS FROM CAL POLY POMONA
WHO PUT A LOT EFFORT AND
THOUGHT.
INTO THIS BILL. I'M SORRY CAL
POLY NNOVA SAN LUIS OBISPO
I WAS REALLY IN A BAD SPOT THERE
DO I CORRECT. THANK YOU.
AND IT'S.
CAL POLLY SAN LUIS OBISPO.
WE DO HAVE TO CAL POLICY MAKE
SURE GET THE RIGHT ONE. THANK
YOU TO THE STUDENTS FOR ALL
THEIR HARD WORK OTHER
THOUGHTFULNESS FOR BRINGING.
AN IMPORTANT BILL TO US.
ASA WITH THAT.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MS BAKER
SECOND BY MS QUIRK SILVA.
AND MR LEVIN AND MADAM SECRETARY
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
MEDINA I'VE MEDINA AYE BAKER.
BAKER AYE ARAMBULA.
BLOOM.
CHAVEZ.
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE AYE LOW. PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
NINE ZERO THE BILL IS OUT WE
WILL KEEP IT OPEN FOR. ABSENT
MEMBERS SAFE TRAVEL HOPE.
BUT AUTHORS WRITE
.
I GOT ANOTHER WOULD. DO IT
AGAIN.
MEMBERS.
THE CLAIM.
IT'S GOT HERE HAD SOME PLACE SO
.
NOW.
WE HAD NO.
YEAH GIPSON.
YEAH.
WE NEED A. PERSON SUCH.
WHAT WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO CONSENT
ITEMS LIKE COULD HAVE A MOTION?
MOVED BY MISTER LEVINE
SECOND BY MISTER SANTIAGO.
THEN SECRETARY.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER.
ARAMBULA BLOOM.
CHAVEZ IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE LEVINE LEVINE AYE LOW.
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
EIGHT ZERO CONSENT ITEMS ARE OUT
WILL KEEP IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS
.
WE GO.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE W..
THANK YOU PROBLEM.
SO WE'LL MOVE TO ITEM THREE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE SIXTY
SIX.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AM PLEASED TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY ONE SIXTY SIX THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BILL. I WOULD
LIKE TO THINK COMMITTEE STAFF ON
THE RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS AND
WE ACCEPT THOSE AMENDMENT.
THE CALIFORNIA FARM BILL HAS
THREE CORE TENANTS FIRST
IMPROVES THE STATE'S STANCE
TOWARDS THE BUSINESS OF
AGRICULTURE.
CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY HAS SEEN DRAMATIC
CHANGES IN HOW IT MUST OPERATE.
FOOD SAFETY CONCERNS FROM THE
CONSUMER STATE REGULATIONS ON
PESTICIDES WATER ENERGY SOIL AND
WORKERS AND IN THE PAST TWO
YEARS A DRAMATIC CHANGE IN
AVAILABLE WORKERS REGARDLESS OF
WAGES AND OVERTIME. THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BILL TAKES
ACTION TO IMPROVE THE STATE'S
INDUSTRIES WORKING RELATIONSHIP
TODAY. IT EASES REGULATORY
COMPLEX WITH THE CREATION OF A
CDFA LED MULTI AGENCY REVIEW
COUNCIL. TO IDENTIFY AND
RECOMMEND RESOLUTION WHEN
COMPLIANCE WITH ONE REGULATION.
POTENTIALLY CREATES CONFLICT
WITH ANOTHER IT FUNDS FORTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO SEE IF IT CDF
PHASE INVASIVE PLANT AND PEST
MANAGEMENT PROGRAMS. FUNDS ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION TO THE
CALIFORNIA GROWN MARKETING
AGREEMENT.
FIND TO ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
TO CDFA FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF A
CENTRALIZED AG BUSINESS PORTAL.
AND REQUIRES THE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT TO
DEDICATE RESOURCES TO CAPTURE
THE FARM TO FORK ECONOMIC IMPACT
OF AGRICULTURE.
SECOND IT CREATES A STATEWIDE AG
INNOVATION PLATFORM.
AG IN RURAL CALIFORNIA OR IF IN
INTRINSICALLY INTERTWINED AND
AND AS GO GOES AG SO GOES RURAL
CALIFORNIA. I WANTED TO IMPROVE
THE ECONOMIC CONDITION FOR RURAL
RESIDENTS IN MY COMMUNITY AND I
WAS THINKING INITIALLY WAS GOING
TO BE ACT TOURISM. BUT I QUICKLY
REALIZED THAT THE AG INDUSTRY
QUESTIONS ITS SURVIVAL IN THE
STATE. AND THAT LEAVING WILL BE
A DEATH BLOW TO RURAL
COMMUNITIES AND TO EFFORTS TO
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GASES.
SO IT IS NOT ABOUT ACT TOURISM
AT THE GROUND LEVEL IT'S ABOUT
SAVING AG SO THERE CAN BE AG
TOURS IN THE FUTURE.
WE REALIZE THAT PROGRAMS LIKE
SWEET AND HEALTHY SOILS ARE
OVERSUBSCRIBED TIMELY GRANT
PROGRAMS.
THAT IMPROVE AG PRACTICES.
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR WEALTH
CREATION IN RURAL AREAS THROUGH
AG TECH ISRAEL IF CALIFORNIA
CAPTURES ACT TECH FOCUSED
VENTURE CAPITAL. AND IS HOME TO
AG TECH INNOVATORS AND START UP
COMPANIES IN A REALLY GOOD
EXAMPLE. IS THE BLUE REVELAR
RIVER TECHNOLOGY PRECISION
WEEDING THROUGH LASERS PROGRAM
THAT WAS ACQUIRED BY JOHN DEERE
FOR OVER THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN AND THIS IS THIS IS
PERCENT PRECISION WEEDING THAT.
TAKES NO.
HUMAN EFFORT.
THE CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU AT
BILL BRINGS BEST USES TOGETHER
FOR A STATEWIDE PAT PLATFORM IT
FINDS TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
DEVELOP THE AGRICULTURE
TECHNOLOGY INNOVATION INSTITUTE
AT CDFA IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. AND
ITS MODELED OFF OF FOUR OTHER
STATE CREATE INSTITUTES.
TO IDENTIFY AND COMMERCIALIZE
NASCENT TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRIES
IT FUNDS TEN MILLION ANNUALLY TO
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE AND NATURAL
RESOURCES DIVISION TOUGH HIGHER
AND RETRAIN COOPERATIVE
EXTENSION EXPERT ADVISORS. AND
IT PROVIDES INCENTIVE TAX
CREDITS TO ADOPTERS OF
AGRICULTURE TECHNOLOGY ONLY WHEN
DEPLOYED ON PRODUCING
HARVESTABLE ACRES WITH THE GOAL
TO REDUCE ENERGY. WATER
FERTILIZER PESTICIDE USE OR TO
AUTOMATE PLANTING THINNING
HARVESTING YOUR PRODUCTION
SERVICES IT EXPANDS ON THE
REGIONAL EFFORTS IN SALINAS
FRESNO SAN LUIS OBISPO AND
DAVIS.
TO DEVELOP TECHNOLOGY INCUBATOR
INCUBATORS AND ACCELERATORS AND
IT CONDUCTS A STATEWIDE ON FARM
BROADBAND SURVEY SO THAT
STAKEHOLDERS CAN MAP OUT GAPS IN
ABILITY TO A. ADOPT PRECISION AG
TECH.
IT CREATES A STATEWIDE PLATFORM
THROUGH THE INSTITUTE AND THE
TAX CREDIT WILL BRING VENTURE
CAPITAL FUNDED COMPANIES BLOWING
IN THE CALIFORNIA. WE DOMINATE
OTHER TECH VERTICALS AND WE WE
DOMINATE AG PRODUCTION WERE NOT
STRUCTURED TO DOMINATE AG TECH.
AND THIRD AND FINALLY IT
PROVIDES FOR REAL ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT OPPORTUNITIES SINCE
THE GREAT RECESSION CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY RECOVER ECONOMIC
RECOVERY HAS BEEN IN EVEN AND
RHEA RURAL COMMUNITIES FEEL LEFT
BEHIND. THE TRUTH IS THAT THE
BAY AREA WITH JUST TWENTY
PERCENT OF THE STATE'S
POPULATION HAS GENERATED FORTY
PERCENT OF THE JOB GROWTH.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF HIGH WAGE
JOB GROWTH HAS OCCURRED IN A
HANDFUL OF ASSEMBLY DEPT
DISTRICT CENTERED AROUND URBAN
TECH CENTERS. SO THE FARM BILL.
THE CALIFORNIA FARM BILL TRICK
TRAINS RURAL CALIFORNIA YOUTH
FOR FARMS OF THE FUTURE IT
CREATES SMART FARMS A COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO BE AG TECH SHOWCASES
AND REAL WORLD CAREER PACKED. IT
ENCOURAGES AG TECH COURSEWORK
EXPANSION TO THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM.
THE AG TECH INNOVATION INSTITUTE
WILL VET AND APPROVE
TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE CREDIT
WORTHY. OPERATORS WILL HAVE TO
SHOW THAT THE TECHNOLOGY IS
DEPLOYED ON THE ACRES IN
PRODUCTION WHAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT ABOUT THIS IS THAT I'M
A LOT OF THE ACTIVE. TECH THAT'S
BEEN CREATED HAS BEEN CREATED BY
INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE NO
COMMITTEE.
NO CONNECTION TO AGRICULTURE
AND SO EACH COMMODITY EACH OP
PRODUCT THAT'S GOING TO
CALIFORNIA.
HAS DIFFERENT NEEDS DIFFERENT
SOIL NEEDS DIFFERENT WATERY
NEEDS AND SO THIS.
INSTITUTE WILL BE PERFECTLY
POISED TO TEST THESE MASON
TECHNOLOGIES TO DETERMINE
WHETHER THEY'RE REALLY GOING TO
WORK.
JOBS ON THE FARM WILL CHANGE
THE CURRENT FARMWORKERS OVER
FIFTY FIVE IN THE LABOR POOL IS
FINE EIGHT NOW FEWER JOBS ARE IN
THE FIELD BUT THEY WILL BE IN A.
IN A OF A DIFFERENT NATURE
HIGHER PAYING ABLE TO MANAGE IN
IN A GREAT WITH TECHNOLOGY.
IT WILL RESULT IN THE RETENTION
OF INTELLECTUAL CAPITAL IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA THEY WON'T HAVE TO
MOVE TO THE SILICON FOR VALLEY
TO WORK AT THAT. TECH IN AG TECH
AND THE RETURN OF TECH START UP
EXECUTIVES TO RURAL ROOTS LIKE
MEGAN NEWNESS OF INSIGHT WHO
MOVED BACK TO GUSTINE AFTER TEN
YEARS IN THE AEROSPACE INDUSTRY.
APPLYING HER TECH EXPERIENCE TO
OUR HOME DOWN INDUSTRIES NEEDS
WITH ME TODAY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY.
SIX OUR CLINIC CAO CAO DIDN'T
DEAN OF THE CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT FROM PART NOW
COLLEGE. I GLENN IF YOU MISSED
AND VICE PRESIDENT PRESIDENT OF
YOU SEE AND ARE NANCY WOULD GET
AS AGRICULTURE WATER AND
ENVIRONMENT. AND ENVIRONMENTAL
TECHNOLOGY SECTOR NAVIGATOR
RETHINK COMMUNITY COLLEGE THANK
YOU AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MY NAME
IS GLENDA HUMUS DENY SERVICE
VICE PRESIDENT OF BAGAN NATURAL
RESOURCES FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. ARE SPEAKING TODAY
IS AN EXPERT WITHIN MY FIELD IN
A PRIVATE INDIVIDUAL NOT AN
OFFICIAL REPRESENTATIVE OF YOU
SEE.
A IN OUR SERVICES THE PUBLIC
SERVICE ARM FOR THE UC SYSTEM
AND PROVIDES LEADERSHIP FOR UC'S
FEDERAL RESPONSIBILITIES AS A
LAND GRANT UNIVERSITY. THIS
INCLUDES COOPERATIVE EXTENSION
AND THE AGRICULTURAL EXPERIMENT
STATIONS.
WE SERVE ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTS
OF CALIFORNIA WORKING CLOSELY
WITH FARMERS GOVERNMENT AGENCIES
AND OTHER PARTNERS TO PROVIDE
SCIENCE BASED INFORMATION AND
DELIVER SOLUTIONS IN A WIDE
ARRAY OF DISCIPLINES.
OUR COOPERATIVE EXTENSION
ADVISORS FURTHERMORE COORDINATE
OVER TWENTY THOUSAND VOLUNTEERS
THROUGH FOR H. MASTER GARDENER
MASTER FOOD PRESERVER AND THE
CALIFORNIA NATURALIST PROGRAMS.
YOU SEE A IN OUR COOP
COLLABORATES WITH ALL TEN UC
CAMPUSES.
THE CSU SYSTEM OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES NONPROFITS THE PRIVATE
SECTOR AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS IN
EVERY CORNER OF THE STATE.
IT'S TRUE THAT THE NUMBER OF
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION ADVISORS
HAVE FALLEN DRASTICALLY OVER THE
PAST TWENTY YEARS.
WITH DRAMATIC BUDGET CUTS TO YOU
SEE DURING THE NINETIES
RECESSION AND THE TWO THOUSAND
AND EIGHT ECONOMIC CRISIS. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT HALF AS
MANY COOPERATIVE EXTENSION
ADVISORS AND SCIENTISTS THAT WE
HAD TWENTY FIVE YEARS AGO.
SOME OF THIS IS BECAUSE A IN OUR
IS A DIVISION WITHIN THE UC
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT AND AS
THE UC OP BUDGET IS CUT IT
AFFECTS FUNDING FOR FOR AGING
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION.
THE FUNDING IN AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY SIX WOULD PROVIDE ROUGHLY
FORTY FIVE NEW SCIENTIST
ALLOWING US TO TARGET SOME OF
THE SEVERE CHALLENGES WE
CURRENTLY FACING CALIFORNIA.
DROUGHT CLIMATE CHANGE INVASIVE
SPECIES NATURAL DISASTERS AND
MORE. THAT SAID I MUST MAKE IT
CLEAR THAT THE YOU SEE DOES NOT
HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION ON
THIS BILL RIGHT NOW. IN CLOSING
WE ARE INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CUBBY EURO
SUPPORT AND INTEREST IN
REBUILDING CALIFORNIA'S
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION SYSTEM
THANK YOU.
HELLO AND THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME COME MY NAME IS CLINT CAO
THEN THE DEAN OF CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT HARTNELL
COLLEGE IN SALINAS.
.
I'VE BEEN IN THE AG TECH SPACE
SINCE TWO THOUSAND TWO BOTH.
SPENT OVER TEN YEARS OUT IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY THAT WEST HILLS
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
TEACHING PRECISION AGRICULTURE
AN INTEGRATION. OF GPS AND GIS
INTO THE CURRICULUM WHERE WE'RE
AT THAT SAME TIME HARTNELL AS IT
HAS BEEN DOING A LOT OF THIS IN
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT MADE US.
REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THIS BILL
IS WHEN WE LOOK AT IT IT PUTS IN
PERSPECTIVE WHAT A CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IS.
AND HOW WE CAN REALLY SOLVE A
LOT OF OUR EQUITY ISSUES AND SO
IN A TYPICAL AG TECH CLASSROOMS
GONNA WALK IN A THIRD OF THE
STUDENTS ARE YOU HAVE A
BACHELORS DEGREE. THEY'RE COMING
BACK TO THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FOR UP SKILLS AND FOCUS ON THE
SPECIALTY CROPS ON THOSE TYPES
OF THINGS AND HOW TO INTEGRATE
THAT TECHNOLOGY. A THIRD OF THE
STUDENTS ARE RIGHT OUT OF HIGH
SCHOOL THEY'RE EXCITED THEY
WANNA LEARN ANYONE INTEGRATE
THIS TYPE OF THING. THE OTHER
THIRD OF THE STUDENTS ARE PEOPLE
THAT ARE NONTRADITIONAL THEY'RE
COMING OUT OF THE FIELDS ARE
COMING BACK AND GETTING RETOOLED
AND WANTING TO GET IN INTO THE
MARKET THE EXCITEMENT OF THIS
BILL. IS GOING TO BRING A LOT OF
THE STAKEHOLDERS TOGETHER SO WE
CAN GO TO THAT ONE PLACE AND
FIND SOME OF THIS GREAT.
TECHNOLOGY THAT WE CAN PUT INTO
OUR STUDENTS HANDS.
AND AND TRULY HAVE IT BE
ACTIONABLE IN OUR IN OUR AREA
THERE WAS A CONVERSATION THAT
THIS IS A LITTLE BIT
DUPLICATIVE.
OF THE TNC.
PROCESS OUT THERE THIS IS
ACTUALLY THAT IN ADDITION TO AND
SO WE ARE VERY EXCITED SO
PARTNER.
HARTNELL IS A VERY EXCITED TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
OTHER WOULD. WORK.
SO WE WE WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT. TWO MINUTES WEEK WE
HAD THAT NOW WE'RE GOING TO
WITNESSES OVER HERE.
AARON DRIVER IN SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF THE ALLMAN ALLIANCE
THE GRAIN AND FEED ASSOCIATION
EIGHT FARMERS FOR ASSOCIATION
PACIFIC EGG AND POULTRY PEAR
GROWERS BEING SHIPPERS. WHEAT
GROWERS SEEDS AND WAREHOUSE
ASSOCIATION THINKING.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ROBERT OR FROM
THE LOCAL GROUP ON BEHALF OF THE
SPONSOR OF THE BILL WEST HILLS
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
COALINGA THE MORE FIREBAUGH.
WITH THE STUDENT BODY IS TWO
THIRDS DISADVANTAGED WE'RE
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
AND VIEW IT IS OF THE WAVE OF
THE FUTURE.
NANCY GOOD TEARS I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM AND I REPRESENT AND THE
SIXTY ONE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE AG NATURAL
RESOURCES. AYE DEGREES AND
CERTIFICATES AND WE ON SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
ANY TWO WINNERS.
JEANNIE MERRILL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE IN
AGRICULTURE NETWORK WHERE A
COALITION OF SUSTAINABLE
ENERGETIC AGRICULTURE
ORGANIZATIONS AND FORMER GROUPS.
WERE VERY PLEASED TO SEE A
CALIFORNIA FARM BILL.
BEING DISCUSSED
IN THE STATE LEGISLATURE AND
SUPPORTIVE OF.
AS SPECIALLY HAVING MORE
RESOURCES FOR COOPER EXTENSION
IS BADLY NEEDED WE'D LIKE TO SEE
A MORE COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO
INCLUDE CONSERVATION MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES WITH A PROVEN TRACK
RECORD. FOR MANY FARMERS AND FOR
THE ENVIRONMENT AND FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PIECE TO
REALLY EMBRACE OTHER
CONSERVATION MANAGEMENT.
CLIMATES WHERE AGRICULTURE AS
WELL AS OPPORTUNITIES FOR
SKILLED OF FARMWORKER CREW
PATHWAYS THANKS.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
STILL A TWEENER SORRY. A COUPLE
TOWERS WITH PESTICIDE ACTION
NETWORK HE AND ON BEHALF OF A
HANDFUL OF OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
THAT SHARED SOME CONCERNS THE
AUTHORS OFFICE WHICH WE CONTINUE
TO DISCUSS AND THANK THEM FOR
THAT. AND THINK THE THE AUTHOR
FOR TAKING A BIG SWING AT A AT A
REALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE. AYE THIS
BILL CONTAINS AN AWFUL LOT AND
IT WHICH WE APPRECIATE.
YEAH BEHALF OF SOME THE FARM
WORKER ROLE COMMUNITIES WE WORK
WITH AYE WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THESE PATHWAYS IN CONSIDERING
PATHWAYS FOR ALL CHILDREN
FARMWORKERS WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE TEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR AG EXTENSION FOR YOU
SEE AND OUR ADVISORS.
AND MUCH LIKE THE COMMENTS FROM
MY THE PERSON BEFORE ME WE'D
LIKE TO SEE MORE OF THE MARRIAGE
BETWEEN TECHNOLOGY.
AND PRACTICES IN A BLACK
PRACTICES IN CONSERVATION
PROVIDING CLEAR DIRECTION FOR
BODIES CLIMATE SMART FARMS IN
THE ACT TECH INSTITUTE TO MOVE
US A LITTLE BIT MORE IN THAT
DIRECTION THAT WE'D LIKE TO SEE
CALIFORNIA HAD.
YOU THINK ANY WHICH IS IN
OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE. ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MS DOCTOR WEB.
I JUST A QUICK THIS IS A.
THIS IS THE DEVELOPMENT OF A
CERTIFICATE PROGRAM IS THAT WHAT
WE'RE DOING HERE.
AND WHAT WERE AUTHORIZING THE.
COMMUNICATIVE DEVELOPING. A
CERTIFICATE PROGRAM IRAQ CORRECT
IT NOW THEY ALREADY HAVE A A AD
CURRICULUM HOW DOES THIS
INTERFACE WITH THAT. AND.
IN MAY IN MAYBE I CAN HAVE THAT
SOME OF THE.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE NOT STAFF IF
YOU WANNA AT HAVE A DETAILED
ANALYSIS BUT THE IDEA IS THAT.
DID THE THAT CAREER TECHNOLOGY.
RIGHT NOW DOESN'T THAT FOR
THEIR VERY. IT INFORMALLY MANY
OF THE OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ARE TO ARE INTEGRATING
TECHNOLOGY INTO WHAT THEY'RE
DOING.
WEST TELLS HAS A SMART FARM
WHERE THEY'VE DEPLOYED A A
NUMBER OF.
.
AT OF THE TECHNOLOGY TYPES IN
ORDERED IT TO TEACH THEIR
STUDENTS BUT WE THINK IT OUGHT
TO BE CURRICULUM BASED AND WE
REALLY THINK THAT IT OUGHT TO
BE.
THAT YOU OUGHT TO BE ABLE TO
GET THE SAME KIND OF CURRICULUM
ALL OVER THE STATE.
AND SO WHAT WHAT.
MY VISION OF IT IS IS THAT IT'S
IT'S THE ABILITY TO HAVE.
YOU SEE A IN OUR.
LOOKING AT DIFFERENT
TECHNOLOGIES TEACHING.
THEY'RE.
.
TECH AG PEOPLE WHAT THOSE
TECHNOLOGIES ARE AND THEN USING
THEM ALSO DOWN IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM.
SO MAYBE WE CAN HAVE SOMEBODY
THAT HAS A BETTER EXPLANATION OF
HOW THAT COMMUNITY COLLEGE
WORKS.
THAT'S THAT'S ALL THANKS FOR
ASKING ACT I WAS THAT DON'T WHEN
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT THIS AND
AND ONE OF THE THINGS WE WITH
THE AND THE C. ID. WAS BASED ON
THE NUMBER OF TRANSFER STUDENTS
TRANSFERRING AND AND SO ACT WE
ORIGINALLY WERE GOING TO GET
ONLY ONE PATHWAY.
AND THAT MANY OF OUR
UNIVERSITIES THAT THAT SIXTEEN
DIFFERENT MAJORS AND SO WE WERE
VERY HAPPY THAT WE GOT THREE BUT
WITHIN THOSE THREE PLANT SCIENCE
ANIMAL SCIENCE BAG BUSINESS.
THEY DON'T HAVE A FOCUS ON.
TECHNOLOGY AND SO ONE OF THE THE
COMPONENTS HERE IS FOR STUDENT
THAT GOES THROUGH A TNC PROCESS.
BUT DOESN'T TRANSFER TO
UNIVERSITY DO THEY HAVE THOSE
THOSE TECHNOLOGY SKILLS TO BE
ABLE TO LAND A JOB.
AND THIS WOULD THIS WOULD
INCREASE THAT.
AND THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS DOES IT GO TO
ALL THE CAMPUS SO SUGGEST
CERTAIN CAMPUSES.
YES AND THEY ARE SUPPORTIVE AND
AT ITS THOSE CAMPUSES THAT OFFER
DEGREES AND CERTIFICATES AND
AGONIZE RESOURCES AND SO THE SEE
EDDIE ALSO IS BASICALLY A MODEL
SO THAT EACH CAMPUS HAS THE
SAME.
COURSE WORK.
AND THEY ARE ALIGNED STATEWIDE
SO THAT THERE'S NO
DIFFERENTIATION BETWEEN THE TWO
BETWEEN ALL THE CAMPUSES THAT
OFFER IT BUT YES THEY ARE
SUPPORTIVE.
AND THEY CAN'T CURRENTLY HAVE A
CURRICULUM THOUGH THAT THEY
PRESENT AN ACT CURRICULUM DON'T
THEY HAVE ONE I WAS READING
ABOUT IT. THEY HAVE THEY HAVE A
CURRICULUM THAT THE COMMUTER
COLLEGE OF THIS OF.
THAT ALL OF THEM USE ARE THOSE
WHO HAVE AG PROGRAMS THEY
ALREADY HAVE A PROGRAM UNTIL YOU
ADDING IS A TECHNOLOGY.
SO RIGHT NOW SO WHAT EACH
COMMUNITY COLLEGE THERE ARE MANY
DISCIPLINES BUT THEN AGAN AFTER
RESOURCES PROGRAM FORCED TO NOT
RESOURCES AG BUSINESS. IN TERMS
OF THEIR COURSE IDENTIFICATION
TRANSFER MODEL CURRICULUM THERE
ARE JUST THREE AG BUSINESS PLANT
SCIENCE AND ANIMAL SCIENCE SO
THIS I DON'T THINK IT'S EXACTLY
DOES A CREATE A TRANSFER MODEL
CURRICULUM. BUT MODEL CURRICULUM
FOR THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM
SPECIFICALLY IN AG TECHNOLOGY SO
WHILE THERE IS EDUCATION GOING
ON IN AB TECHNOLOGY WHAT THERE
IS NOT IS CONFIRMED STATEWIDE
ALIGNMENT IN THE ACT TECHNOLOGY.
AND AND IF.
I CAN INTERJECT AYE AYE.
I BELIEVE THAT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM IS NOT TAKING A
POSITION FROM THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE THEY HAVE NO POSITION.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM.
AND.
.
THERE HAVE BEEN NEXT CONCERNS
EXPRESSED BY THE COMMUNICATIVE
ACADEMIC SAID.
IN ANY OTHER QUESTION MISTER
PATTERSON.
JUST TAKE A QUICK COMMENT ABOUT
WEST HILLS COMMUNICATIVE KNOW
THEM WELL.
IN OUR AREA.
.
WHAT YOU WERE DOING IN THAT AREA
INNOVATIVE LEAD NOT ONLY IN THIS
BUT IN ALL KINDS OF OTHER AREAS
IS REALLY REMARKABLE I'M WANTED
TO COMMEND YOU FOR IT AND JUST?
SUGGEST MY COLLEAGUES AT WHAT
THEY'RE PROPOSING HERE REALLY
DOES WORK GOTTA.
ON THE SITE IN THE IN THE
REGION.
AND I THINK WOULD HAVE TERRIFIC
ADVANTAGE UP AND DOWN THE
STATE'S APPRECIATE YOU BRING IT
FORWARD MEMBERS WELL THANK YOU.
DISCOVER YOUR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
COMMENTS AND AND THE.
THE QUESTIONS.
I'VE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO.
.
ACT TOURS.
OVER THE PAST THIRTY YEARS AND
TECHNOLOGY HAS CHANGED
TREMENDOUSLY IN THIS LAST TWO
YEARS THE ACTORS THAT I'VE DONE.
HAVE BEEN IT I BEEN ASTONISHED
AT THAN THE AMOUNT OF TECHNOLOGY
THAT'S BEING USED ON. IN AYE
DAIRY FARMS IN EGG PRODUCTION
IN.
CITRUS PRODUCTION IN NOT
PRODUCTION HOME IF WE DON'T.
GET OUR WORK FORCE RETRAIN THOSE
WORKERS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
WORKING IN THE FIELD. OR WE
DON'T TRAIN OUR YOUNG YOUNGER
WORKERS THAT ARE INTERESTED IN
AGRICULTURE WERE GOING TO END UP
WITH A RICK GET REAL LACK OF
TALENT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
APPS ARE CREATED SO THAT THE.
THE DRIP IRRIGATION IS PLACED
ACCURATELY AND WEEK THAT THEY
CAN BE READ OFF A PHONE AND THAT
THE INFRASTRUCTURE IS IN PLACE
SO THAT THESE FORMS OF THE
FUTURE CAN ACTUALLY OPERATE SO.
THIS BILL STARTS TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THE NEEDS THAT WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE AS WE MOVE FORWARD WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO RETRAIN OUR
WORKFORCE AND SO. ON I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU.
NOT THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE
BILL FORWARD AND WHILE I AGREE
THAT THERE IS A NEED FOR
INNOVATIVE AGRICULTURAL BUSINESS
AND TECHNOLOGY THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
I'M CONCERNED THAT THERE ARE
HUGE REVENUE AND TAXATION.
IMPLICATIONS IN THIS BILL SO I
WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO WORK WITH
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD. TO
ADDRESS THE REVENUE AND.
TAXATION IMPLICATIONS.
I WE HAD A MOTION BY MISTER
SANTIAGO SECOND BY MISTER
PATTERSON.
DO PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MADAM
SECRETARY IF YOU WOULD CALL THE
ROLL.
MEDINA ALRIGHT MEDINA AYE BAKER.
BAKER I ARAMBULA. BLOOM.
CHAVEZ
SCHABAS I IRWIN.
KILEY.
KILEY AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW. PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA.
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
EIGHT ZERO YOUR BILL IS OUT WE
WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MOVING TO ITEM TO.
MISS GONZALEZ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FORTY NINE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
AB TWENTY FORTY NINE IS A SIMPLE
BILL THAT MAKES THE PROCESSING
OF COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN CLASS
WHITE SCHOOL EMPLOYEES UNION
MEMBERSHIP DUES. UNIFORM WITH
THE CURRENT PROCEDURE THAT
EXISTS FOR PROCESSING TEACHERS
DUES BY LINING THE STATUE FOR
CLASSIFIED SCHOOL INCOMING
COLLEGE EMPLOYEES THE BILL
CLARIFIES THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
IN SCHOOL EMPLOYERS. ARE
REQUIRED TO TRANSMIT MEMBERSHIP
DUES TO THE EMPLOYEES LABOR
REPRESENTATIVES.
FINALLY AB TWENTY FORTY NINE
ENSURES THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
COMMITTEE COLLEGES ARE
INDEMNIFIED FOR DEDUCTING
MEMBERSHIP DUES BASED ON THE
EMPLOYEES MEMBERSHIP AGREEMENT.
HAVE A COUPLE WITNESSES HERE AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
YES. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
JUDGE SURPRISE SUIT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION. A WE DON'T HAVE
MUCH MORE TO ADD TO WHAT THE
AUTHOR HAS ALREADY DESCRIBED
WHAT THE BILL DOES.
IT SETS UP A SIMPLE PROCESS WHAT
DO BUT TO PROCESSING TO MIRROR
WHAT THAT THE TEACHERS WERE
TEACHERS HAVE IN THEIR CODE
SECTION.
THANK YOU.
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
MICHELLE CAST OF THE SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
THIS BILL WILL FINALLY PUT.
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ON PAR WITH
THE REST OF THE PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
IN CALIFORNIA FBI.
I GIVE.
ANY OTHER WHICH ISN'T SUPPORT
AFTER DIDN'T NOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS JOSTLED WILL GO WITH THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANY
TWEETERS.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
WE HAD.
MOTION BY MISTER SANTIAGO
SECOND BY DOCTOR WEBER.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
JUST AS HE AYE VOTE.
MADAM SECRETARY WHO WOULD CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. MEDINA
AYE AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER.
BAKER NO ARAMBULA.
BLOOM.
CHAVEZ
CHAVEZ NO IRWIN.
KILEY.
KILEY NO. LEVINE LEVINE AYE LOW.
PATTERSON.
QUIRK SILVA.
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
FOR THREE YOUR BILL IS ON CALL.
MOVING TO ITEM TEN. THIS
SEGMENT.
WELCOME. MY COCA COLA THROUGH IT
THAT MISTER GRAYSON AND THEN
DOCTOR WEBER WHO LOOKED IN STATE
SEATED OVER THERE SHE SAID JOB
SO TROOPS.
HAD GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYBODY
WERE VERY PLEASED TO BE WITH
YOUR TO YOU TODAY TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY ONE.
A HIGHER EDUCATION FACILITIES
BOND ACT OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
THIS BOND WOULD GENERATE SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN REVENUE FOR
CONSTRUCTION OF NEW FACILITIES
AN IMPROVEMENT TO EXISTING
FACILITIES.
HISTORICALLY BONTA BEEN USED TO
FIND LARGE CAPITAL INVESTMENTS
IN OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM BOTH K.
THROUGH TWELVE AND HIGHER ED.
THIS FUNDING FOR PROJECTS TO THE
BUDGET HAS FAILED TO KEEP PACE
WITH THE NEED THIS ISSUE WHEN
YOU SEE HAVE BEEN LEFT OUT
RECENT BOND MEASURES.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE
VOTERS PASSED PROPERTY ONE AND
NINE BILLION DOLLARS BOND FOR
PRIMARY SCHOOLS THROUGH
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
WE ALSO NEED TO REST AND THE
REST OF OUR SYSTEM.
NOT ONLY OR CURRENT FACILITIES
LACKING NECESSARY MAINTENANCE.
BUT OUR SYSTEM IS ALSO TURN AWAY
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS I
TALK TO A PROFESSOR THIS WEEKEND
FROM C. ISSUE SAN FRANCISCO.
WHO TALKED ABOUT A THE ELEVATOR
SHE COULDN'T GET OUT OF IT
SOMETIMES TO BE ABLE TO TEACH A
CLASS?
SHE SAID SHE CRIED OUT I*
GET THROUGH THE WORLD WAR TWO
WILL NEVER GET TO CIVIL RIGHTS
AS YOU COULD HARDLY GET ON THE
ELEVATOR TRYING TO GET TO CLASS
ON TIME.
.
AND WE'RE EXTREMELY TENS OF
THOUSANDS STUDENTS THIRTY ONE
STYLE THOUSAND STUDENTS THIS
YEAR DID NOT HAVE THE CAPACITY
TO HAVE CAPACITY TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE SEATS FOR THEM TO SIT IN.
WE ARE PROJECTED TO FALL
MILLIONS OF GRADUATE SHORT OF
THE JOB MARKET NEED BY TWENTY
THIRTY. AND IN ORDER TO DO THAT
WE MUST EXPAND OUR CAPACITY TO
OFFER OPPORTUNITIES TO
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
THE NEEDS ALL OVER THE STATE OF
CONTINUE TO GROW. ESPECIALLY THE
CENTRAL VALLEY THERE IS THAT
MORE PEOPLE ARE MOVING INTO. THE
COASTAL AREA MORE PEOPLE ARE
MOVING INTO AND YET WE HAVE A
DEARTH OF FACILITIES.
THERE WILL BE NO DOUBT
FACILITIES LIKE MINE WITH LARGE
POPULATIONS.
OVER THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE WITHOUT A PUBLIC
UNIVERSITY WITHIN FIFTY MILES.
IF YOU WANT TO HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO MEET FUTURE NEEDS
WE HAVE TO EXPAND EXISTING
SCHOOLS AND INVEST IN NEW
CAPITAL CONSTRUCTION.
WE WENT A WHOLE GENERATION
PASSING THE THESE BONDS FOR
EVERY TWO TO FOUR YEARS BUT IT'S
NOW BEEN TWELVE YEARS SINCE WE
PASSED. A HIGHER EDUCATION BOND.
THIS BONTA PUT THE DECISIONS IN
THE HANDS OF THE VOTERS WHO HAVE
CONSISTENTLY AGREED THAT WE NEED
TO RAISE ADDITIONAL FUNDS. FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM THIS
REALLY IS OUR PLAN FOR THE
FUTURE IT'S GONE LAYING OUT A
PATH FOR CALIFORNIA BILL TO BE
ABLE TO MEET OUR EDUCATIONAL
NEEDS TO MEET OUR WORKFORCE
NEEDS. AND MAKE SURE OUR
FACILITIES HAVE A.
THAT THAT REFLECT BLOOD THAT THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY AND WITH ME
TODAY I HAVE MISTER GRAYSON ALSO
SPEAK ON THIS ISSUE.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE
TO COPE PRESENT TODAY. AND IT IS
SUCH AN HONOR TO BE ABLE TO
JOINT AUTHORED WITH DOCTOR WEBER
DOCTOR EGGMAN. BY THIS VERY
IMPORTANT BILL DOCTOR EGGMAN IS
ALREADY PRESENTED AND WELL
ARTICULATED. AND.
THE JUSTIFICATION FOR THE NEED
OF THIS BILL. I HAVE AND WILL
SIMPLY ADD THAT I HAVE TALKED
WITH SPOKE WITH CONSTITUENTS
AS WELL AS SET IN STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS. LISTENING TO THE CASE
AS TO WHY THIS BILL WOULD BE IN
THE BEST INTEREST OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AS WELL AS THE
CAMPUSES OF CS USE AND UC'S
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE HAVE YOU SEE.
BERKELEY WHO HOLDS CLASSES THAT
ARE PACKED OUT AND THERE WITH NO
AIR CONDITIONING AND NO ABILITY
TO CIRCULATE AIR.
AND THE KIND OF ENVIRONMENT
CLIMATE CHANGE WE HAVE WHERE
IT'S WARMING UP.
IS CERTAIN TIMES OF THE YEAR
WERE CLASSES ARE MAXIMIZED.
DO THIS.
STATE TO THE STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS WITH YOU SEE NCS USE
THEY HAVE CLEARLY.
LAID OUT THE NEED FOR
IMPROVEMENT TO EXISTING CAMPUSES
CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS. AND.
THE NEED TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
FOR FUTURE DEMANDS ESPECIALLY
WHEN IT COMES TO ATTENDANCE OF
STUDENTS.
CALISTO ROOMS FACULTY STAFF
ADMINISTRATORS HAVE ALL SPOKEN
OUT ABOUT THE NEEDS THAT THEY
HAVE SO I STRONGLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT ASKED WHAT I VOTERS
WILL.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SYLVIA
SOLELY SHOT BEHALF OF THE TWENTY
EIGHT THOUSAND FACULTY
COUNSELORS LIBRARIANS AND STOP
OF THE CUT CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
AS NOTED BY THE MEMBERS SPEED
DEFINITELY HAVE.
A GREAT NEED OF DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AS WELL AS FOR NEW
FACILITIES SO WE. I THINK THE
AUTHORS FOR THIS MEASURE THINKS
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS JASON
MURPHY ON BEHALF OF THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA WE DON'T
HAVE A FORMAL POSITION AT THIS
TIME HOWEVER WE DO APPRECIATE
SINCERELY. THE AUTHORS UGLINESS
PUSHED ISSUE FORWARD THE NEEDS
ARE GREAT AS NOTED YOUR ANALYSIS
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA'S BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IN. DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND OTHER NEEDS AND
WE DO APPRECIATE THE EFFORT SAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MARY MOYLE WITH THE CSU WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING ATTENTION TO THIS
ISSUE. AYE WE ALSO HAVE HAVE A
LOT OF NEED IS NOTED IN THE
ANALYSIS THAT THIS IS REALLY
ABOUT GETTING STUDENTS RELIABLE
FACILITIES SO THANK THANK YOU.
JERRY DUSA CAL STATE SOON
ASSOCIATION AND TRUNK SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU.
TWEETERS.
IT WAS IN OPPOSITION.
YEAH MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
GOOD AFTERNOON DAVID WILL FOR
THE HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
BUT WOULD LIKE TO JUST MAKE A
COUPLE COMMENTS REGARDING BONDS
IN GENERAL.
MEMBERS BONDS ARE NOT INHERENTLY
BAD.
AND THERE IS A PROPER AND
APPROPRIATE PLACE FOR CAPITAL
FACILITIES BONDS
HOWEVER I THINK THERE'S A
HANDFUL OF THINGS THAT WE NEED
TO PAY ATTENTION TO BEFORE YOU
LOOK AT APPROVING MORE BOND AT
AND I DON'T THINK THIS BOND. YOU
KNOW AT THIS SPECIFIC ITERATION
DOES THAT YET SO WE HAVE TO BE
OPPOSE.
THINGS THAT YOU KNOW JUST STAND
OUT THAT I WOULD MENTION
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW HAS A DEBT
SERVICE RATIO OF ABOUT FIVE
PERCENT THAT'S FIVE PERCENT OF
GENERAL FUND REVENUE. THAT GOES
TO NOTHING MORE OR LESS THAN
PAYING OFF ON DAD.
NOW CAN BE DEBATED WHETHER OR
NOT THAT NUMBER IS TOO HIGH OR
TOO LOW. BUT.
WHEN YOU THINK OF PRISONS WHEN
YOU THINK OF KICK YOUR COLLEGE
EDUCATION WHEN YOU THINK OF
PENSIONS WHEN YOU THINK OF OTHER
FUNDING PRIORITIES AND
ESPECIALLY WITH A NINE BILLION
DOLLAR PROP FIFTY ONE K. TWELVE
BOND THAT JUST PASSED. LAST
NOVEMBER. YOU KNOW WE HAD A
GOVERNOR THAT AT ONE TIME WAS
REALLY REALLY FOCUSED ON A WALL
OF DEBT AND IT SEEMS LIKE HE'S
PULLING BACK FROM THAT A LITTLE
BIT. BUT AGAIN WE ALSO DO YOU
HAVE THESE ONGOING GENERAL FUND
PRIORITIES THAT WE NEED TO PAY
ATTENTION TO.
BEYOND THAT NUMBER TWO I THINK
WHEN ANALYZING A BLIND WE DO
NEED TO PAY ATTENTION TO. LIKE
PROP FIFTY ONE SOME OF THE BONDS
THAT HAVE COME BEFORE THIS ONE
YOU KNOW BONDS LIKE HIGH SPEED
RAIL BUT THERE IS MEMBERS KNOW
PRIORITY WITHIN OUR BOND SYSTEM
ABOUT PRIORITIZING WHICH BONDS
ARE MORE IMPORTANT. IS A HIGHER
EDUCATION BOND MORE IMPORTANT
IMPROPER FIFTY ONE IS IT MORE
IMPORTANT IN HIGH SPEED RAIL
THERE ARE NO THE TREASURE HAS
ATTEMPTED TO. ATTEMPT TO TRY AND
ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS BUT
THERE'S NONE OF THAT IN PLACE
RIGHT NOW WE DON'T KNOW WHICH
ONES ARE MORE IMPORTANT ANOTHER
BONDS AND IF THESE OTHER
PROGRAMS CONTINUE TO CROWD AND
TERRY DEBT SERVICE RATIO. AND AS
WE PREPARE TO ENTER INTO ANOTHER
RECESSION WHICH IS INEVITABLE
THOSE ARE THINGS WE NEED TO PAY
ATTENTION TO.
AND YOU KNOW FINALLY. PROPER AND
APPROPRIATE USE OF BONDS IS TO
FUND PROJECTS THAT LAST THE
LENGTH OF THE BLIND.
SO PRIMARILY MAJOR CAPITAL
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS AND ALSO
TO ENSURE THAT LIFE CYCLE COSTS
ARE APPROPRIATE YOU DO NOT WANT
TO USE BOND DOLLARS FOR INSTANCE
IS WHAT ALL US POSSIBLE. DEFINED
IPHONES IPADS EITHER DIGITAL
TECHNOLOGY ORDER FUN FURNITURE
BECAUSE THOSE THINGS ARE NOT
GOING TO LAST A LINK TO THE BOND
LIFE CYCLE COSTS.
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
AND MEMBERS NONE OF THESE
FACTORS HAVE BEEN CONSIDERED YOU
KNOW WHEN LOOKING AT THIS BOND
OR FRANKLY A LOT OF OTHER BONDS
AND SO. IT'S MORE JUST PREVIOUS
OVER OUR KING REASONS AND NOT
NECESSARILY FOR THE BOND ITSELF
THAT WE FIND OURSELVES IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS THIS
BAKER.
BECAUSE I THINK YOU MEMBERS THAT
A MAN AND GRAYSON FOR.
FOR BRINGING FOR THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
INVESTMENT WE MAKE IN FACILITIES
WE VISITED ABOUT THIS I DON'T
PARTICULARLY LIKE BONDS FOR MANY
OF THE REASONS THAT THE
REPRESENTED SOME HOWARD JARVIS
OF POINTED OUT IF WE. IF WE IT'S
A IT'S A MUCH OF THE TIME IT'S A
QUESTION OF PRIORITIES WHICH BUT
WE DO IN OUR BUDGET BECAUSE IF
WE SPEND IT. WITHOUT ISSUING A
BOND WE ARE PREVENTING FUTURE
BUDGETS BEING CROWDED OUT BY IST
INTEREST.
SO I LOOK AT WITH THE VERY
SKEPTICAL I BONDS WHEN THEY COME
BEFORE ME.
I'M GONNA SUPPORT THIS ONE
TODAY BECAUSE I WANT THE
CONVERSATION TO CONTINUE ABOUT
WHAT WE NEED TO BE INVESTED IN
HIGHER EDUCATION. BUT DO YOU
WANT TO UNDERSCORE SOME OF THE
VOTE VALID POINTS THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED PARTICULARLY MAKING SURE
IF YOU CAN AND MAKE PRIORITIES
IN THIS THAT IT IS. LONG TERM
CAPITAL INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WILL
LAST NOT STILL HAVE FOR THE BOND
THAT PERHAPS EVEN LONGER.
HARD TO BELIEVE THAT BUT. IN AND
SECONDLY. AN ISSUE WAS NOT
RAISED BUT YOU KNOW I SUPPORTED
THE FACILITIES VON FOUR KEY
THROUGH FOURTEEN AND FOUND THAT
THE GOVERNOR'S TRICKLING OUT
THOSE DOLLARS WHICH I THINK IS
VERY MUCH AGAINST THE WILL. OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO VOTED FOR IT
OVERWHELMINGLY. AND I WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU AS YOU LOOK AT THE
LANGUAGE TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
CLOSE ANY.
LOOPHOLES RUN ALL THE TRAPS TO
MAKE SURE THAT A GOVERNOR CANNOT
UNILATERALLY REWRITE WHEN THE
DOLLARS ARE BEING SPENT.
BECAUSE ONCE WE'VE MADE A
DECISION AS AS A LEGISLATURE TO
PUT IT ON THE BALLOT FOR VOTERS
TO CONTINUE VOTE YES ON THIS
THAT YOU MAY
NOT SUPPORT IT WHEN IT'S ON THE
BALLOT THAT YOU WANNA GET ON
THERE. BUT ONCE IT'S ON THERE
THAT THE WILL OF CALIFORNIANS IS
HONORED AND SO THAT'S A
CAUTIONARY WORD GIVEN THE WHAT
WE WHAT WE'RE SEEING HAPPEN
RIGHT NOW WITH THE SCHOOL
FACILITIES BOND AND WHAT IT'S
DOING TO OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
WHO ARE BASICALLY AWAITING A
RETURN OF LOANS THEY'VE
ESSENTIALLY MADE TO THE STATE
AND TO TRY TO REALLY MAKE SURE
THIS GOES TO LONG TERM CAPITAL
INVESTMENT OUTLAYS? I THINK THAT
MAKES IT A MUCH MORE LEGITIMATE
CASE IN AN IDEAL WORLD.
WE WE SET OUR PRIORITIES SO THAT
WE DON'T HAVE TO RELY SO MUCH ON
DEBT THERE IS A CASE TO BE MADE
IN TIMES FOR BONDS AND I THINK
YOU CAN MAKE THAT CASE. WITH
SOMEBODY'S CORRECTIONS THANK YOU
SUB REPORT SUPPORTING TODAY
LOOKING FOR IT HOPING THOSE.
IMPROVEMENTS.
BUT YOU WILL BE.
I THINK IS AS ALWAYS MISTER WILL
MAKE SOME VERY SALIENT POINTS
BUT I WOULD HATE TO BE
OUTFLANKED ON THE LEFT BY MS
BAKER.
SO I'LL BE AYE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS IS WELL.
.
I I THINK WHEN WE WE KIND OF
THINK GLOBALLY IN LONG TERM IN
ALL SERIOUSNESS I APPRECIATE MY
SPEAKERS POINTS.
.
THAT.
YEAH WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO LOOK
AT THE FUTURE OF THE DISTANT
HIGHER HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM
IN CALIFORNIA. AND WHAT THE WHAT
THE PHYSICAL NEEDS THE CAPITAL
NEEDS ARE FOR THOSE SYSTEMS AND
HOW THEY CAN BE RESPONSIVE TO
THE EDUCATIONAL NEEDS THE SKILL
BUILDING NEEDS TO CAREER. NEEDS
IN ANY JOB.
THE PROSPECT OF JOBS AS WELL
AND WHERE THEY WOULD BE AND THEN
THE TYPE OF.
.
COUPLE WE WE NEED TO BUILT TO
SUPPORT ALL OF THAT AND.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT ORDER THEY
SHOULD GO IN BUT I THINK THAT WE
WOULD NEED THE SEGMENTS TO BE.
PART OF THAT PLANNING TO TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND THE DOLLARS
THAT WE NEED AND ALSO WHERE THE
INVESTMENT WOULD BE MADE WHICH I
THINK WOULD BE HELPFUL FOR
VOTERS TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
THEY'RE VOTING FOR.
DOCTOR WEBER. YES I WANNA THANK
MY COLLEAGUES ON EGGMAN IN
GRAYSON FOR.
FOR US GETTING TOGETHER TO
SUPPORT THIS SUB PARTICULAR
BILL.
UP MOST OF YOU KNOW WE'VE TRIED
MULTIPLE WAYS OF FIGURING OUT
HOW TO RESPOND TO THE ISSUE OF
THE C. ISSUE. THEN YOU SUCH
SHORTAGE IN TERMS OF STUDENT
ENROLLMENT.
MANY OF YOU HAVE PUT TOGETHER
RESOLUTIONS TO A BASICALLY BUILD
NEW CAMPUSES ONLY TO HAVE THAT
EITHER DERAILED BY THE GOVERNOR
OR SOMEBODY. WE'VE TRIED THE.
THE.
THE ORGANIZATION THAT WE HAVE
THE HIGHER IT ORGANIZATION THAT
USED TO HAVE A MAP OUT THINGS
FOR US AND PUT THINGS TOGETHER
AND THAT HAS NOT. A SOMEONE'S
TRIED THAT FOR THE LAST SIX
USING EACH YEAR IT'S BEEN DITA
IT'S BEEN VETOED SO. THIS IS AN
EFFORT TO REALLY START LOOKING
FORWARD.
PROBABLY OF ALL THE THINGS THAT
A BOND COULD DO THAT MIGHT LAST
IN TERMS OF LONGER THAN THE.
PLAYBACK OF OF OF OF OF THE OF
THE BOND ITSELF IS UNIVERSITY. I
MEAN WE DON'T HAVE UNIVERSITIES
THAT DIE OUT IN THE AGENCY ISSUE
pCALLED IS THE DOUBT IN TWENTY
THIRTY YEARS. MOST OF THEM
EXPAND AND GROW IN A MOST ARE
UNIVERSES OVER FIFTY YEARS OLD
NOW I THINK IRVINE WAS THE LAST
ONE JUST TURNED FIFTY OR SAN
MARCOS ONE. TURN TWENTY FIVE SO
THEY GENERALLY LAST THEY LAST
LONGER THAN THAN MOST THINGS AND
SO IT THAT SINCE HE BECOMES VERY
GOOD INVESTMENT. OF BECAUSE YOU
KNOW IT WILL LAST LONGER THAN
JUST PAYING BACK THE BOND TO BUY
IPADS AND THINGS THAT CHANGE.
THE UNIQUE THING TOO IS THAT YOU
KNOW OF THE SYSTEMS WHICH
NORMALLY DON'T COOPERATE ALL THE
TIME TOGETHER ARE REALLY IN
COOPERATION WITH THIS. THE
PRESIDENT OF THE A UC CAMPUS THE
CHANCELLOR OF THIS A C. ISSUE
HAVE ALL WEIGHED IN ON THIS
AND THINK IT'S A GREAT IDEA.
BECAUSE THEY TOO ARE
EXPERIENCING THE FACT THAT WE
ARE REVVING UP EVERYBODY OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THEY SAY WE
GETTING THEM READY.
TO GO SOMEWHERE MOVES LIKE WHEN
THEY GET READY TO GET ON THE ON
RAMP OF THE FREE WEIGHTS THIS
ISSUE OF THE UC AND THERE'S NO
ROOM.
AND SO AS WE KEEP TALKING ABOUT
MORE AND MORE OF OUR STUDENTS
NEEDING TO GET AN A A DEGREE OR
SOMETHING AND THEN HAVE THE
POSSIBILITY OF MOVING ON. WE
HAVE TO CREATE A SYSTEM THAT'S
GOING TO DO IT AND OUR SYSTEMS
BEEN VERY EFFECTIVE IN
ACCOMPLISHING THAT BUT UNLESS WE
DO SOMETHING TO BUILD MORE. OF
CAMPUSES WILL THEN FIND
OURSELVES ONCE AGAIN WITH AS WE
DO THIS YEAR OVER THIRTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS NOT BEING ABLE
TO GET A SLOT. IN EITHER ONE OF
OUR CAMPUSES ARE AND.
THAT WILL ONLY GROW AS WE
CONTINUE TO TALK ABOUT.
THE OTHER EXPANDING OUR
CURRICULUM GETTING MORE OF OUR
STUDENTS INTO THE UNIVERSITY
WE'RE TALKING EXPANDING
FINANCIAL AID ALL THOSE THINGS
AS INCENTIVES FOR STUDENTS TO
GO.
AND GO TO THE NEXT LEVEL POST
SECONDARY AND.
AND YET WE ARE NOT THINKING IN
TERMS OF EXPANSION OF THOSE
CAMPUSES WE HAVE A WHAT WE CALL
EDUCATION DEBTS IN THE STATE.
WHERE THERE ARE NO CAMPUSES
ALMOST THE ISSUE NO UC CAMPUS?
AND ONE OF THE GREAT THINGS IS
AB AS OUR POPULATION GROWS AND
WE EXPAND BECAUSE WE HAVE MORE.
OF STUDENTS WERE WORKING CLASS
STUDENTS NOW WANT TO GO TO
COLLEGE WHICH WHAT THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA WAS
DESIGNED FOR.
OF MANY OF THEM CAN GOING TO
FOR THE GOAL OF VACANCY AT HOME.
BUT THEY CAN'T STAY AT HOME
BECAUSE THEY LIVE IN A COMMUNITY
WHERE THERE ARE NO SEE ISSUES
AND NO UC'S AND WE HAVE SOME
PLACES LIKE THAT. THEN THE COST
OF ONE COLLEGE WITH THEM BECOMES
EXTREMELY EXPENSIVE.
WE WANT TO CREATE A GREAT
TAXPAYERS IN TERMS OF THOSE WHO
GOOD JOBS WE KEEP TALKING ABOUT
GOOD JOBS THAT THIS THAT THAT
AND SO FORTH AND SO ON SO THIS
IS REALLY A FORWARD LOOKING
EFFORT TO TALK ABOUT WHAT WE CAN
DO. AYE AS WELL ENTERING
HOPEFULLY A NEW CYCLE OF OF
LEADERSHIP IN AND AND CALIFORNIA
WITH THE NEW GOVERNOR.
AND SOME OTHERS TO START
TALKING ABOUT PLANNING IN THIS
IS DESIGNED TO DO THAT TO REALLY
HELP TO EXTRACT AND BUILD OUR
CAMPUSES.
I CANCERS ARE CONCERNED SOME OF
THE OTHER BECOMING OBSOLETE IN
THEIR LABS IN THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS AND SO. ALSO WE
RESPONSIBILITY WE TAKE PRIDE WE
BRAG ABOUT OUR THREE TWO SYSTEM
AND IT IS ONE OF THE GREATEST
SYSTEMS IN THE WORLD. BUT IT
WILL NOT REMAIN THAT WAY UNLESS
WE CONTINUE TO INVEST IN IT AND
SO I'M REALLY PLEASED WITH THIS
AND I TO MOVE AB TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY ONE.
SECOND.
ANY OTHER.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS MISTER JOBS
QUESTIONS GARMENTS.
IT WAS.
TODAY I WAS TALKING TO A.
TWO STUDENTS FROM THE
UNIVERSITY.
OF SAN DIEGO.
AND WE'VE ALL HEARD THE STORIES
IN THE SUB TO MEETING ABOUT THE
INABILITY OF THE STUDENTS.
TO TAKE THEIR CLASSES THEY NEED
TO GET OUT WITHIN FOUR YEARS.
AND A LOT OF TIME JUST BECAUSE
WE JUST DON'T HAVE THE
CLASSROOMS IN THERE TO GET A
MINUTE.
THEY ALSO TALK TO THE STUDENTS
OR STAND. THERE.
THERE IN ROOMS THAT ARE LARGE
ENOUGH FOR THE STUDENTS SO THEY
HAVE TO SIT ON THE FLOOR BRING
TABLES AND CHAIRS AND.
THE UC'S SYSTEM.
IS THE INNOVATOR.
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT HAVE
DIFFERENT REGIONS WITHIN THE
STATE.
IT MAKES MONEY.
AND THE ABILITY OF GETTING YOUNG
PEOPLE IN AND OUT FOR YEARS.
SAVES US MONEY
VERSUS TAKEN SIX YEARS TO GET
OUT.
NOW THE SHE ISSUES ARE ALL
AROUND THE STATE AND THEY DO
WONDERFUL JOBS.
SOME TO LIKE IN MY OWN HISTORY.
SEVENTY FIVE EIGHTY PERCENT OF
THE GRADUATES ACCOUNT STANCE A
CAL STATE SAN MARCOS STAY WITH
TO MY DISTRICT. AND ARE MAKING
BUSINESSES IN THE NBA'S IN THEM
GRAYSON QUALITY. ECONOMY AND
ACTUALLY NORTH COUNTY SAN DIEGO
WOODS OVER A MILLION PEOPLE NOW.
IS COMPETING WITH SAN DIEGO FOR
OPPORTUNITY JOBS.
BECAUSE OF CSU SAN MARCOS.
TO ME THIS JUST MAKES A LOT OF
SENSE.
AS FAR AS WHAT DO WE AS A
SOCIETY INVEST IN.
AND THAT'S A LOT OF PEOPLE AND
THAT'S WE NEED THESE
INSTITUTIONS.
NOW I'M ALL FOR BE IN A FISCAL
CONSERVATIVE EVERYTHING ELSE
MIGHT INVESTING.
IN.
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH HAS A MUCH
LONGER LIFE CYCLE THAN THIRTY
YEARS.
AND INVEST IN OUR PEOPLE TO GROW
OUR ECONOMY.
SO THAT THEY CAN PROVIDE NEW
JOBS
IS A SMART THING TO DO.
SO ONLY BE REAL CLEAR I'M GLAD
THIS IS HERE.
CLEARLY SOMETHING THAT WE NEED
FOR UC'S GARCIA ISSUES. AND.
.
HOPE THE GOVERNOR SIGNED A DAMN
THING
SO PROBABLY THAT'S WHY SECOND.
NO OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
.
THE SEGMENT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE WOODS AT THANK EVERYBODY
FOR THEIR COMMENTS IN THEIR OF
THEIR THOUGHTFULNESS AND I. YOU
KNOW IS THIS THE BEST WAY TO GO
ABOUT IT I DON'T KNOW BUT I DO
KNOW THAT ARE PART DEBT RATING
IS IS GOOD RIGHT NOW. FITS
STANDARD POOR'S AND MOODY'S ALL
PRAISE US FOR OUR OUR RIGHT
DIVERSE ECONOMIC PORTFOLIO. OR
DEBT RATIO IS DOWN RIGHT NOW.
AND ITS PEOPLE SAID THERE'S
GOOD DEBT AND THERE'S BAD DEBT.
I THINK INVESTING IN OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND AND WE TALK
ABOUT THE LIFE OF A BOND. THE
CAMPUSES WILL LAST BUT THE
STUDENTS THAT WE EDUCATE IN
THOSE CAMPUSES WILL LAST EVEN
LONGER AND PROVIDE FOR THE.
ECONOMIC SECURITY OF CALIFORNIA
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR RIVAL.
SO WE WE HAVE HAD A MOTION.
WE NEED A MOTION.
I PSYCHOLOGY MOVE BY DOCTOR
WEBER SECOND BY MISTER CHAVEZ.
AND I SHOULD SAY MISTER LACKEY
IS ALSO A CO AUTHOR.
I I I HEARD A COUPLE OF
DIFFERENT THINGS.
IN THE PRESENTATION.
AND I CERTAINLY AGREE WITH THE
NEED OF YOU SEE AND CSU. NEEDING
MORE FACILITIES THAT'S BEEN
OBVIOUS TO ME AS CHAIR OF HIGHER
ED AS I. A TOUR SAC STATE AS I
SPEND TIME ON CAMPUSES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
BUT IT IS ALSO MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS
HISTORICALLY RESPECTED THE
SEGMENTS DETERMINATION.
OF THE STATEWIDE SYSTEM CAPITAL
OUTLAY PRIORITIES.
AND I WOULD EXPECT THAT THIS
WOULD CONTINUE SHOULD THIS BOND
MEASURE BE APPROVED.
THAT THEREFORE THIS MEASURES
SHOULD NOT BE SEEN AS A WAY TO
FIND NEW CAMPUS CONSTRUCTION.
ABSENT. UC'S AND CSU AND THE
LEGISLATURE'S PRIOR CONCURRENCE
OF THE NEED FOR ANY NEW
CAMPUSES.
SO WITH THAT SAID THE MOTION WAS
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. WITH
THE AMENDMENT ADDING A URGENCY
BECAUSE.
AND MATTER SECRETARY IF YOU
WOULD. CALL THE ROLL.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER.
BAKER AYE ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM. CHVEZ.
CHAVEZ I IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING. LEVINE LEVINE
AYE LOW. PATTERSON.
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO WEBER.
WEBER I.
ZERO YOUR BILL IS OUT WILL KEEP
IT UNCALLED FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM SIX MISTER
BRYANT THIS.
DOES ITEM ONE SORRY ABOUT THAT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE
TO START OFF BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ON PAGE
THREE OF THE ANALYSIS AND THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF.
ON THEIR WORK FOR ON THIS BILL.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
SIX CONTINUES TO BUILD UPON THE
WORK THE LEGISLATURE HAS DONE
RELATED CHOI AWARDING. ACADEMIC
CREDIT FOR PRIOR LEARNING WHAT
THE SPECIFIC EMPHASIS ON OUR
VETERAN POPULATION IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE THE GOVERNOR
SIGNED AN ASSEMBLY BILL THAT
REQUIRE THE CHANCELLOR OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. TO DETERMINE
WHICH COURSES CREDIT WOULD BE
AWARDED A FOR PRIOR MILITARY
EXPERIENCE CALIFORNIA HAS AN
ESTIMATED ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION VETERANS RECITING IN THE
STATE AND UPON RETURNING FROM
SERVICE MANY DECIDE TO USE OUR
MILITARY BENEFITS. TO PURSUE
HIGHER EDUCATION.
WELL ARE VETERAN STUDENTS BRING
A UNIQUE EXPERIENCE SURE
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITY CAMPUSES
WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE OTHER
STUDENT POPULATIONS THAT HAVE
EXPERTISE IN A VARIETY OF
INDUSTRY SECTORS. AND TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
COUNSELORS OFFICE RECEIVED A
GRANT TO DEVELOP A STRUCTURE FOR
INSTITUTING CREDIT FOR PRIOR
LEARNING SYSTEM WIDE. MY BILL
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY SIX WOULD
REQUIRE THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
BY JANUARY ONE OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO REPORTS THE LEGISLATURE
ABOUT THE INITIATIVE. AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS REGARDING POLICY
CHANGES NECESSARY TO IMPLEMENT
BEST PRACTICES TO IDENTIFY THE
SCOPE OF WORK.
IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE CAN DO
ALL THAT WE CAN TO FURTHER
IMPROVE CAREER ATTAINMENT FOR
OUR STUDENTS ACROSS THE STATE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
NOT A PROBLEM.
IF THE GOALS OF THE AUTHOR IN
THE AMENDMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MOVE IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK TOGETHER IN
SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
ANY TWEENER WHO'S.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
WITH THE.
MOVE BY.
DOCTOR RUMBULA.
SECOND BY.
BUT MR LEVINE.
MISTER BY THIS WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. I APPRECIATE.
THE SUPPORT OF FOR A MOTION IN
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
SO THE.
MOTION WAS DO PASSES AMENDED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE BUT
BEFORE CALLING THE ROLE I JUST
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THE BILL FORWARD. FOR
AGREEING TO THE COMMITTEE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS
I BELIEVE THIS LEGISLATION WILL
NOT HELP. COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO
DEVELOP A STRONG PROGRAM OF
PRIOR LEARNING ASSESSMENT. THAT
WILL NOT ONLY GREAT LEE BENEFIT
VETERANS AND SERVICE MEMBERS BUT
ALSO OTHER STUDENTS WHO BRING
VALUABLE SKILLS TO THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE.
MADAM SECRETARY BUTTE CALL THE
ROLL.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER.
BAKER I ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA AYE
BLOOM.
CHAVEZ.
CHAVEZ I IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE LEVINE. LEVINE AYE LOW
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO. WEBER.
WEBER I.
GEN ZERO YOU BILL IS OUT WE'LL
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
DOCTOR RUMBULA.
ITEM EIGHT.
THIS TO. ME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
TODAY I AM HERE TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY FIVE NINETY SEVEN WHICH
WOULD APPROPRIATE FUNDING FOR
THE PROGRAMS IN MEDICAL
EDUCATION.
AND EXPAND ENROLLMENT A FULL
TIME MEDICAL STUDENTS IN THE
PRIME PROGRAM.
YOU SEE PRIME IS AN INNOVATIVE
TRAINING PROGRAM FOCUSED ON
MEETING THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA'S UNDERSERVED
POPULATIONS. IN BOTH RURAL
COMMUNITIES AND URBAN AREAS.
BY COMBINING SPECIALIZED
COURSEWORK STRUCTURED CLINICAL
EXPERIENCES ADVANCED INDEPENDENT
STUDY IN MENTORING.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA HAS A LACK
OF RUTH A ROBUST PRIMARY CARE
WORK FORCE.
THE REPORT FROM THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA SAN FRANCISCO'S
HEALTH FORCE CENTER RELEASED
LAST SUMMER PROJECTS THAT THE
STATE WILL SUFFER A PRIMARY CARE
CLINICIANS SHORTFALL OVER THE
NEXT FIFTEEN YEARS. WHAT THE
HARDEST HIT AREAS BEING IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY? THE CENTRAL
COAST AND THE SOUTHERN BORDER
AREAS.
IF WE CONTINUE ALONG THIS PATH
MORE AND MORE CALIFORNIANS WILL
BE HEADING TO THE EMERGENCY ROOM
FOR CONDITIONS LIKE ASTHMA. EAR
INFECTIONS OR THE FLU BECAUSE
THEY LACK PRIMARY CARE.
CONDITIONS THAT CAN BE PREVENTED
WITH PROPER CARE AHEAD OF TIME.
DURING MY TIME AS ANY OUR DOCTOR
ANSELMO I SAW FIRSTHAND THE
SHORTAGE OF MEDICAL DOCTORS IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AND WANT
TO OFFER A PERSONAL PLEA. TO
REALLY ENSURE THAT WE ARE
HELPING TO REPAIR WHAT IS A
CONDITION THAT SO MANY IN OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE STRUGGLING WITH.
LACK OF ACCESS TO PRIMARY CARE
DOCTORS.
PLUNDER AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY
SEVEN ENROLLMENT OF MEDICAL
STUDENTS WHEN INCREASE BY TWENTY
FIVE PERCENT FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY ONE CALENDAR
YEAR. FIFTY PERCENT FOR THE
TWENTY ONE TO TWENTY TWO
CALENDAR YEAR AND A HUNDRED
PERCENT FOR THE TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE ACADEMIC YEAR.
THIS INCREASE IN THE ENROLLMENT
OF MEDICAL STUDENTS IN PRIME
WILL ENSURE THAT WE ARE NOT JUST
SUPPORTING THE HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE. BUT REMOVING BARRIERS
TO HIGHER EDUCATION FOR STUDENTS
OF COLOR WITHIN THE MEDICAL
FIELD.
ENSURING THAT WE ARE INVESTING
IN FUNDING HEALTHCARE EDUCATION
THROUGH PROGRAMS LIKE PRIME WE
CAN GET AHEAD OF THE SHORTFALL
IN THE HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE WE
ARE PROJECTED TO FACE IN THE
FUTURE.
AND PARTICULARLY THROUGH PRIME
WE WILL BE ABLE TO SERVE THE
NEEDS OF UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS
WHO ARE AT GREATEST RISK.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
ADRIAN MUHAMMAD FROM THE INNER
UNION OF AMERICAN PHYSICIANS AND
DENTISTS.
THANK YOU.
GET AFTERNOON.
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
STAFF MY NAME'S ADRIAN MOM IT
WITH THE YOU KNOW AMERICAN
PHYSICIANS AND DENTISTS ASKED ME
LOCAL TO A SIX.
WHERE THE SPONSOR THE MEASURE
WE REPRESENT? PHYSICIANS IN
STATE SERVICE AND COUNTY
SERVICE.
WE HAVE POSITIONS IN THE US
ISSUE AND YOU SEE.
STUDENT HEALTH CENTERS AS WELL.
AND.
AS DOCTOR ARAMBULA TESTED THIS
IS REALLY ABOUT ENSURING LONG
TERM. ACCESS TO CARE FOR OUR
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
AND.
ARE COUNTY POSITIONS CURRENTLY
THEY THEY'RE THEY'RE TAXED
AND A LOT OF THESE MEDICALLY
UNDERSERVED AREAS MANY OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY COUNTIES.
THEY THEY HAVE TO DEAL WITH SO
MANY PEOPLE GOING TO THE
EMERGENCY ROOMS AS DOCTOR
ARAMBULA STATED AND SO.
HAVING MORE DOCTORS ALLOWS US TO
MITIGATE THAT FACTOR OVER THE
COURSE OF.
THAT THE LIFE OF EVERYONE AND
THEIR GENERATION.
.
SO WE WE JUST WERE POSSIBLY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL AND I'M
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
EXPIRED THEY CALIFORNIA ACADEMY
OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
I'M CATHERINE NATION I'M THE
ASSOCIATE VICE PRESIDENT IN THE
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT I'M.
SO GRATEFUL TO SEE DOCTOR
ARAMBULA IS INTERESTING FUNDING
THESE PROGRAMS. THIS IS AN
INNOVATIVE SUTTER PROGRAMS THAT
WE LAUNCHED WITHIN YOU SEE
NEARLY FIFTEEN YEARS AGO.
WE HAVE THREE EARNED SEVENTY
ONE STUDENTS CURRENTLY ENROLLED
LEVEL OF DIVERSITY THAT IS. VERY
MUCH NEEDED AND RARELY SEEN ON
MEDICAL EDUCATION NEARLY TWO
THIRDS OUR STUDENTS WERE
UNDERREPRESENTED IN MEDICINE.
EACH OF OUR PROGRAMS HAS AN
AREA OF FOCUS ON AND TIME ON
ALLOWED TO TO GO INTO THIS BUT
WE HAVE A RURAL PRIME PROGRAM IN
URBAN UNDERSERVED PRIME PROGRAM.
THESE PROGRAMS OR PERSISTENT
REST JUST BECAUSE OF A LACK OF
CORE OPERATING SUPPORT. AND I
THINK THEY WERE LAUNCHED AT THE
TIME OF THE GREAT RECESSION AND
IT'S.
TIME I HOPE TO STABILIZE THIS
AND WILL LOOK FORWARD TO
FOLLOWING UP WITH YOU DOCTOR
ARAMBULA AROUND IN ROMAN TARGETS
IN THE VISION OF WHERE WE THINK
THIS CAN GO IN AND.
IN THE FUTURE.
ANY TWO WIENERS.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
LIKE ARAMBULA WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
I URGE YOU TO JOIN ME IN
SUPPORTING THIS BILL SO WE CAN
INVEST IN OUR STATES HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE AND WORK TOWARDS A
HEALTHIER CALIFORNIA.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
WOULD ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
MOVED BY MISTER LEVINE.
SECOND BY DOCTOR WEBER.
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THE BILL FORWARD AND TO HIS
DEDICATION AND ALWAYS LOOKING
FOR WAYS TO PROVIDE. MEDICAL
TRAINING TO AREAS THAT THAT NEED
MORE DOCTORS
SO THE MOTION WAS DO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. MADAM
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL. MEDINA
AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER.
BAKER I ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE
BLOOM CHAVEZ.
CHAVEZ I IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY. KILEY AYE
LEVINE. LEVINE AYE LOW.
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO WEBER.
WEBER I.
JURY TEN ZERO YOUR BILL IS OUT
COOKIES THAT HELP THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. WILL GO TO
ITEM TWELVE MISTER HOLDEN. A. B.
TWENTY EIGHT NINETEEN.
WELCOME.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'D
LIKE TO THANK YOU.
AND THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR WORK
ON. WORKING WITH US ON THIS BILL
IN YOUR UNDERSTANDING. OF ITS
IMPORTANCE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
NINETEEN REQUEST UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA CONDUCT A BIANNUAL
STUDY ON THE RACIAL AND ETHNIC
DIVERSITY. OF THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS EMPLOYEES OF
CALIFORNIA HIGH TECHNOLOGY
COMPANIES THE REPORT WILL
INCLUDE PROGRAMS AND BEST
PRACTICES THAT SEEK TO DIVERSIFY
THE TECHNOLOGY WORKFORCE.
AT THE TOP SEVENTY FIVE
COMPANIES IN SILICON VALLEY ONLY
THREE PERCENT. OF EMPLOYEES ARE
BLACK ACCORDING TO THE EQUAL
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY
COMMISSION.
PREMIER EMPLOYERS FACEBOOK AND
GOOGLE HAVE YET TO ACHIEVE TWO
PERCENT AND TECHNICAL JOBS.
ANY DISCUSSION ABOUT DIVERSE
HIRING SIICON VALLEY INEVITABLY
BECOMES A DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
PIPELINE.
YET IT HAS BEEN REPORTED BY THE
NATIONAL SCIENCE FOUNDATION IN
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN THAT THERE
WERE TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY TWO
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
ONE. AMERICANS OF COLOR AGES
FORTY FIVE YEARS AND YOUNGER
WITH BACHELOR'S OR ADVANCED
DEGREES IN COMPUTER. AND
MATHEMATICAL SCIENCES AS WELL AS
ELECTRICAL ENGINEERING JUST
THREE OF SEVERAL FEELS CLOSELY
ASSOCIATED WITH. HIGH TECH JOBS
REPRESENTING EIGHTEEN POINT
EIGHT. PERCENT. OF DEGREE
HOLDERS
YOU KNOW THE PEOPLE OF COLOR
WITH DEGREES IN THESE BILLS
SEVEN PERCENT. OF MEN AND TWELVE
PERCENT OF WOMEN WHO ARE
UNEMPLOYED UNEMPLOYED. COMPARED
WITH TWO PERCENT OF WHITE MEN.
OUR COMMUNITIES ARE UNDER
UTILIZE AND UNDER EMPLOYED.
FURTHERMORE THERE IS A SIXTY
FIVE PERCENT INCREASE AMONG
HISPANIC STUDENTS AND A FIFTY
PERCENT INCREASE AMONG BLACK
STUDENTS FOR STEM DEGREES.
AND TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN TOP
SILICON VALLEY FIRMS BEGAN
DISCLOSING THEIR DIVERSITY DATA.
AND TAKING STEPS TOWARDS GROUP.
REMEDYING THEIR DIVERSITY
PROBLEM AMID PUBLIC PRESSURE.
YET WE ARE UNSURE IF THERE ARE
ANY TANGIBLE CAO COMES FROM
THEIR EFFORTS.
ALTHOUGH TECH COMPANIES ARE
EAGER TO SHARE THEIR SUPPORT FOR
DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION THEY ARE
NOT AS EAGER TO SHARE THEIR
PROGRAMS AND PRACTICES.
I ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT FROM
THE COMMITTEES ANALYSIS THAT THE
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND EQUAL
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY
COMMISSION REPORT FOUND. THAT
NATIONWIDE BLACKS HISPANICS AND
HISPANICS WERE
DISPROPORTIONATELY FEWER IN
LEADERSHIP POSITIONS AND AND
TECHNOLOGY JOBS IN THE HIGH TECH
SECTOR. AND THAT THESE GROUPS
HAD NEGLIGIBLY NEXT NEGLIGIBLE
EMPLOYMENT REPRESENTATION. AND
HIGH TECH INDUSTRIES IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA.
AS WITH FAIR HOUSING AND
EMPLOYMENT EFFORTS IS UP TO US
TO FORCE THE ISSUE AND MAKE IT A
PRIORITY SINCE DIVERSITY IS THE
VERY FABRIC. THAT CALIFORNIA'S
MADE.
AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETEEN WILL
EXPLORE THE DIVERSITY PROGRAMS
AND HIRING PRACTICES THAT EXIST
THROUGH AN ACADEMIC WINS TO
CREATE A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF
HOW TO ADDRESS THE LACK OF
DIVERSITY. IN THE SILICON
VALLEY.
THIS BILL ALSO HELP US DETERMINE
WHAT IS NEEDED TO INCREASE
DIVERSE HIRING IN THE FASTEST
GROWING INDUSTRY TO ENSURE ALL
COMMUNITIES ARE CONSIDERED. FOR
THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THE RIGHT.
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY TWEENER.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
IN IS BAKER THANK YOU AND THEN
YOU HAVE UNDERSCORED JUST.
HAY A ISSUE THAT OUR STATE IN
OUR CULTURE REALLY DOES NEED TO
ADDRESS.
MY OPPOSITION TO THIS IS THAT
WE RE DIRECT.
SO MUCH TO YOU SEE TO DO AND
THEN WE ASK THEM.
MAYBE WE'LL FIND IT MAYBE WE
WON'T FIND IT.
AND.
AND I THINK I DO BELIEVE THAT
THESE IN FACT THE SOURCE OF SOME
INFORMATION YOU HAVE.
SHOWS THAT WE CAN GET THIS
INFORMATION WITHOUT GIVING
ANOTHER. ASK HAVE YOU SEE AT A
TIME WHEN YOU HAVE BEEN ONE OF
ITS HARSHEST CRITICS IN TERMS OF
HOW IT SPENDS ITS DOLLARS BUT.
THE FINGER COMMUNITY BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE IS THAT EVERY TIME
WE ASK THEM TO DO A STUDY.
AND EVERY TIME WE ASK HIM TO DO
REPORTS AFTER REPORTS AFTER
PORTS THEY'RE GONNA NEED A LINE
ITEM AT SOME POINT TO DO THAT
AND. I WOULD I AM JUST LOATH TO
DO THAT WHEN THERE ARE DEATHLY
OTHER WAYS TO GET. YOU SEE TO
APPLY FOR GRANTS.
ACROSS THE COUNTRY TO GET. THIS
VERY RESEARCH THAT WE NEED AND
SO IT'S NOT AT ALL OUT OF.
A DISREGARD FOR THE VERY GOOD
SPOTLIGHT YOU ARE SHINING ON AN
ISSUE THAT IS WORTHY OF
ATTENTION IT'S THAT.
I THINK THE SOLUTION IS ONE
THAT AT WE CAN START GOING FOR
WITHOUT.
PUTTING ANOTHER ASK OF UC SO I
THANK YOU FOR THE THOUGHTFUL
APPROACH TO THE ISSUE.
AND I WILL NOT BE SUPPORTING
TODAY THAT PERHAPS WILL
ENCOURAGE THEM TO. GO AHEAD AND
AND BE APPLYING FOR THESE ARE
MANY OF THE OTHER ENTITIES IN
THERE SO MANY NONPROFIT RESEARCH
ENTITIES AROUND THE COUNTRY AND
IN CALIFORNIA. THAT CAN BE
UNDERTAKING THIS WITHOUT ANOTHER
DIRECTIVE FROM THE LEGISLATURE'S
THANK YOU.
I I WOULD ASK THE AUTHOR IS
THERE BEEN ANY DISCUSSIONS WITH
YOU SEE.
ESPECIALLY. TO MS BAKER'S POINT.
UP ON ON FUNDING AT ALL THERE
BEEN ANY DISCUSSIONS WITH YOU
SEE.
THERE HAVE BEEN.
AND I SEE YOU SEE. COMING IN THE
MICROPHONE.
YES GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS JASON MURPHY UP WE HAVE
WE EVER SEE CALIFORNIA I HAVE
BEEN IN TOUCH WITH THE AUTHOR
STAFF RECENTLY.
THE DELAY IN GETTING CONNECTED
WAS ON MY END NOT IN THE ON THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND AND SO WE
DO LOOK FORWARD TO CONNECTING
FURTHER WITH THE AUTHOR HAS THIS
BILL MOVES FORWARD TOWARDS
APPROPRIATIONS. THE ISSUE OF
COST IS IMPORTANT ONE I DON'T
ONE UNDERSCORE OR I DON'T WANT
TO MINIMIZE THE THE IMPACT TOM.
WILL CONTINUES CONVERSATIONS OF
THE POEM WAS FORWARD THANK YOU.
AND AND AND ANOTHER QUESTION.
TO THE AUTHOR OF.
WHY DO YOU BELIEVE?
THAT YOU SEE IS THE THE
APPROPRIATE. ABOUT.
ENTITY TO BE DOING THE STUDY.
I WILL WELL I THINK FOR RELEASED
A COUPLE REASONS ONE.
LOOKING AT IT THROUGH AN
ACADEMIC LANDS.
AND TO THAT AS A RESEARCH
MINDED INSTITUTION I THINK THEY
HAVE THE.
INSTITUTIONAL STRUCTURE TO BE
ABLE TO GET US TO WHERE I THINK
WE NEED TO BE ON THIS IN TERMS
OF GATHERING INFORMATION.
YOU KNOW.
IN A PERFECT WORLD. A VOTE
PERFECT WORLD THIS WOULD BE AN
ISSUE BUT TO THE EXTENT THAT.
YOU HAVE A SILICON VALLEY
COMPANIES THAT HAVE BEEN
ENGAGING WITH US AND I WILL SAY
THEY'RE THEY'RE THEY'RE STARTING
TO HAVE MORE CONVERSATION AROUND
THE TOPIC.
BICU IT. IN THAT PERFECT
WORLD LOOK TO SEE THEM TAKE ON
INITIATIVES THAT WOULD WOULD
CREATE. A MORE OPEN DOOR POLICY
AND A CULTURE THAT WAS LOOKING
TO BRING IN.
OF THE KIND OF DIVERSITY THAT
THE STATE ATTACKS WE PRIDE IN. A
BUT TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION WE
BELIEVE THAT THE UC'S PROVIDE
THE KIND OF INSTITUTIONAL
STRUCTURE ACADEMIC STRUCTURE AND
WE.
THE ABILITY TO DO THE KIND OF
RESEARCH I THINK WILL BE HELPFUL
TO US IN THIS PROCESS.
GIVEN ANOTHER. WEEK OR TWO AND
WITH THAT KIND OF DIRECTION THAT
WE COULD HAVE IDENTIFIED SOME
OTHER.
WAYS OF GOING OUT IT BUT.
I THINK BECAUSE OF THE
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE STATE.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
UC'S I THINK IT'S ALSO
APPROPRIATE.
.
A RELATIONSHIP THAT WE WANNA.
BUILD ON IT EVEN THOUGH I
UNDERSTAND AND APPRECIATE THE
FACT THAT THEY WERE CAUGHT
POTENTIAL COSTS INVOLVED.
AND WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE UC'S IN.
TERMS OF HOW WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS THAT AND TO BE HONEST
WITH YOU THESE BUDGETS ARE SO.
SO VAST THAT.
ONE COULD PROBABLY LOOK AT A
LINE ITEM OR LOOK AT A TOTAL
BUDGET AND FIGURE OUT WHAT THE
COST COULD BE AND HOW IT COULD
BE ABSORBED. BUT THAT'S PART OF
THE CONVERSATION THEY WERE
WILLING TO HAVE WITH.
REPRESENTS OF THE UC'S GOING
FORWARD.
WELL I I SHARE WITH THE AUTHORED
THE THE GOAL. AND.
IN MY.
A LIMITED TRIPS TO SILICON
VALLEY IS AN ISSUE THAT I
BROUGHT UP WITH THEM. AND THAT I
KNOW THAT THE LATINO CAUCUS HAS
DONE AS WELL.
OUR AND I.
PASSED THE AUTHOR FEE MIGHT.
INCLUDE.
THE LGBT. A COMMUNITY IN THE
STUDY AS WELL THINK JUST AS A
SUGGESTION I'M NOT A. WITHOUT A
DOUBT.
THANK YOU.
.
SO DID WE HAVE THEM WHO.
MR LOVE IF ENACTED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I APPRECIATE THAT
THAT RECOGNITION OF THE ALTAR
COMMUNITY AND.
NOW WANTED PUBLICLY STATE THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE COLLABORATION
AS FELLOW CHAIRS OF THE
RESPECTIVE CAUCUSES TO BE AS
INCLUSIVE AS POSSIBLE. AND I
APPRECIATE THAT MOVING FORWARD
TO INCLUDE THE UGLY COMMUNITY.
I AS I REPRESENT SILICON VALLEY
MUCH OF THE CONVERSATION IS TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE A WIDE
VARIETY OF DIVERSITY TO
CELEBRATE THE STRENGTH OF THE
VERSION THAT. WILL BE REFLECTIVE
OF SOCIETY.
BUT THE SENSE OF THAT THE THE.
IMPLEMENTATION AND AUTHORITY
WITH YOU SEE TO HOWEVER BECAUSE
A TO TO GET THIS INFORMATION AND
THE DATA FROM TECH COMPANIES.
HAVE YOU FORESEE THE YOU SEE
HAVING THE CAPACITY IN THAT SORT
OF THE TEETH TO BE ABLE TO. DO
THAT MY APOLOGIES IF A YOUR TO
ANSWER THAT EARLIER.
WELL I THINK YOUR. WELL SORT OF
NOT REALLY I THINK THE POINT IS
IS THAT WE'RE LOOKING TO THE
UC'S BECAUSE YOU SEE IS.
OUR RESEARCH INTENSIVE IN TERMS
OF HOW THEY.
THERE JUST TO THE FABRIC OF HOW
THE INSTITUTIONS PUT TOGETHER SO
WE SEE THAT AS AN ASSET AND.
VALUABLE ASSET AND I THINK THAT
THERE WOULD BE AT LEAST ON THIS
INITIAL GLIMPSE THE MOST
APPROPRIATE.
THAT THAT IS THAT DID THE BUT
THAT THINK THE CAPACITY THAT THE
UC HAS TO TO TO GET THIS
INFORMATION.
IT ABOUT
CAN YOU HELP EXPLAIN PERHAPS
WHERE THE UC HAS THE HOW. TO
WORK FORTY TWO THEY HAVE TO
DEMAND THIS INFORMATION FROM
THEM SOMEONE WILL A LOT OF THE
RESEARCH IS A LOT OF THE DATA IS
AVAILABLE.
SO IT'S IT'S NOT LIKE THERE
WOULD BE NECESSARILY CREATING
THE DATA IT'S BASICALLY
COLLECTING THE DATA WHICH HAS
ALREADY BEEN.
DIGNIFIED AS I MENTIONED IN MY
MY TALKING POINTS THERE'S
ALREADY.
SOME RECORD RECOGNITION OF WHAT
THE PERCENTAGES ARE VARIOUS.
IMPACTED GROUPS AND HOW THEY
ARE NOT EMPLOYED WITHIN CERTAIN
TECH COMPANIES WITHIN THE AT
WITHIN THAT REGION AND SO WHERE.
LOOKING AND HOPING THAT WE WOULD
BE ABLE TO DRAW UPON EXISTING
DATA TO HELP IN TERMS OF.
FASHIONING SOME UNDERSTANDING OF
HOW TO MOVE FORWARD GREAT WELL I
I AM GOT IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
A BILL IN THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION AND HOPE THAT THE
LEGISLATIVE AND INTENT.
ENCAPSULATES A COLLABORATIVE
FOCUS WHICH IS THAT OF THIS IS
NOT ABOUT A DEMANDING OF THE
RATHER WORKING WITH AT THE TECH
COMMUNITY ENSURING THAT WE HAVE
A CALIFORNIA THAT IS REFLECTIVE
OF OUR COMMUNITY. AND OUR
SOCIETY.
THANK YOU.
TO TO THAT POINT I I THINK THAT
THAT IS A POINT WORTH
UNDERSCORING I KNOW THAT.
THE VTECH COMMUNITY WAS HERE.
MAYBE A MONTH AGO A
REPRESENTING OVER THE BEGIN OF
THIS MONTH. ARE RECOGNIZING.
.
TECH AWARENESS INTACT A IN IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO WE
WANT TO CONTINUE TO BUILD ON
THAT.
BUT WE DO THINK THESE ARE SOME
IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN
NEGLECTED FOR AWHILE THAT
SOMEONE TO BE SERIOUS AND SOBER
ABOUT HOW WE GO AFTER BUT I DO
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT.
TO UNDERSCORE THAT WILL BE IN
COLLABORATION.
SEE NO OTHER QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE THE
MISTER HOLDING WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE A LET THAT BE MY CLOSING
RESPECTFULLY ANSWERING.
.
AND I WOULD ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
MOVED BY DOCTOR WEBER SECOND BY
MISTER BLOOM.
.
THE THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. A
MADAM SECRETARY OF YOU WOULD
CALL THE ROLL.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER.
BAKER NO ARAMBULA. BLOOM.
BLOOM I CHAVEZ
CHAVEZ NO IRWIN.
KILEY.
KILEY NO LEVINE LEVINE I LOW.
LOW AYE PATTERSON.
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO WEBER.
WEBER I.
THREE BILL IS ON CALL.
KEEP IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU MISTER OR
YEAH.
NEXT ITEM FIVE MR MCCARTY.
AB TWENTY TO FORTY. EIGHT.
THANK YOU.
IT'S GOOD TO BE IN THIS COZY
ROOM.
YES.
WELL I'D THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I YOU KNOW I I CAME HERE A FEW
WEEKS AGO WITH THAT MUCH MORE
PROVOCATIVE BILL ON THIS SAME
TOPIC AND I WANT TO THANK YOU.
AND YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR FOR WORKING WITH US TO COME
UP WITH SOMETHING THAT I THINK
ADD MEETS THE GOAL OF WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH AND IS THAT
A REALISTIC WITH THEIR. CSU
STUDENTS AND THE CSU
ADMINISTRATION SO ESSENTIALLY
THIS BILL IS ABOUT SOUTH FINANCE
LADEN CALIFORNIA FULL TIME
STATUS WE ALL KNOW WE HAVE A.
PROBLEM WITH NINE THAT CSU
STUDENTS GRADUATING WITHIN FOUR
YEARS IN FACT ONLY NINETEEN
PERCENT. ARE GRADUATING IN FOUR
YEARS ON SALE STORY.
THEN I MET WITH FORCED TO SEE IF
YOU STUDENTS LAST MONTH. REAL
QUICK AND I ASK THEM.
MY LAST OR NOT.
MY LETS STORY FROM THE NIGHT
TECH
I ASKED THE STUDENTS ARE YOU CAL
GRANT RECIPIENTS
THEY ALSO YES.
I ONE BY ONE I SAID DO YOU YOU
KNOW I ARE YOU TAKE COMING IT'S
YOU TAKEN THIS AT TWELVE
THIRTEEN ELEVEN FOURTEEN.
AS WOULD YOU KNOW IF YOU IF YOU
DON'T GRADUATE FOR YEARS.
A TWELVE PERSON MESSES NOT FOUR
YEARS YOU RUN OUT OF YOUR
CALDERON IF IT'S. NOT OF A NEW.
REVENUE AND THEY'RE REAL
IMPLICATIONS IT'S ABOUT SIXTY
SEVENTY GRAND. AND.
COST OF LIVING FINANCIAL LAY
BOOKS A SO WORKS TO GO TO
COLLEGE IF YOU LOSE YOUR CAL
GRANT SO COMING UP WITH A PLAN
TO MAKE SURE STUDENTS KNOW ABOUT
INFORMATION THE FRONT END THAT
WITH ME.
IS THAT GRADUATIONS ARE THAT CSU
SACRAMENTO WHO INSPIRED US TO DO
THIS BILL AS WELL AS THE
DIRECTOR OF THIS UNIQUE MISSION.
THANK YOU.
SWITCHING MY NAME IS JIM DRAGNA
I SERVE AS THE ARM EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR STUDENTS ARM.
EXCESS AND UNIVERSITY
INITIATIVES AT SACRAMENTO STATE
AND YES I AM DESIGNATED AS THE
GRADUATIONS ARE I THINK YOU FOR
AN OPPORTUNITY TO TALK WITH YOU
TODAY. I'M NOT TALKING ON BEHALF
OF THE CSU ARM SYSTEM AND I WANT
TO BE ON CLEAR WITHOUT AS WELL.
SACRAMENTO STATE AS MANY.
UNIVERSITIES THROUGHOUT THE
NATION ARE ABOUT THE BUSINESS AT
THIS TIME OF OPTIMIZING STUDENT
SUCCESS WE MEASURE THAT IN ONE
WAY BY LOOKING AT IMPROVE
GRADUATION RATES. OF FOREIGN TEN
TODAY WE'RE LOOKING AT FOUR YEAR
GRADUATION RATES.
LIKE OTHER UNIVERSITY SACRAMENTO
STATE HAS BEEN A PART OF OF
DEVELOPING EDUCATION PROGRAMS TO
WORK WITH STUDENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES. AND LOOKING AT THE
ADVANTAGES OF GRADUATING IN FOUR
YEARS WE HAVE AS WELL HIRED NEW
FACULTY OVER SEVENTY OVER THE
LAST TWO YEAR SEVEN HUNDRED NEW
SECTIONS TO ALLOW THOSE CLASSES
TO BE AVAILABLE TO GO. TO OUR
STUDENTS WERE PURSUING THAT
ENDEAVOR.
AS WELL AS OFFERING ONGOING
SUPPORT ACADEMIC AND FINANCIAL
FOR STUDENTS IN ORDER FOR THEM
TO PROGRESS THE WAY THEY
INTENDED EXPECT TO.
I'M ONE OF THE MESSAGES IT'S
OFTEN LOST WITH ALL OF THESE BUT
PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE AT THE
UNIVERSITY.
IS THAT THERE IS A SIMPLE
DIRECTION ABOUT HOW TO FINISH IN
FOUR YEARS AND THAT IS TO TAKE
THIRTY HOURS EACH YEAR. THE IDEA
OF FOUR TIMES THIRTY CALL
HUNDRED AND TWENTY IS ALSO
OFTENTIMES MISCONSTRUED BY OUR
STUDENTS AND ESPECIALLY THOSE
STUDENTS WHO MAY BE FIRST
GENERATION STUDENTS OR NOT
REALLY FAMILIAR WITH THE
OFFICIAL DIRECTION. OF MANY
MEDIEVAL INSTITUTION
FORMALITIES.
SO WHAT WE DO AT THE UNIVERSITY
AND WHAT WE'VE DONE OVER THIS
LAST TWO YEARS IS DURING OUR
SUMMER PROGRAM WE HAVE A FINISH
IN FOUR OBJECTIVE. WE ASK OUR
STUDENTS TO PLEDGE TO TAKE
FIFTEEN HOURS IN THEIR FIRST TWO
SEMESTERS WORTH THIRTY HOURS IN
THEIR FIRST YEAR. IN OTHER WORDS
WE ASK THEM THE PLEDGE.
FINISH OR INTEND TO FINISH IN
FOUR.
AS A RESULT OF THAT PROGRAM A
LAST TWO YEARS.
I SHOULD MENTION THAT WE'VE
RAISED OUR FIRST YEAR
PARTICIPATION AND AND FIFTEEN
HOURS. FROM TWENTY SEVEN PERCENT
IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE TO EIGHTY
FOUR PERCENT ON THIS LAST
ORIENTATION PERIOD.
WE FEEL THAT A SIGNIFICANT PART
OF THAT INCREASE IS THAT SIMPLE
MESSAGE THAT HELPS TO STUDENTS
TO DEFINE THEIR EXPECTATION AND
TO PLAN THEIR PARTICULAR
JOURNEY.
IN ACCORDING TO THE PATH OF FOR
YEARS.
WHAT WE?
ENDORSE WITHIN THIS PARTICULAR
BILL HIS SAID THIS ON PROGRAM
MARRIES THAT OBJECTIVE WITH THE
CAL GRANT
WE HAVE OVER FIFTEEN THOUSAND
STUDENTS AT SACRAMENTO STATE.
WHO ARE CAL STATE AS QUICKLY CAL
GRANT RECIPIENTS?
AND WE FEEL THAT AT THE POINT OF
TIME OR THEY.
ACKNOWLEDGE OR.
UNDERTAKE TAKING ON THE CAL
GRANT THAT THEY WILL BE NOTIFIED
AGAIN.
THAT THE COW PRINT ITSELF IS A
FOUR YEAR OPTIMAL TYPE OF
PROGRAM IT IS TIME LIMITED AND
IT IS OUR EXPECTATION THAT THEIR
EXPECTATIONS WILL BE MARRIED TO
THE FACT. THAT FINISHING IN FOR
ALSO ALLOWS ITSELF THROUGH BEING
A CAL STATE.
RUGRATS HIS MERE CAL GRANT
RECIPIENT THE OPPORTUNITY ON TV
TO DIRECT AND PROGRAM THEIR
PETITION OF THEIR PARTICULAR
FINANCIAL AID IN A WAY THAT
HELPS AND OPTIMIZES THAT
ENDEAVOR.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND REPEAT THAT
COURSE THAT SOMEHOW LA I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION. A WHILE THE
COMMISSION DOES NOT HAVE A
FORMAL POSITION ON TWENTY FORTY
EIGHT THE BILL ALIGNS VERY
CLOSELY WITH OUR EFFORTS TO
PROVIDE STUDENTS. THE
INFORMATION AND SUPPORT THEY
NEED TO SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETE
THEIR DEGREE OBJECTIVES THIS
BILL REALLY OFFERS OF REALLY
GOOD SOLUTION THAT EMPOWERS
STUDENTS WITH THE KNOWLEDGE THAT
THEY NEED TO GRADUATE ON TIME IT
REQUIRES THE COMMISSION.
AND THE A SEGMENTS TO WORK SIDE
BY SIDE TO ENSURE THAT STUDENTS
ARE INFORMED THAT FIFTEEN UNITS
THIS SEMESTER THIRTY UNITS PER
YEAR IS NEEDED TO COMPLETE. A
TYPICAL FOR YOUR DEGREE IN FOUR
YEARS STUDENT WILL RECEIVE THIS
RECEIVE THIS INFORMATION BEFORE
THEY GET TO CAMPUS THROUGH THE
COMMISSION'S.
FINANCIAL AID AWARD.
SECOND ONE STUDENTS ARE ON
CAMPUS ALL STUDENTS WILL RECEIVE
IT AGAIN DURING ORIENTATION AND
THIRDLY A STUDENTS CONTINUING
THEIR EDUCATION ALL STUDENTS
WILL CONTINUE TO BE REMINDED
THROUGH THE ENROLLMENT OF
CLASSESTHAT TAKING THIRTY UNITS
WILL ALLOW THEM TO GRADUATE IN
FOUR YEARS.
WE AS POLICY MAKERS HAVE AN
IMPORTANT RESPONSIBILITY TO
ALIGN OUR EXPECTATIONS OF
STUDENTS WITH OF SUFFICIENT
SUPPORT AND RESOURCES WE HAVEN'T
YET FOUND THAT PERFECT BALANCE
BUT WE CONTINUE TO WORK TOWARDS
IT. THE COMMISSION AND THE
LEGISLATURE'S EFFORTS TO
STREAMLINE THE STATE'S GENEROUS
FINANCIAL AID PROGRAMS TO COVER
MORE OF THE COST OF ATTENDANCE
IS ONE WAY. THE SEGMENTS OF
EFFORTS TO INCREASE WITH ON TIME
GRADUATION IS ANOTHER AND THIS
BILL REPRESENTS A SIGNIFICANT
STEP. IN ACHIEVING THAT BALANCE
THANK YOU AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
IF YOU.
ANY QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS I'M SORRY ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MANY RODRIGUEZ ON BEHALF
EDUCATION TRUST WEST WE DID NOT
HAVE A CHANCE TO SUBMIT A LETTER
BUT WE HAVE APPROVED OUR
OPPOSITION TO THE PREVIOUS
VERSION. AND ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THE INFORMATIONAL CAMPAIGN
THINKING.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS J.
PRINTER WITH THE CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY WE ALSO
DIDN'T HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SUBMIT A LETTER OF SUPPORT BUT I
AM HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CAMPAIGN. TO OFFER OUR SUPPORT
FOR THE EFFORT TO BETTER INFORM
STUDENTS AROUND THEIR FINANCIAL
AID AS WELL AS HELP THEM
GRADUATE IN A TIMELY FASHION
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ALEX GRAVES AT
THE CSU CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE WE.
IN THE BILL THAT WAS INTRODUCED
HAD OPPOSED.
THE PROPOSAL HOWEVER WITH THE
AMENDMENTS WE'VE REMOVED OUR
OPPOSITION WE ARE RUNNING AT
THREE OUR INTERNAL PROCESS I
THANK YOU TO THE MEMBER. AYE AND
THE STAFF FOR THE AMENDMENTS WE
HOPE TO GET TO A SUPPORT
POSITION IN THE NEAR FUTURE
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER BETWEEN HERS.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY COMMENT SIR.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE.
MR MCCARTY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
THANK YOU.
YOUR YOUR SUPPORT ASKING RIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR THE TO THE AUTHOR
TO BRING THIS MEASURE FORWARD TO
INFORM STUDENTS OF THE POTENTIAL
CONSEQUENCES OF TAKING LESS.
THAN A FULL LOAD OF CLASSES
I.
APPLAUD THE EFFORTS OF OF
SACRAMENTO STATE.
AND AS NOTED IN THE ANNOUNCES
THE OTHERS EFFORT TO EXPAND THE
SUCCESS.
THAT'S ACT STATE HAS BY
PROVIDING TIMELY AND REPEATED.
NOTIFICATIONS OF STUDENTS ON
THEIR NEED TO TRY TO TAKE
SUFFICIENT COURSES TO GRADUATE
ON TIME. WITH EMOTION BUT HIS
BAKER SECOND BY MISTER LO. THE
IT'S DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
AND SECRETARY.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER.
BAKER I ARAMBULA BLOOM.
BLOOM I CHAVEZ.
CHAVEZ I IRWIN.
KILEY.
KILEY AYE LEVINE LEVINE AYE LOW.
LOW AYE PATTERSON QUIRK SILVA.
SANTIAGO WEBER.
GIVE.
SEVEN ZERO YOUR BILL IS OUT WE
WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
WE CAN NOW TAKE UP ITEM NUMBER
NINE.
BY CHAIR MEDINA AB TWO SIX SIX
SIX
.
IT'S CHAIRMAN EVERY READY. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
TODAY I PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SIX SIXTY SIX.
AB TWENTY SIX SIXTY SIX.
ESTABLISHES AN INTER AGENCY
AGREEMENT WHICH WILL MEASURE
EMPLOYMENT OUTCOMES OF STUDENTS
AND CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
PROGRAMS.
THE BILL REQUIRES THE
COLLABORATION BETWEEN THE D. M.
V.. THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
AND THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND
THE EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT TO TRACK WAGE DATA SO
THAT CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
PROGRAMS. CAN BE IMPROVED TO
YIELD OPTIMAL RESULTS FOR ITS
STUDENTS.
SOME OF THE ISSUES OF PRIVACY IS
HAVE BEEN MENTION ANDI CAN
ASSURE YOU THAT ALL AGENCIES
WILL PROTECT THE DATA.
CLARIFY.
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WOULD NOT BE RECEIVING
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBERS.
THE ONLY INFORMATION THAT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. AND THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE WOULD BE
GETTING BACK IS WAGED DATA. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE HERE WITH ME TODAY ON
BEHALF OF AB TWENTY SIX SIXTY
SIX.
OUR LARA MATTOON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. AND
ALEJANDRO IS B. KNOWS THAT WITH
THE STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC EDUCATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M MORE MATURE
IN WITH THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE WHERE THE CO
SPONSORS OF AB TWENTY SIX SIXTY
SIX.
IN SEPTEMBER A BOARD OF
GOVERNORS APPROVED OUR VISION
FOR SUCCESS THE VISION CONTAINS
SIX GOALS FROM PRUDENT IMPROVING
STUDENT OUTCOMES. AND A SERIES
OF COMMITMENTS ONE OF THE
COMMITMENTS WE MAKE TO OUR
SYSTEM IS THAT WE WILL FOSTER
THE USE OF DATA TO DRIVE
DECISION MAKING ACROSS THE
COLLEGES. TO THIS AND OUR OFFICE
PUBLISHES AN ANNUAL SCORECARD TO
ABOUT WHO YOU A COLLEGE PROGRESS
AND WE PUBLISH AN ANNUAL LAUNCH
BOARD THAT PROVIDES DATA THAT
COLLEGES CAN USE TO UNDERSTAND
HOW THEIR CAREER EDUCATION
PROGRAMS ARE GIVING IN IMPROVING
STUDENT OUTCOMES. SPECIFICALLY
WE CAN LOOK AT SALARY GAINES AND
PLACEMENT RATES AND WE CAN LOOK
AT HOW MANY OF OUR GRADUATES
ATTAIN A REGIONAL LIVING WAGE WE
ALSO PUBLISH AN ONLINE TOOL
CALLED SALARY SURFER. THAT
ALLOWS THE PUBLIC TO VIEW THIS
AGGREGATE INFORMATION AND THEY
CAN HELP STUDENTS MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS ABOUT WHAT PROGRAMS
THEY MIGHT LIKE TO STUDY.
IN.
THIS IS ALL A.
ABLE TO HAPPEN BECAUSE OF AN
AGREEMENT WE HAVE UNDER EXISTING
CALIFORNIA LAW THAT ALLOWS US TO
ENTER INTO A DATA SHARING
ARRANGEMENT WITH THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT. TO MATCH
OUR GRADUATES WITH WAGE FILES
THAT THEY CAN.
HAVE ON FILE AYE WE HAVE BEEN
DOING THIS PUP AND PROVIDING
THIS INFORMATION SINCE TWENTY
THIRTEEN AND TWENTY FOURTEEN
SENATOR HUFF AUTHORED A BILL
THAT ACT REQUIRED CSU AND YOU
SEE TO PUBLISH SIMILAR DATA.
WE SUPPORT THIS BILL IT WOULD
ENCOURAGE A SIMILAR DATA SHARING
AGREEMENT THAT WOULD INVOLVE
STUDENTS THAT TOUCH THE UC CUT
BY CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ON HOW THERE'S BEEN ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE.
STATE SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TOM TOWARD ACCENT CO
SPONSOR OF THE BILL. OF THIS
BILL STEMMED FROM ORACLE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE THE OF THE
ADULT EDUCATION BLOCK GRANT
ALONG WITH THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE.
WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT?
ON OUR SIDE ADULT STUDENTS OR.
ADULT COURSES ADVOCATE TWELVE
LEVEL DON'T COLLECT SOCIAL
SECURITY.
SO THAT WAS ONE BARRIER AND KIND
OF COLLECTING AND SEEING.
SOME OF THE WAGE DATA TO SEE
HOW STUDENTS ARE FARING AFTER
COMPLETING COURSEWORK. IN THE
EVENT OF DEVELOPING THE
PROPOSAL.
WE ALSO LOOK AT HOW WE CAN
EXPAND THIS TO LOOK AT K. TWELVE
RECENT GRADUATES
TO TO BE A TO BE ABLE TO BETTER
INFORMED AND AT DATA TO OUR
COLLEGE AND CAREER INDICATOR FOR
THE DASHBOARD.
SO WE'RE HOPING.
WITH THIS DATA WOULD BE ABLE TO
SEE THE NUMBER PERCENT OF
STUDENTS WHO ENTERED THE
WORKFORCE DIRECTLY. OUT OF HIGH
SCHOOL WHAT SECTOR THEY THEY
WENT INTO.
THEIR THEIR WAGE LOOKING AT.
STUDENTS WHO ENTER THE
WORKFORCE.
MAKING HIGHER WAGES IF THE
COMPLETED A CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION PATHWAY OR SOME SORT
OF CERTIFICATION OR THEY ARE
THEY GOING DIRECTLY INTO.
ANOTHER SECTION OF HIGHER
EDUCATION.
AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE
CHANCES OFFICE MENTIONED
ON THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
WOULD NOT RECEIVE SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBERS.
WE WOULD BE SENDING OUR NAME OUR
FIRST NAME LAST NAME. BIRTHDATE.
GENDER AND THE STUDENT.
I DE.
TO THE DMV WHO THEN WOULD
IDENTIFY.
THOUGH SOCIAL SECURE SECURITY
NUMBERS THOSE NUMBERS WOULD BE
VAN TRANSFER TO THE E. D. D.
DIRECTLY.
I WHAT WE WOULD GET BACK IS
BASICALLY.
THE STUDENT IDENTIFIER WITH THE
WAGE STATE ON WE WOULD NOT
RECEIVE SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBERS
AT ALL. THE ONLY FOLKS THAT
WOULD I'M LOOK BE ABLE TO SEE
THOSE SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBERS
WOULD BE BOTH THE DMV AND EBD
WHO ALREADY HAVE ACCESS TO THE
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBERS.
AND AGAIN. WE'RE HOPING THAT
THIS DATA.
WOULD HELP INFORM SCHOOL
DISTRICTS UP TO SEE WATER THEIR
LOCAL NEEDS WITH REGARDS TO.
EMPLOYMENT AND SO FORTH TO
BETTER ALIGN THEIR CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION PROGRAMS.
AND WITH THAT OF HOLLOW OPEN UP
FOR QUESTIONS AND I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
TWEENER SOME OTHER COMMENTS.
ANYWAY THIS IS IN OPPOSITION.
TRIP BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
I DO HAVE MY EM.
THOUGHTS AND QUESTIONS HAD THAT
WE TALKED ABOUT IN
TRANSPORTATION WHEN THIS WAS
BEFORE TRANSPORTATION I
APPRECIATE. THAT YEAH THE FIRST
APPRECIATE THE GOAL JUST MAKING
SURE FOR GONNA HAVEPROGRAMS RUN
HAVE EXPENDITURES TRYING TO DO
PROGRAMS.
TOO OFTEN WE MIGHT SEE RESULTS
BUT WE DON'T KNOW WHICH PROGRAM
TO TIED TO THE RESULTS SO THAT
WE CAN INVEST IN THOSE MORE AND
WHICH ONES ARE FAILING WE OR
UNDER PERFORMING THAT WE CAN.
NOT PRIORITIZE.
HOWEVER THE WHILE YOU MAY NOT BE
GETTING SO SECURITY NUMBERS TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION THE
RELIANCE ON THEM PARTICULARLY
WITH THE WITH EDT.
IS WHERE I FEEL THIS IS FLAWED
AND WHY I DIDN'T SUPPORT IN
TRANSPORTATION AND AGAIN DO NOT
TODAY.
EDT HAS.
USES FULL SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBERS WHEN THEY MAIL. UP
BENEFIT INFORMATION OUT TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS.
AND THEY SAY THAT THE REASON WHY
THEY'RE SO RELIANT ON THE FULL
SO SECURITY NUMBERS IT THEY NEED
ANOTHER FIVE OR SIX YEARS. TO
CHANGE THEIR SOFTWARE AND IT'S
GONNA TAKE MILLIONS AND MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS.
THE MORE WE PERPETUATE THAT
INSTEAD OF STARVING OUR STATE OF
HAVING TO RELY ON FULL SO
SECURITY NUMBERS THE MORE WE
ARE.
CONTINUING TO CREATE A COSTLY
PROBLEM. AND SEE WHERE I WOULD
BE CONCERNED IS THAT THIS IS
GOING TO BE POTENTIALLY A VALID
REPORTING THAT WE'RE GOING TO
WANT TO SEE. BUT. RIGHT NOW EDTA
IS TRYING TO CHANGE OVER A SIX
YEAR PROCESS ITS COMPUTERS IF
THEY COME TO US AGAIN AND SAY
WELL WE IT'S GOING TO BE EVEN
MORE EXPENSIVE BECAUSE NOW WE'RE
GETTING ALL THIS INFORMATION
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT FOR THIS
REPORT. BUT WE HAVE TO HAVE THE
FULL SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER FOR
THAT AND SO WE CAN'T CHANGE THIS
PART OF OUR CODE OR IT JUST
MAKES IT TAKE LONGER. COST MORE
AND CONTINUE TO EXPOSE OUR
CONSTITUENTS TO PRIVACY
CONCERNS.
AND MY HOPE WAS THAT THE LAST
FOUR DIGITS WE'RE GOING TO BE
REQUIRED.
.
YOU CAN EVEN WONDER IF ANY SO
SECURITY INFORMATION AS I RECALL
WAS NECESSARY BECAUSE.
THIS IS WHERE THAT THE DATA IS
ARE ARE AND SO WE WE NEED TO
HAVE SOME.
SO SECURITY NUMBER TIED BUT
USING THE FULL NUMBER AND AND.
ENABLING.
I ET DE TO CONTINUE ITS PROBLEMS
IS I THINK OF THE FLAW HERE.
AND.
I STILL VERY STRONGLY ENCOURAGE
MAKING THAT CHANGE.
AND A EITHER LOOKING FOR OTHER
IDENTIFIERS.
OR OR IT'S A MUCH BETTER USE OF
TIME AND MONEY TO TRY TO DEVELOP
THOSE IDENTIFIERS INSTEAD OF
BASICALLY LOCKING US EVEN
FURTHER INTO E. D. D.'S
ANTIQUATED. AND.
VERY COSTLY AND UNHELPFUL
SYSTEM
SO WITH THAT LOVE LOVE THE GOAL
CONTINUE TO VERY MUCH RESPECT
THE CHAIR FOR HAVING THE RIGHT
PRIORITIES FOR HOW WE CAN HAVE
ACCOUNTABILITY. BUT AM.
VERY MUCH WHICH WE HAVE A
DIFFERENT WAY OF DOING IT AND
AND I HOPE WE DON'T MISS THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO.
WITH THAT AT THIS WAS MOVED BY
MISTER LOW WE NEED A SECOND.
SECOND I MISTER ARAMBULA. THIS
IS DUE PASSED TO PREPARATIONS
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER
CHAIR FORGOT ABOUT THAT PART
YEAH THANK YOU.
THEM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MEDINA. MEDINA I BAKER NOW BAKER
NO ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM.
BLOOM I SAW THIS.
IRWIN.
KILEY.
KILEY AYE LEVINE. LEVINE AYE
LOW.
LOW AYE PATTERSON.
QUIRK SILVA.
SANTIAGO.
WEBER.
WEBER I.
SEVEN ONE BILL IS OUT WILL BE
HELD OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS AND
IF.
YOU ARE GAME I THINK WE CAN DO.
WE. MET WE CAN GO AND FILE ORDER
I THINK DO IT WE'VE COMPLETED
THE FILE.
IF WE WANNA GO AHEAD AND GO TO
ITEM NUMBER ONE TO ADD ON
MEMBERS.
AND DO WITH ITEMS THAT ARE ON
CALL. I MEMBER ONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY SIX.
BLOOM.
BLOOM I LOW.
LOW AYE SANTIAGO.
TWELVE WHEN THAT BILL IS OUT
WILL CONTINUE HOLD IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM NUMBER TWO
YOU AB TWENTY FORTY NINE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. AROUND.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM.
BLOOM I.
IRWIN.
LOW.
LOW AYE PATTERSON.
QUIRK SILVA.
SEVEN THREE THAT BILL IS OUT
WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS ITEM THREE A. B..
TWO ONE SIX SIX.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM.
BLOOM I IRWIN.
LOW.
LOW AYE QUIRK SILVA.
ELEVEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER THREE IS
OUT WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM NUMBER FOUR
AB TWENTY TO GO TO PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM.
BLOOM I CHAVEZ.
KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING.
LOW. LOW AYE.
SANTIAGO.
WEBER.
WEBER I.
TEN ZERO THAT IS OUT ITEM NUMBER
FOUR IS OUT AND WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY TO
FORTY EIGHT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ARAMBULA PATTERSON.
QUIRK SILVA.
SANTIAGO.
WEBER.
WEBER I.
I AM NUMBER FIVE TEN ZERO IS OUT
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM NUMBER SIX
AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY FIVE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM.
BLOOM I.
CHAVEZ
CHAVEZ I LOW.
LOW AYE.
AND AND I WANT TO CHANGE MY VOTE
FROM I CANNOT VOTING PLEASE.
ON. IRWIN I TO NOT VOTING.
ITEM NUMBER SIX.
SO THAT MAKES IT TWELVE THERE
TWELVE ZERO IS OUT WILL HOLD IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN AB TWO FOUR SEVEN
NINE BY A. MR VOEPEL PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM I SHOT THIS
SHUDDERS I KILEY.
KILEY AYE LOW. LOW AYE SANTIAGO.
WEBER.
WEBER I.
S. TWELVE ZERO I AM NUMBER SEVEN
IS OUT WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT AB TWO FIVE NINE SEVEN.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL BLOOM.
BLOOM I LOW. LOW AYE SANTIAGO.
AND MEMORY
THAT SAID.
I MEMORIES OUT TWELVE ZERO WILL
HOLD WILL OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS ITEM NUMBER NINE.
AB TWO SIX SIX SIX PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
CHAVEZ.
CHAVEZ NO IRWIN.
IRWIN I.
PATTERSON.
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO.
NINE TWO THAT WENT OUT ITEM
NUMBER.
NINE A. WILL HOLD OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM NUMBER TEN
AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN ONE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. BLOOM.
BLOOM I.
LOW LOW AYE PATTERSON SANTIAGO.
TEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER TEN IS OUT
WILL HOLD OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. ITEM NUMBER. TWELVE AB
TWO EIGHT ONE NINE. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I.
IRWIN.
IRWIN I.
PATTERSON.
SANTIAGO.
A THREE THAT'S OUT ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN AB TWO EIGHT THREE SIX.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AROUND.
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM.
BLOOM I SHOT THIS.
CHVEZ I KILEY.
KILEY AYE LOW LOW AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
THAT WENT OUT THIRTEEN ZERO WE
WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS AND HEADING TO ITEM
FIFTEEN A. B.. THREE ONE FIVE
THREE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM I CHAVEZ
CHAVEZ I LOW. LOW AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
THIRTEEN ZERO THAT ITEM IS OUT
WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS AND WE HAVE ITEMS
FOURTEEN. AB TWO EIGHT NINE FOUR
AND I AM SIXTEEN AB THREE TWO
FIVE FIVE KIDS FOR CONSENT WHEN
ANY MEMBER LIKE PULL AND I AM
FROM CONSENT.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
WE HAVE. MOVED AND SECONDED
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL CONSENT.
BAKER AYE BAKER AYE ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM I CHAVEZ SCHABAS AYE LOW.
LOW AYE.
THIRTEEN ZERO ITEMS ON CONSENT
OUT WILL HOLD OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
WAIT A MOMENT OR TWO TO.
GET A FEW MORE COLLEAGUES.
AND DO ONE MORE RUN THROUGH.
ARE AMONG.
GREAT.
YEAH.
YEAH ONE AROUND
NO WAIT I DON'T ANALYZE A BILL.
YEAH.
BOB.
NNAMDI PEOPLE WORKING ON.
GOING TO GO.
THE SECOND MEMBER.
IF YOU.
YOU'RE EXACTLY WHERE.
WE ARE WE WILL READ.
LIKE YOU SAID TRANSPORTATION. I
WAS LIKE.
IT'S ALREADY.
THIRTY.
THE DOW JONES
WE DID TRY
.
THAT THE ITEM ONE.
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY SIX
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
AB SEVENTY. SIX THIRTEEN
THIRTEEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT.
I DON'T TWO AB TWENTY FORTY
NINE.
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE PATTERSON.
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE.
I AM TO AB TWENTY FORTY NINE.
NINE THREE THE BILL IS OUT.
ITEM THREE AB TWO ONE SIX SIX
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA HIGH.
ITEM THREE AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY
SIX THIRTEEN ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT.
ITEM FOR AB TWENTY TWO OH TO.
CHAVEZ.
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
I DON'T FOR AB TWENTY TWO OH TWO
ELEVEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT.
ITEM FIVE EIGHTY TWENTY TO FORTY
EIGHT. PATTERSON.
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
AB TWENTY TO FORTY EIGHT TWELVE
ZERO THE BILL IS OUT.
ITEM SEVEN AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY NINE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
AYE.
AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY NINE
THIRTEEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT.
ITEM EIGHT. AB TWENTY FIVE
NINETY SEVEN SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY SEVEN.
THIRTEEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT.
ITEM NINE AB TWO SIX SIX SIX.
PATTERSON.
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
A V. TWENTY SIX
SIX
TEND TO
THE BILL IS OUT.
ITEM TEN A. B. TWO SEVEN SEVEN
ONE.
PATTERSON SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
AB TWENTY SEVEN SEVEN B. ONE
ELEVEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT.
ITEM TWELVE AB TWENTY EIGHT
NINETEEN.
PATTERSON SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
THE TWENTY EIGHT NINETEEN.
NINE THREE THE BILL IS OUT.
ITEM THIRTEEN AB TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY SIX.
TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY SIX THIRTEEN
ZERO THE BILL IS OUT.
GOOD.
THANK YOU.
ROGER